GOOD MORNING EVERYONE.
THE MORNING WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD
AND WELCOME TO THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE AUDIT COMMITTEE THIS
IS A COMMITTEE SECOND HEARING
THIS SESSION OF WHICH WE WILL
HEAR NEW AUDIT REQUESTS.
LOOK FORWARD TO A PRODUCTIVE
HEARING TODAY I WOULD LIKE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE WELCOME OUR NEWEST
COMMITTEE MEMBER.
SENATOR GONZALEZ THANK YOU FOR
BEING WITH US.
ALSO LIKE TO THINK AS SENATOR
DRAWS A FOR HER TIME AND HER
SERVICE ON THE THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE AUDIT COMMITTEE --
NOW THAT WE HAVE A QUORUM MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SALAS PRESENT
[inaudible]
BOERNER HORVATH [inaudible]
DEEP [inaudible]
YOUR PATTERSON [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
VOEPEL [inaudible]
WHAT?
SENATOR ROTH HERE [inaudible]
MORE JUST [inaudible]
GONZALEZ [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
MORNING [inaudible]
MORE LACK [inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
OKAY.
WHAT THAT WE'VE ESTABLISHED
QUORUM -- NEXT WE WILL MOVE.
TO MEMBERS WE HAVE THREE ITEMS
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
UNDER AGENDA ITEM NUMBER TWO
THERE ONE TWO AND NUMBER THREE
TWENTY NINETEEN DASH ONE ONE ONE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT MOBILE
HOME PARK INSPECTIONS BY SENATOR
LEYVA -- NUMBER TWO TWENTY
NINETEEN DASH ONE TWELVE
CALIFORNIA STATE LOTTERY BY
SENATOR CHIANG.
NUMBER THREE TWENTY NINETEEN
DASH ONE NINETEEN LANGEVIN PETER
SHORT ACT IMPLEMENTATION BY
SENATOR STERN.
IF I COULD HAVE A MOTION ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR [inaudible]
IT'S BEEN.
YEAH AND AS WE DO THAT -- JUST
FOR THE RECORD WE ARE WAVING.
RULES THIRTEEN AND FIFTEEN SO
SPENDING RULE THIRTEEN WILL
ALLOW THE STATE AUDITOR'S
ANALYSIS TO BE PUBLICLY RELEASED.
SUSPENDING ROLE FIFTEEN WILL
ALLOW THE COMMITTEE TO WAIVE
DISCUSSION ON THE OTHER REQUEST.
AN ANALYSIS TAKEN ON ACTION FOR
THE CONSENT CALENDAR ITEMS.
WITH THAT.
THAT MOTION A AGREED WITH BY
SENATOR ROTH.
IT'S BEEN SECOND IN BY -- MISS
RUBY ARE MISSED BURNER **** BATH
I THINK I HEARD IT FOR BOTH OF
THEM -- A CIRCULAR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO WAIVE COMMITTEE
RULES THIRTEEN AND FIFTEEN IN
ORDER TO TAKE UP THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS
[inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
HI I SALAS AYE.
BOERNER HORVATH.
BURGER MORE ABOUT I DEEP.
DEEP I PATTERSON.
RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE VOEPEL.
VOEPEL I WOULD [inaudible]
SENATOR ROCK.
ROTH AYE FORGES.
GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG.
MORNING.
MONNING AYE MOORLACH
[inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
YOUR AYE.
OKAY MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR THAT.
WE'VE NOW SUSPENDED RULES
THIRTEEN AND FIFTEEN WE WILL NOW
VOTE ON THE PROPOSED CONSENT
CALENDAR -- MISS SEXUALLY CALL
THE ROLL.
I BELIEVE WE NEED ANOTHER MOTION
AND A SECOND.
BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED.
THE MOTION IS TO APPROVE THE
pFOLLOWING AUDIT REQUESTS
200-019-1112 PART OF HOUSING
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT MOBILE.
HOME PARK INSPECTIONS BY SENATOR
LEYVA. TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN ONE
TWELVE CALIFORNIA STATE LOTTERY
BY SENATOR CHIANG. TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN ONE ONE NINE LANCEMENT
PEACHTREE SHORT ACT
IMPLEMENTATION SENATOR STERN.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS.
SALAS AYE BOERNER HORVATH.
THERE WERE ABOUT HI DEEP.
DEEP HI PATTERSON.
RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE VOEPEL.
VOEPEL I WOULD [inaudible]
SENATOR ROTH.
ROTH AYE FORGES.
ORIGINS AYE GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ HI HERTZBERG.
MORNING.
MONNING AYE MOORLACH
[inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
WIENER AYE.
OKAY THAT PASSES -- WILL HOLD
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS --
WITH THAT NO WILL NOW MOVE TO
THE STATUS REPORT FROM OUR STATE
AUDITOR MISS LA HOUSE.
THAT'S HOW PLEASE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS FOR THE RECORD MY
NAME'S ELAINE HELL IN CALIFORNIA
STATE AUDITOR -- STATUS REPORT
WE CURRENTLY HAVE TWELVE AUDITS
THAT WERE APPROVED BY THIS
COMMITTEE -- AIR THE PREVIOUS
COMMITTEE IN AUGUST OF LAST YEAR
BUT PRIMARILY THE OBVIOUS THAT --
ARTISTS THAT WERE APPROVED THIS.
THIS PAST MARCH -- THE MOST
RECENT AUDIT WE COMMENCED AS THE
AUDIT OF SEX CITY UNIFIED AS A
COMMITTEE DIRECTED US TO DO WE
WAITED UNTIL LATE MAY EARLY JUNE
TO COMMENCE THAT ON IT BUT ALL
OF THE WORK.
THAT HAS BEEN APPROVED BY THIS
COMMITTEE IS UNDER WAY -- THAT'S
TWELVE AUDITS WE ALSO HAVE A
STATUTORY AUDIT THAT WE'VE BEEN
WORKING ON WITH RESPECT TO THE
STATE'S FINANCIAL STATEMENTS --
THAT ON IT SHOULD BE COMPLETED
WITHIN THE NEXT FEW WEEKS -- AS
AS YOU CAN SEE THE AGENDA TODAY
HAD EIGHT ITEMS WITH THE CONSENT
CALENDAR BEING APPROVED -- THERE
WILL BE FIVE REMAINING ITEMS TO
BE HEARD BY THE COMMITTEE MY
STAFF RESOURCES AT THIS POINT
FOR JULY AND AUGUST SINCE IT'S
THE END OF JUNE WE ESTIMATED HOW
MANY AUDITS WE CAN START BETWEEN
NOW AND THE END OF AUGUST.
WE CAN START SIX AUDITS
ESSENTIALLY HAVE STAFF AVAILABLE
IMMEDIATELY TO START MOST OF
THOSE AUDITS -- IN ADDITION AS
THE COMMITTEE IS AWARE THERE
WILL BE ONE MORE COMMITTEE
HEARING -- TOWARDS THE END OF
AUGUST TOWARDS THE END OF
SESSION THIS YEAR ARE AT THIS
POINT WE'RE ESTIMATING WE WOULD
BE ABLE TO START AN ADDITIONAL
NINE AUDIT SO I WILL HAVE MORE
TEAMS FREEING UP.
OVER THE COURSE OF THE NEXT
SEVERAL MONTHS AS WE RELEASE
AUDIT REPORTS SO JUST WANTED TO
GIVE THE COMMITTEE SOME CONTEXT
SINCE WE CAN START SIX AUDITORY
COURSE FOR THE NEXT TWO MONTHS.
IF THE COMMITTEE DECIDES TO
PROVE MORE THAN SIX I WILL START
THOSE AUDIT AS STAFF FREE UP BUT
THAT WILL STILL ALLOW FOR
ADDITIONAL LOT IT'S TO BE
APPROVED BY THIS COMMITTEE AT
THE AUGUST HEARING.
I'M ALSO JUST FOR MEMBERS
INFORMATION ARE PART OF THE
REASON WE DON'T HAVE QUITE AS
MANY REESE SOURCES AVAILABLE
THIS YEAR TYPICALLY WE HAVE MORE
RESOURCES AVAILABLE FOR AN
AUGUST HEARING.
A COUPLE OF THINGS ONE IS
REDISTRICTING -- AS I MENTIONED
IN THE PAST WERE RESPONSIBLE FOR
CREATING THE NEW CITIZENS
REDISTRICTING COMMISSION -- WE
HAD TO DRAW THREE NAMES TO
ASSIGN STAFF AS OUR APPLICANT
REVIEW PANEL.
THOSE INDIVIDUALS HAVE TO BE
AUDITOR'S WITH THE OFFICE WITH A
MINIMUM OF TEN YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE SO THAT MEANS I LOSE
MANAGEMENT FOLKS AND WE PULLED
THAT PANEL.
THEY WILL BE COMMENCING THEIR
WORK NEXT MONTH BUT WE'RE GONNA
GET THEM AND SOME TRAINING SO I
LOST ONE SUPERVISOR ACTUALLY
LOST A DEPUTY WHICH HAD A RIPPLE
EFFECT SO I HAD TO MOVE SOME
PEOPLE UP.
INTO ACTING POSITIONS ARE SO A
LITTLE BIT OF A HIT IT'S TYPICAL
HAPPENS EVERY TEN YEARS BUT I
JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THE
COMMITTEE WAS AWARE OF THAT.
THE OTHER -- REAP RESOURCE --
NOT I WANNA SAY CONSTRAINT BUT
WE HAVE SOME STATUTORY ON IT'S
WE ARE ALSO RESPONSIBLE FOR
CONDUCTING ONE WE DO EVERY YEAR.
IT'S OF CONTRACTING PRACTICES
PROCUREMENT PRACTICES BY IN THE
JUDICIAL BRANCH ON ONE YEAR IT'S
FIVE JUDICIAL ENTITIES ON THE
OPPOSITE YEAR WHICH IS THIS YEAR.
OR REQUIRED TO GO IN AND AUDIT
JUDICIAL COUNCIL THEMSELVES
FORMERLY REFERRED TO AS A SEE SO
WILL BE CONDUCTING THAT OUT WE
HAVE TO START THAT ON IN JULY.
BUT WE ALSO HAVE TWO NEW
STATUTORY AUDITS THAT WE HAVE
NOT BEEN RESPONSIBLE FOR IN THE
PAST ONE IS RELATED TO PROP
FIFTY SIX WHICH WAS THE TOBACCO
TAX INITIATIVE.
THAT REQUIRED MY OFFICE TO DRAFT
REGULATIONS TO DEFINE WHAT
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS WOULD BE
THERE ARE A VARIETY OF DIFFERENT
STATE AGENCIES THAT RECEIVE SOME
OF THOSE FUNDS. TO ADMINISTER
VARIOUS PROGRAMS -- IT VARIES
FROM UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA GET
SOME MONEY FOR RESEARCH --
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION GETS
MONEY FOR PREVENTION EDUCATING
STUDENTS AND CERTAINLY
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES DEPARTMENT PUBLIC
HEALTH RISK RECEIVES FUN SO
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO PUT A TEAM
TOGETHER TO CONDUCT SOME AUDIT
WORK.
WITH RESPECT TO TO THE USE OF
THOSE FUNDS AND PARTICULARLY
LOOKING AT ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS
BUT THE STATUTE OR THE
INITIATIVE ACTUALLY REQUIRES US
TO CONDUCT A FINANCIAL AUDIT AND
AND ACTUALLY DO SOME PERFORMANCE
ART WORK AS WELL SO.
WE WILL BE ASSIGNING A TEAM TO
THAT.
THE OTHER AUDIT THAT WE HAVE TO
COMMENCE -- IS RELATED TO A
STATUTE NOW I HAVE TO READ IT
NATIVE AMERICAN GRAVES
PROTECTION AND REPATRIATION ACT --
THIS IS SOME RESPONSIBILITY AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF HAS THEY HAD
TO COME UP WITH SOME POLICIES
AND PROCEDURES THERE SOME THINGS
THEY HAD TO PUT INTO PLACE THIS
YEAR.
WE ARE REQUIRED TO COMMENCE AN
AUDIT AND TWENTY NINETEEN AND A
SECOND AUDIT AND TWENTY TWENTY
ONE SO AGAIN WE WE KNOW THAT
WE'VE GOT TO DEDICATE AT LEAST
ONE TEAM SOME RESOURCES TO THAT
WORK.
WE INTEND TO COMMENCE THAT WORK
PROBABLY IN THE NEXT FEW MONTHS.
BUT JUST FOR THE COMMITTEES
INFORMATION JUST WANTED YOU TO
UNDERSTAND THE NATURE OF SOME OF
THE RESOURCES AND WHY WE'RE
HAVING TO DEDICATE SOME OF THOSE
TWO THAT STATUTORY WORKING
CERTAINLY REDISTRICTING.
BUT EVEN GIVEN THAT AS I SAID WE
HAVE RESOURCES AVAILABLE TO
START SIX AUDITS.
WITHIN THE NEXT TWO MONTHS IN
JULY AND AUGUST AND THEN WE'LL
HAVE ANOTHER NINE TEAMS
AVAILABLE FOR EITHER ADDITIONAL
ARTISTS THAT ARE PROOF TODAY OR
AUDITS THAT APPROVED AT THE
AUGUST HEARING.
WITH THAT MISTER CHAIR -- BE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS MEMBERS MAY HAVE THANK
YOU THANK YOU APPRECIATE THAT IN
THE UPDATE ON THE CONTINUING --
WORKED THAT THAN REPORTS THAT WE
SHOULD EXPECT WITH THAT LET ME
ASK THERE'S ANY QUESTIONS ON THE
STATUS REPORT.
BY THE STATE AUDITOR FROM ANY
MEMBERS OF THE DíAS.
HEARING AND SEEING NONE WE WILL
MOVE INTO TODAY'S -- REGULAR
CALENDAR.
I BELIEVE -- SENATOR WIENER HAD
ASKED -- TO PRESENT FIRST WILL
HONOR THAT REQUEST -- CENTER
WIENER IF YOU'D LIKE TO BEGIN.
SO MEMBERS WE'RE STARTING WITH
THE REGULAR CALENDAR IT'S NUMBER
EIGHT TWENTY NINETEEN DASH ONE
ONE EIGHT CALIFORNIA LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES AUTOMATED
LICENSE PLATE READERS -- SENATOR
WINNER WHEN YOU'RE READY TO
BEGIN.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH I MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND THANK YOU FOR
ACCOMMODATING THE SCHEDULE ONE
OF OUR WITNESSES BY ALLOWING US
TO GO FOR A SWIM PRECIADO -- TO
COLLEAGUES -- THIS -- AUDIT
REQUESTS FOCUSES ON HOW DATA IS
COLLECTED AND STORED BY PUBLIC
AGENCIES THROUGH THE USE OF
AUTOMATED LICENSE PLATE READERS.
COMMONLY KNOWN AS A L. P. R..
LPARS SOPHISTICATED COMBINATION
OF CAMERAS VISUAL PROCESSING
SOFTWARE ANALYTICS TOOLS
INSURABLE DATABASES.
IT AUTO DETECTS LICENSE PLATE
NUMBERS ON CARS THAT PASS A
GIVEN LOCATION -- FOR EXAMPLE A
CAMERA ATTACHED TO A LIGHT POSTS
ON A ON A PUBLIC STREET.
TRANSLATES -- THAT DATA INTO A
FILE OF LETTERS AND NUMBERS
ACCOMPANIED BY THE DATE TIME.
AND LOCATION -- WHERE THE
LICENSE PLATE WAS CAPTURED AND
IT CREATES?
AN ENTRY IN A DATABASE -- THESE
DATABASES HAVE BILLIONS OF
POINTS -- LPARS USED BY
TRANSPORTATION AGENCIES FOR
PARKING ENFORCEMENT OF AS WELL
AS BY LAW ENFORCEMENT TO ENHANCE
INVESTIGATIONS BY TRACKING THE
LOCATIONS OF CARS.
THAT MAY BE RELEVANT TO AN
INVESTIGATION -- WHEN USED
APPROPRIATELY THE STATE -- CAN
BE VERY USEFUL TO PUBLIC
AGENCIES.
BY EFFICIENTLY AND FORCING
PARKING AND OTHER RULES -- OR
SHARING DATA ACROSS
JURISDICTIONS -- ONE HI WHEN A A
CRIME HAS BEEN COMMITTED.
HOWEVER WHEN MISUSED -- THIS
DATA AND THE POWERFUL ANALYTICS
SOFTWARE THAT A COMPANY IT.
CAN BE USED AS A TOOL OF MASS
SURVEILLANCE.
AGENCIES WITH ROBUST LPR
NETWORKS -- CAN USE ANALYTICS TO
KNOW DRIVING HABITS AND PROJECTS
WHERE A CAR WILL BE LOCATED AT A
GIVEN POINT IN TIME -- THE TOOLS
BUILT FOR LPR ARE DESIGNED TO
STORE AND NOT TO DELETE DATA ON
PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT IMPLICATED IN
ANY CRIME OR VIOLATION OF THE
LAW.
AND THE THAN THEIR SHARE OF
BILLIONS OF THE STORED DATA
POINTS ACROSS AGENCIES WITHOUT
ACCOUNTABILITY TO THE PUBLIC
ABOUT WHERE IT'S BEING SHARED.
INDEED THERE ARE ALREADY KNOWN
EXAMPLES OF THIS TECHNOLOGY
BEING USED TO TRACK PEOPLE.
IN OUR IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES AND
IT IS KNOWN THAT MILLIONS OF
THESE DATA POINTS HAVE BEEN
SHARED IN THE PAST.
WITH ICE -- THERE THEN USE OF
THE FEDERAL IMMIGRATION
ENFORCEMENT CAN PREDICT WHERE A
FAMILY OR INDIVIDUAL WILL BE.
AT ANY GIVEN POINT IN TIME.
GIVEN THEIR PAST DRIVING HABITS.
IN -- TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN OUR
COLLEAGUE SENATOR JERRY HILL --
AUTHORED IMPASSE SENATE BILL
THIRTY FOUR WHICH ESTABLISH
REASONABLE REGULATIONS FOR DATA
COLLECTED THROUGH THIS
RELATIVELY NEW TECHNOLOGY.
THE REQUIREMENTS AND SB THIRTY
FOUR FOR NOW THE LAW DO NOT BAN
LPR INSTEAD THEY REQUIRE THEM
PUBLIC AGENCIES USE LPR.
THEY FOLLOW STANDARDS TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC KNOWS THAT IT'S
BEING USED IN A JURISDICTION --
AND HOW IT'S BEING USED AND
STORED FOR EXAMPLE THERE ARE
REQUIREMENTS FOR AN AGENCY TO
HAVE A PUBLIC HEARING BEFORE
PROCURING A CONTRACT FOR THIS
TECHNOLOGY -- AND REQUIREMENTS
TO PUBLISH WHAT THE POLICIES ARE --
FOR STORING AND SHARING THAT
DATA.
UNFORTUNATELY RECENT RECENT
ENQUIRIES -- INITIATED BY THE
ELECTRONIC FRONTIER FOUNDATION
IN THAT YOU SEE ALL YOU HAVE ON
COVER THEM -- VARIOUS LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES.
THAT USE LPR HAVE NOT BEEN
FOLLOWING -- THE LAW.
I HAVE NOT BEEN HAVING HEARINGS
ARE REQUIRED TO HAVE OR
PUBLISHING POLICIES.
ADDITIONALLY THERE ARE OTHER
SITUATIONS WHERE AN AGENCY HAS
ADOPTED A POLICY ON PAPER --
WHEN THE AGENCY MERELY COPIED
AND PASTED A BOILER PLATE
ORDINANCE FROM A COMPANY CALLED
LEXICAL WHICH IS IN THE INDUSTRY?
BOB MOST OF THESE AGENCIES OR
MANY OF THEM ARE NOT FOLLOWING
THEIR OWN POLICIES.
LIKELY BECAUSE THEY DON'T EVEN
KNOW WHAT THESE BOILER PLATE
POLICIES CONTAIN.
THE GOALS OF THE AUDIT TODAY ARE
TO BETTER UNDERSTAND THE DEGREE
TO WHICH LPR IS BEING USED BY
CALIFORNIA LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES.
AND THEIR WHICH VENDORS -- TO DO
A DEEP DIVE ON FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES THAT USE
THE TECHNOLOGY.
IN ORDER TO ASSESS COMPLIANCE
WITH THE REQUIREMENTS OF SB
THIRTY FOUR PARTICULARLY
REGARDING DATA SHARING.
AND TO DEVELOP LEGISLATIVE
RECOMMENDATIONS IF THE IF NEEDED
TO SEE IF WE NEED TO UPDATE THE
LAW OR TIGHTEN IT UP -- I I
APPRECIATE -- THE STAFF WORKING
WITH US IN THE AUDITOR.
I DO WANT TO NOTE ARE -- FOR
CITIES AND COUNTIES THAT ON OR
INCLUDED -- IN THIS REQUEST --
WE WERE -- WE WERE ASKS. TO
SPECIFY THE FOUR CITIES BY THE
AUDITOR BY THE COMMITTEE ON
OTHERWISE FOR CITIES WOULD BE
RANDOMLY SELECTED -- WHICH MAY
NOT EVEN HAVE THE TECHNOLOGY --
AND SO WHAT WE TRIED TO DO IS
SELECT GEOGRAPHICALLY DIVERSE
CITIES WITH LARGE ON LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES SO THAT WE
COULD GET A MEANINGFUL A SAMPLE
OF WHAT'S GOING ON AROUND -- THE
STATE -- SO WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
AND WITH ME HERE -- TODAY ARE --
DE MáS A SENIOR INVESTIGATOR
WITH THE ELECTRONIC FRONTIER
FOUNDATION AND KEVIN BAKER --
WITH THE ACLU.
OKAY THANK YOU.
WE HAVE A MOTION WE HAVE A
SECOND WITH THAT WILL MOVE -- TO
YOU SAID YOU HAVE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF WAR HERE BRIEFLY FROM
WHAT THIS IS PART OF THE MOVE TO
THE STATE WATER.
PLEASE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE -- MY
NAME IS DAVE MáS IN A SENIOR
INVESTIGATIVE RESEARCHER AT THE
ELECTRONIC FRONTIER FOUNDATION.
WHEN ALL THE SLEEVE THE CAPITAL
TODAY AND GET IN OUR CARS TO GO
HOME WE WILL BE TRACKED
USING AUTOMATED LICENSE PLATE
READERS ALSO KNOWN AS A PR
POLICE WILL SCANNER LICENSE
PLATES TO DOCUMENT OUR LOCATION.
TO GIVE AN IDEA OF THE SCALE IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN TO TWENTY
SEVENTEEN DRIVERS AS SACRAMENTO
HAD THEIR PLATE SCANNED A
HUNDRED AND NINETY FIVE MILLION
TIMES BY POLICE AND SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENTS.
THAT'S NEARLY TWO HUNDRED
SEVENTY THOUSAND SCANS PER DAY.
THAT DATA WAS UPLOADED TO THE
CLOUD WHERE BECAME SEARCHABLE BY
MORE THAN EIGHT HUNDRED AGENCIES
AROUND THE COUNTRY FROM POLICE
IN RURAL GEORGIA TO THE US
BORDER PATROL.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF THE STATE
OF BELONGS TO PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT
AND NEVER WILL BE CONNECTED TO A
CRIINAL INVESTIGATION.
THESE NUMBERS ARE NOT UNIQUE
MASS ALE PR COLLECTION IS GOING
ON ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
AND YOU MAY WELL ASK HOW IS THIS
DATA WHICH REVEALS ARE SENSITIVE
DRIVING PATTERNS PROTECTED AND
CONTROLLED.
A YOU WON'T LIKE THE ANSWER.
IN TWENTY FIFTEEN THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE PASSED SB THIRTY
FOUR A FAIRLY BASIC LIST
REGULATIONS THAT INCLUDES
IMPLEMENTING A USAGE POLICY THE
PROTECT CIVIL LIBERTIES AND
PRIVACY.
IN ANALYZING RECORDS FROM
AGENCIES AROUND THE STATE WE
HAVE DETERMINED AGENCIES ARE
OFTEN FLOODING FLOODING THIS LAW.
SOME HAVE BEEN PROMULGATED
POLICIES OR IF THEY HAVE THEY
ARE FOLLOWING THEM.
MANY ARE CONDUCTING AUDITS WE'RE
KEEPING THE REQUIRED LOGS OF
WHEN THE DATA IS SEARCHED OR
SHARED.
WHETHER YOU BELIEVE LPARS USEFUL
PUBLIC SAFETY TO OR NOT ONE MUST
RECOGNIZE THE NEED TO ENSURE
THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT ARE ACTING
AS RESPONSIBLE STEWARDS OF OUR
CONFIDENTIAL LOCATIONAL DATA.
AT NEW LEGISLATION MAY VERY WELL
BE IN ORDER BUT BEFORE WE CAN
GET THERE WE NEED TO MEASURE THE
SCOPE OF THE PROBLEM.
THAT IS WHAT YET THAT SUPPORTS
AN IMPARTIAL STATE AUDIT AND WE
URGE YOU TO MOVE THIS SOLID
FORWARD FOR THE SAKE OF EVERY
DRIVER IN THIS ROOM AND EVERY
DRIVER IN CALIFORNIA.
PLEASE PROCEED GOING TO TURN
MEMBERS KEVIN BAKER FOR THE
AMERICAN CIVIL LIBERTIES UNION
OF CALIFORNIA WE REVEAL THE USE
OF THIS TECHNOLOGY BY LIFE'S
THROUGH PUBLIC INFORMATION OR
REQUEST -- THE SENDER WIENER
ALLUDED TO LEGISLATURE HAS
RECOGNIZED THAT THIS IS POWERFUL
TECHNOLOGY IT HAS ADOPTED
STANDARDS FOR MINIMUM STANDARDS
AT LEAST FOR USE.
I THINK THE ANECDOTAL EVIDENCE
AT THIS POINT SUGGESTED THERE
ARE SERIOUS QUESTIONS ABOUT
COMPLIANCE UNFORTUNATELY I THINK
THAT ARISES WHEN YOU HAVE A
STATUTE THAT DOESN'T HAVE A
ROBUST ENFORCEMENT MECHANISM --
SO I THINK IT'S APPROPRIATE THAT
THE COMMITTEE CONSIDER THIS
REQUEST AND LOOK AT THIS ISSUE
FURTHER THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT WITH THAT WILL GO
AHEAD AND MOVE TO THE STATE
AUDITOR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AS CENTER
WIENER INDICATED.
VERY FIRST OBJECTIVE IS REALLY
ASKING US TO TRY TO GET
STATEWIDE INFORMATION -- AND
JUST TO REMIND MEMBERS WE'VE
DONE ON ITS IN THE PAST WHERE WE
HAVE HAD TO SURVEY LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT WE RECENTLY DID AN
AN AUDIT ON HATE CRIME REPORTING
IN CALIFORNIA WHERE WE WERE ABLE
TO SURVEY.
OVER TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY LOCAL
ENTITIES IN SOME STATE ENTITY SO
THAT WOULD IN ALL LIKELIHOOD BE
THE APPROACH WE WOULD USE THIS
TO TO FIND OUT BECAUSE CENTER
WIENER IS IS INTERESTED IN HOW
MANY LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
ENTITIES ARE USING THIS.
TECHNOLOGY WHAT POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES DO THEY HAVE IN PLACE
SO WE WOULD INTEND TO DO A
SURVEY TO TRY TO CAPTURE THAT
INFORMATION AND THEN CERTAINLY
THE THE KEY OBJECTIVE IN IN THE
HONOR.
TO AUDIT REQUEST AND THE
ANALYSIS THAT WE'VE PREPARED IS
TO GO LOOKING AT THOSE FOR
PARTICULAR ENTITIES.
ACTUALLY THERE'S FIVE BECAUSE IN
SACRAMENTO WILL BE LOOKING AT
TWO SACRAMENTO COUNTY NEWS ALSO
ASKED US TO LOOK AT DEPARTMENT
HUMAN.
ASSISTANCE BUT ALSO LAPD FRESNO --
PD AND MARIN COUNTY SHERIFF AT
EACH OF THESE ENTITIES WE WILL
DRAW DOWN WE CERTAINLY WANT TO
KNOW WHAT THEIR POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES ARE COMPARING THOSE
TO THE STATUTORY REQUIREMENTS TO
MAKE SURE THEIR POLICIES AT
LEAST ALIGNED WITH.
THE STATUTORY REQUIREMENTS AND
THEN ALSO DETERMINE COMPLIANCE
ESSENTIALLY ARE THEY HOLDING
THOSE PUBLIC HEARINGS -- WHEN
NECESSARY ARE THEY SHARING
PUBLIC INFORMATION -- DO THEY
HAVE PROPER PROTOCOLS IN PLACE
TO PROTECT THE DATA -- AND IF
THEY DO ARE THEY FOLLOWING THOSE
PROTOCOL SO TAKING IT A STEP
FURTHER AND ACTUALLY TESTING ARE
HOW THEY ARE PROTECTING THE
INFORMATION.
IF THEY HAVE SOLD THEIR SHARE
THE INFORMATION ARE CAPTURING
THAT AND THAT.
SITUATION BUT ALSO UNDERSTANDING
WHO THEY SHARED IT WITH AND
AGAIN IS THAT IN COMPLIANCE WITH
STATE LAW WAS IT APPROPRIATE FOR
THEM -- THEIR RESPECTIVE ENTITY
TO SHARE THAT INFORMATION HE'S
ALSO ASKED US TO LOOK AT SOME OF
THE CONTRACTS WITH THE THIRD
PARTY VENDORS WHO PROVIDE THIS
TECHNOLOGY REALLY UNDERSTAND --
THE TERMS OF THAT ARE INCLUDED
IN THOSE CONTRACTS AND ARE THOSE
AGAIN IN IN THE BEST INTEREST OF
THE STATE AND AN ALLIANCE WITH.
STATE LAW AND THEN THE FINAL
OBJECTIVE IS REALLY LOOKING AT
STAT THE STATUTE AS IT EXISTS
TODAY AND BASED ON THE WORK THAT
WE DO COMING UP WITH SUGGESTED.
PERHAPS CHANGES OR MODIFICATIONS
TO EXISTING STATE LAW.
THE BUDGET FOR THE SIDE IS A
LITTLE OVER TWENTY EIGHT HUNDRED
HOURS THAT WOULD TAKE US ABOUT
SEVEN MONTHS -- WITH ONE TEAM
HOW WE MAY BE ABLE TO SPLIT IT
UP IN AND GO WITH TWO TEAMS
DEPENDING UPON HOW MANY AUDITS
ARE APPROVED -- BUT AGAIN WE
WOULD WE WOULD INTEND TO GO TO
ALL OF THOSE ENTITIES AND
CERTAINLY CONDUCT THAT STATEWIDE
SURVEY TO GET MORE GLOBAL
INFORMATION.
WITH THAT MISTER CHAIR ON I'LL
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS MEMBERS MAY
HAVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THINK FOR
PRESENTATIONS I'M GONNA MOVE --
TO THE AFFECTED AGENCIES I
INVITE ANY REPRESENTATIVES FROM
AFFECTED AGENCIES IS TABLE OUT
FROM DATA BY THEMSELVES.
THIS TIME WHEN WE ASK IF THERE
ARE ANY AFFECTED AGENCIES FOR
THE SOUGHT.
WE HAVE A COUPLE.
NGUYEN PLEASE PROVIDE SPACE
THANK YOU.
CIVIC PLEASE IDENTIFY YOURSELVES --
WHICH AFFECTED AGENCY OR WITHIN
A FEW COULD -- LIMIT CHORE COMES
TO TWO MINUTES.
THE FANTASY.
PLEASE IN THE MIKE.
STEPHEN CAST WITH FRESNO POLICE
DEPARTMENT.
GIL.
DE MORE SEE -- SIDE WHEN COUNTY
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT.
SURELY DAVIS DEPARTMENT OF HUMAN
ASSISTANCE OKAY IF YOU LIKE TO
BEGIN WITH YOUR COMMENTS PLEASE --
GOOD MORNING EVERYONE HE NOTED
WHO I WAS I AM THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF FINANCE
ADMINISTRATION.
AND I'M REPRESENTING SACRAMENTO
COUNTY -- DEPARTMENT OF HUMAN
ASSISTANCE.
INVESTIGATING AND PROSECUTING
WELFARE FRAUD.
IS THE RESPONSIBILITY OF THE
PROGRAM INTEGRITY DIVISION
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT OF HUMAN
ASSISTANCE.
AND ONE TAKEN SERIOUSLY TO
PREVENT WELFARE FRAUD. TO ENSURE
THAT THE DESERVING ELIGIBLE
CUSTOMERS IN OUR COMMUNITY
RECEIVE THE RESOURCES AND
BENEFITS THAT THEY NEED.
INVESTIGATIVE STAFF BEGAN.
USING THE AUTOMATED LICENSE
PLATE READER SYSTEM THE L. P. R..
IN JUNE OF TWENTY SIXTEEN AND
TERMINATED ITS USE EFFECTIVE
NOVEMBER FIRST.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE REASON THE
DEPARTMENT DISCONTINUED THIS
TECHNOLOGY WAS IT APPROVED TO
HAVE LIMITED UTILITY TO THE
INVESTIGATIVE STAFF.
WE DECIDED THAT BASED UPON THE
VERY LIMITED USE OF THE
TECHNOLOGY THAT WE COULD
ACCOMPLISH OUR MISSION TO DETECT
AND PREVENT FRAUD WITHOUT
MAINTAINING THE SERVICE SO
CONSEQUENTLY.
WE TERMINATED OUR CONTRACT AND
WE HAVE NOT USE THE SYSTEM IN
THE LAST YEAR.
OR SINCE LAST YEAR [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER SALAS
FOR OPPORTUNITY BEER TODAY --
LIKE I SAID PREVIOUSLY MONEY WAS
LIEUTENANT AND MORE SEE AND I'M
THE ASSISTANT COMMANDER.
OR DIVISION.
SO THE AUTOMATIC.
LICENSE PLATE READER PROGRAM
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS ALPERS ONE OF
THE MANY INVESTIGATIVE TOOLS
USED BY THE SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT.
LICENSE PLATE READERS ARE
ANOTHER EVOLUTIONARY STEP FOR
LAW ENFORCEMENT INVESTIGATIONS.
PREVIOUS STEPS INCLUDE THE USE
OF FINGERPRINTS RADIOS COMPUTERS
AND CARS.
WHICH ONE NOT EVEN THE THING
WHEN I WAS A PATROL -- DIGITAL
MAPS IN CAR CAMERAS AMBER ALERT
TEXT MESSAGES AND EVEN DNA.
TOOLS THAT ARE NOW REPRESENTED
IN EVERY MODERN TELEVISION CRIME
DRAMA WE'RE ONE SIGNIFICANT
ACCOMPLISHMENTS.
THE SECOND COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT INTRODUCED LICENSE
PLATE READERS AT THE END OF TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE SINCE THAT TIME
THE SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT
CONTINUE TO DEVELOP THE PROGRAM
POLICIES PROCEDURES. TO UTILIZE
LPARS WITH MUCH SUCCESS IN TERMS
OF ENFORCEMENT INVESTIGATIONS.
AS BURGER MATURE THE PERSONNEL
IN SYSTEMS WERE TRANSFERRED TO
THE FIELD SUPPORT DIVISION WHICH
IS A CENTRAL CLEARINGHOUSE FOR
ALL INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY IN
USER AUTHENTICATION.
ONCE SB THIRTY FOUR WAS ENACTED
THE SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT POLICY
NEEDED A FEW CHANGES TO COMPLY
WITH THE REQUIREMENTS BUT THAT
POLICY IS STILL REMAINS
ACCESSIBLE ON OUR PUBLIC.
FACING WEB PAGES BEEN THERE
SINCE APRIL EIGHTH OF TWENTY
SIXTEEN WE DO NOT USE LIKE
SUPPORT WE WROTE OURS BASED ON
BEST PRACTICES ACROSS THE NATION
AS WELL AS UNDERSTANDING THE THE
RULES AND AND RELATIONSHIP WITH
PRIVACY WITHIN LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THERE ME TIE SO PURE OPERATIONS
BY LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
AROUND THE COUNTRY.
WHEN THIS HEARING I'D LIKE TO
EXPLAIN HOW LP OR IS USED BY
PATROL OFFICERS INVEST IN
INVESTIGATORS? TO BEGIN A
LICENSE PLATE IS SIMPLY JUST
ANOTHER DATA POINT FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
BECAUSE IT IS A DATA POINT THE
ENTIRE LP OUR ROCESS WORKS TO
MAXIMIZE THE ACCURACY OF THE
SCANT IN LAYMAN'S TERMS THAT
MEANS INSTALLING THE CAMERAS IN
A MANNER THAT IDENTIFIES LICENSE
PLATES.
AND NOT THE SUBJECTS THAT ARE
DRIVING THE VEHICLE.
THIS IS VERY DIFFERENT FROM A
RED LIGHT CAMERA PROGRAM WHICH
THE INTENT IS TO LINK A DRIVER
TO A VEHICLE.
ONCE A PLAYER SCANNED THAT DATA
POINT IS THE PROPERTY OF THE
SACRAMENTO COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT.
AND VIGILANT SOLUTIONS ARE
CONTRACTED BETTER HOST OUT IN A
CRIMINAL.
JUSTICE INFORMATION SERVICE
COMPLIANCE REQUIREMENTS THAT
MEANS THE DATA STORE AN
ENVIRONMENT WHICH HAS VERIFIABLE
SECURITY MEASURES.
BECAUSE ART MY COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT APPROACHES LICENSE
PLATE AS ONLY A DATA POINT.
THE INVESTIGATIVE PROCESS NEED
THE USE LOOK UTILIZE THAT
INFORMATION STILL EXIST. FOR
EXAMPLE IF A DEPUTY RECEIVED AN
ALERT THE STORM PLATE THAT ALERT
THE CELL DOES NOT COST TO
PROBABLE CAUSE RESTED ISSUED A
VEHICLE STOP.
THE DEPUTY MUST MAKE SURE THAT
THE SCAMPI IS CORRECT.
BECAUSE A ZERO AND THE LETTER --
OR VERY -- EASILY IN ACTION --
MISTAKEN AND THEY LOOK VERY
SIMILAR TO THE COMPUTER.
THE DEPUTIES NEED TO MAKE SURE
LICENSE PLATE MATCHES THE MAKE
MODEL OF THE VEHICLE THIS
REPORTED AS STOLEN.
IS NOT UNCOMMON FOR THIEVES TO
ATTEMPT TO AVOID DETECTION BY
LAW ENFORCEMENT BY STEALING
OTHER PLATES.
FROM VEHICLES IN HOPES OF THE
OWNERS ARE NOT ALERT ENOUGH TO
RECOGNIZE TO CHANGE.
ONCE A PLATE SCANNERS CONFIRMED
THE MAKE AND MODEL OF THE
VEHICLE IS CONFIRM IT UP WE MUST
STILL VERIFY THAT THE STORE
NOTIFICATION IS STILL ACTIVE.
ONLY THEN CAN LAW ENFORCEMENT
ACTION OCCUR.
PEOPLE OFTEN GET STUCK ON THE
FACT THAT MILLIONS OF LICENSE
PLATE SCANS OCCUR BUT ONLY HAVE
THESE FEW NUMBER OF THEM WORSE
FLAG AT THE TIME OF THE SKIN
[inaudible]
PERSONALLY.
I BELIEVE THAT'S A GOOD THING.
IN HIS BOOK INTELLIGENCE LED
POLICING DR JERRY RADCLIFFE IN
CHAPTER THREE DISCUSSED HOW 6%
OF THE CRIMINAL POPULATION
ACCOUNT 460% OF THE CRIME CALLS
FOR SERVICE.
IDENTIFYING THOSE PROLIFIC
INVENTORS AND INTERRUPTING THEIR
ABILITY TO COMMIT ADDITIONAL
CRIMES HAS LESS TO DO WITH
TRYING TO SURVEIL THE MASSES
MORE TO DO WITH STOPPING THOSE
INDIVIDUALS.
WHO LOOK TO VICTIMIZE SEGMENTS
OF THE POPULATION?
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK
YOU.
PLEASE ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY SURE --
GOOD MORNING AGAIN I'M WITH THE
FRESNO POLICE DEPARTMENT.
THE FRESNO POLICE DEPARTMENT HAS
UTILIZED -- LICENSE PLATE READER
TECHNOLOGY FOR APPROXIMATELY
LAST DECADE -- MORE RECENTLY --
WE HAVE.
CHANGED PROVIDERS AND BEGIN
USING VIGILANCE LUCIEN'S THE
SAME COMPANY THAT -- WITHIN A
MORE SEE -- SPOKE ABOUT SO
REPEAT A LOT OF THE THE POINTS
HE MADE BECAUSE THEY'LL BE THE
SAME -- BUT WE WENT TO COUNCIL
IN APRIL OF TWENTY SIXTEEN FOR
APPROVAL -- FOR THE USE OF
LICENSE PLATE READER SERVICES
FROM VISUAL SOLUTIONS -- THAT
WAS APPROVED SO WE'VE BEEN USING
THEIR SERVICES SINCE APRIL
TWENTY SIXTEEN AND WE DEPLOYED
OUR FIRST -- VIGILANT SOLUTIONS
LICENSE PLATE READER VEHICLES --
IN -- I BELIEVE MAY OF TWENTY
SEVENTEEN SO WE STARTED WITH --
TO TWO VEHICLES AND WE ARE NOW
UP. TO EIGHT VEHICLES -- ONE
VEHICLE IN EACH FOR POLICING
DISTRICTS -- IS EQUIPPED WITH
LICENSE PLATE READER CAMERAS
UNMARKED POLICE CARS AND THEN WE
HAVE THREE UNMARKED CARS
ASSIGNED TO OUR AUTO THEFT TEAM --
THAT ARE ALSO EQUIPPED WITH THE
LP OUR CAMERAS -- I CAN TELL YOU --
YOU KNOW ANECDOTALLY OUR
OFFICERS AND INVESTIGATORS
ESPECIALLY.
LOVE THE SERVICE AND THE
INFORMATION -- THAT IT PROVIDES --
OUR INFORMATION THAT WE COLLECT
AS AN AGENCY IS -- CAP FOR ONE
YEAR UNLESS IT BECOMES PART OF
THE CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION --
AND AT THAT TIME IT'S PURGED
FROM THE SYSTEM SO WE HAVE
ACCESS TO OUR DATA -- THAT WE
COLLECT -- AS AN AGENCY I
BELIEVE THAT NUMBER IS AROUND --
IT'S IT'S NOT VERY HIGH BECAUSE
WE DON'T HAVE THAT MANY CAMERAS
BUT I BELIEVE IT'S FROM ONE
POINT EIGHT MILLION A YEAR --
WHAT WE CALL THE TEXANS -- OR
SCANS -- AND AND THEN IT'S
PURGED -- IN -- CONDUCTS WITHOUT
THAT WE DO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
LICENSE PLATE SCANS THAT ARE
COLLECTED BY VISUAL SOLUTIONS A
PRIVATE COMPANY -- SO WE HAVE
ACCESS TO THEIR NATION WIDE LPR
DATA.
SO WHAT THAT'LL OF FISH.
HI.
THANK YOU.
WE WE HAVE OUR FOURTH.
AGENCY AFFECTED IF YOU CAN
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME AND
AFFILIATION PLEASE A GOOD
MORNING MY NAME'S LIEUTENANT DAN
GOMEZ ON WITH THE LOS ANGELES
POLICE DEPARTMENT.
AND I OVERSEE THE LPR PROGRAM
FOR THE DEPARTMENT -- WE'RE
PROBABLY THE THE AC THAT HAD AT
ONE OF THE LONG AS WE START OUR
PROGRAM AS EARLY AS TWO THOUSAND
SIX AND WE'VE BEEN RUNNING IT --
CONCURRENTLY OF SINCE THAT TIME --
THE THE SYSTEM THAT WE HAVE ARE
NOT VIGILANT WE'VE HAD THE SAME
VENDOR THE ENTIRE TIME IT'S
COMPANY CALLED TIPS TECHNOLOGY.
WE DO NOT -- PUT ANY OF OUR DATA
INTO THE CLOUD TODAY EVERYTHING
IS HOUSE.
IN OUR OWN DATABASES WHICH IS A
C. JUST COMPLIANT DATABASES
WOULD RELEASE THE MENTION BY
ANOTHER ORGANIZATION -- WE FIND
THE INFORMATION COMPLETELY
VALUABLE FROM AN INVESTIGATIVE
STANDPOINT IT WAS FUNDED
COMPLETELY ALL OF OUR LPARS HAVE
BEEN FUNDED THROUGH THE URBAN
AREA SECURITY INITIATIVE -- SO
WE'VE HAD PUBLIC HEARINGS EVEN
PRIOR TO THE LOBBYING ENACTED WE
HAD PUBLIC HEARINGS BOTH ON ITS
PROCUREMENT AS WE EXPANDED INTO
SOME OF OUR COMMUNITIES --
THROUGH OTHER GRANTS -- THROUGH
OUR HOUSING AUTHORITY GRANTED WE
ALSO HAD PUBLIC HEARINGS BOTH IN
OUR HOUSING COMMUNITIES IN OTHER
AREAS THAT WERE AFFECTED AND
THIS IS AGAIN ALL PRIOR TO THE
LOBBYING -- IMPLEMENTED SO WE WE
FEEL COMFORTABLE IN THE PROCESS
AND MATTER IN WHICH WE'VE DONE
IT -- ALL THE CHIEFS AND I'VE OF
COURSE I GOT THROUGH A FEW CHIEF
SINCE I'VE BEEN THERE -- HAVE
BEEN SUPPORTER OF THE OF THE
PROGRAM AND WE CONTINUE TO
ENSURE THAT WE ABIDE BY BOTH THE
LAWS THAT ARE IN PLACE -- WE
PROTECT ALL THE DATA AS
INVESTIGATIVE DATA -- SO WE
DON'T RELEASE DATE -- WE EVEN AS
PART OF OUR IMPLEMENTATION
BECAUSE WE WERE SO EARLY.
WE WERE AHEAD OF THE MATURING OF
THE TECHNOLOGY IN THE SOFTWARE
SO WE DID PARTNER WITH A THIRD
PARTY VENDOR VENDOR TO HAVE AN
OVERLAY SOFTWARE.
THAT AT THAT TIME REQUIRED
PEOPLE TO ENTER IN WHY THEY WERE
SEARCHING IF IT WAS PART OF THE
CASE IT WOULD GIVE US AUDIT
ABILITY AND THAT AGAIN WAS PRIOR
TO THE LOBBYING -- IMPLEMENTED
AND WE STILL USE THAT PRACTICE
TODAY SO WITH THAT I I THINK THE
MEMBERS THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY.
THIS TIME LET'S GO TO MOVE TO
QUESTIONS ON THE DíAS AND WE
WILL BEGIN WITH SENATOR MINING.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR I WANT TO THANK.
THE SENATOR FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD.
APPRECIATE THE SERVICE OF ALL OF
THOSE HERE REPRESENTING AGENCIES
I THINK.
WHAT'S OFTEN STANDARD IN THESE --
AUDIT COMMITTEE HEARINGS THOSE
TO HEAR SOME.
DIRECT RESPONSE TO THE PROPOSED
BOUGHT IT IN I DIDN'T REALLY
HEAR THAT FROM MANY I THINK YOU
TALKED ABOUT YOUR USES -- IN
MAYBE SOME REFERENCE TO
COMPLIANCE BUT OFTEN WE HEAR
RESPONDENTS -- WELCOMING ON IT
TO HELP IMPROVE -- COMPLIANCE
WITH WITH STANDARDS.
SO I WOULD HOPE THERE WOULD BE
THAT OPENNESS SHOULD THE
COMMITTEE SUPPORT THIS AUDIT
THAT IT'S NOT.
AN INDICTMENT OF THE WORK YOU DO
IT'S REALLY.
A PARTNERSHIP TO TRY -- TO
EXAMINE SYSTEMS AND COME UP WITH
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT CAN BE
HELPFUL. FOR THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
PURPOSES OR THE PUBLIC PURPOSE
SERVICES THAT YOU PROVIDE SO
JUST KIND OF BE CLEAR HOW WE
WORK AS A COMMITTEE IT'S WERE
WERE NOT BRINGING YOU HERE TO
SAY GOTCHA IT'S WE WANT TO KNOW
HOW IS THIS WORKING.
HOW DO WE MAKE SURE IT'S IT'S
SUPPORTING ITS INTENDED --
PUBLIC SAFETY USE BUT AT THE
SAME TIME PROTECTING PROTECTING
THE PUBLIC INTEREST.
OF PROTECTING PRIVACY
INFORMATION SO ONE QUESTION
MAYBE FOR THE AUTHOR OR FOR
ANYONE WHO KNOWS.
I'M NOT FAMILIAR WITH THE
SPECIFICS SPECIFICS OF SB.
THIRTY FOUR IT DOES WHAT DOES IT
ALLOW IN THE WAY OF SHARING
COLLECTED DATA IF YOU KNOW.
YEAH AND I'M GONNA MAYBE ASK FOR
MR MOSS TO COME BACK UP.
AS WELL FOR GOOD [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THE BAND SCHERING UPPER PUTS
CONSTRAINTS ON IT SO.
YEAH SO THE LANGUAGE REGARDING
SHARING -- THAT -- PROHIBITS
FIRST ALL SHARING IT WITH THIRD
PARTIES SO NON GOVERNMENTAL
ENTITIES -- THE LANGUAGE DOES
SAY THATNEEDS TO BE SHARED ONLY
WITH PUBLIC AGENCIE DEFINED AS
AGENCIES WITH IN CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU AND THEN ONCE IT
SHARED SAY BETWEEN LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES THERE'S
POTENTIALLY A PUBLIC INTEREST IN
THAT BUT FOR THESE THIRD PARTY
VENDORS.
IN THESE CONTRACTS ARE THEY
PROHIBITED FROM SELLING THAT
INFORMATION TO COVER OTHER
COMMERCIAL INTERESTS THE COMPANY
ITSELF GENERALLY SAYS THAT THE
DATA BELONGS TO THE AGENCY AND
THAT IT IS NOT SHARED --
THERE'VE BEEN.
ELLIS ALLEGATIONS OVER THE PAST
THAT THAT DATA MAY HAVE BEEN
MAKING IT TO THE PRIVATE SECTOR
BUT I DON'T HAVE ANY --
DOCUMENTATION THAT THAT IS THE
CASE ANYMORE SO I THINK WHAT
WOULD BE HELPFUL IN THE AUDIT IS.
TO TO FOCUS ON SHARING OF DATA
AND WHAT ARE THE CIRCUMSTANCES --
OR SUBPOENAS EVER REQUIRED TO
SHARE DATA WITH OTHER LAW
ENFORCEMENT OR PROSECUTORIAL
ENTITIES WE IN CALIFORNIA ALSO
TAKEN SOME -- POSITIONS
LEGISLATIVELY THAT ARE
CALIFORNIA STATE LAW ABOUT
CIRCUMSTANCES FOR COORDINATING
WITH ICE AGENTS.
SOME OF THAT COORDINATION IS
PROHIBITED SOME OF IT IS ALLOWED
AND PROTECTED PURSUIT OF A FELON
IS NOT PROHIBITED.
BUT ONE OF THE INTRODUCTIONS WAS
SHARING INFORMATION WITH ICE I'D
BE CURIOUS OF THAT VIOLATES
CALIFORNIA LAW IN TERMS OF WHAT
WE HAVE.
DEFINED AS APPROPRIATE
COORDINATION WITH ICE ANA OR NOT.
SO AGAIN I THINK THE THE AREAS
OF CONCERN FOR ME.
ARE EITHER COMMERCIAL
DISTRIBUTION OF THIS DATA. TO
FROM THE THIRD PARTY VENDORS OR
THE AGENCIES WITH ANY OTHER
ENTITY THAT MAY HAVE A
COMMERCIAL INTEREST IN KNOWING.
WHAT ARE MY DRIVING HABITS WERE
MINE I STOP?
FOR GASOLINE -- OR RESTAURANT
WHEN I'M DRIVING AND I FIVE I
GET ALERTS TELLING ME ABOUT A
RESTAURANT THAT'S UP IN THE NEXT.
EXIT MY CAR'S FEEDING THAT
INFORMATION SOMEBODY'S
HARVESTING IT.
AND THEN TRYING TO GET ME TO
STOP.
THE RESTAURANT IT'S IT'S REALLY
RATHER AMAZING SO AGAIN WE WANT
TO PROTECT THE APPROPRIATE LAW
ENFORCEMENT USE TO PROTECT
PUBLIC SAFETY.
I WOULD HOPE THAT AGENCIES HERE
TODAY AND THE OTHERS IDENTIFIED
IN ON IT WOULD.
SEE THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
FORTIFY SYSTEMS TO BE IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THE LAW.
WITH THE GOAL OF PROTECTING BOTH
PUBLIC SAFETY.
AND PUBLIC PRIVACY SODA WITH
THAT I'D BE WILLING I WILL BE
SUPPORTIVE YES DID YOU I JUST
WANTED AND THEN -- YOU KNOW WHAT
I SAID SO -- THE MARION COUNTY
SHERIFF AND THE SAN FRAN FAIL
POLICE DEPARTMENT DO CONTRACT
WITH A THIRD PARTY TO DO
ANALYSIS OF ITS DATA I DON'T
KNOW.
WHAT HAPPENS TO IT AFTER IT'S IN
THE HANDS OF THE THIRD PARTY --
AND MEANWHILE THE OAKLAND POLICE
DEPARTMENT HAS HISTORICALLY
PROVIDED A DUMP OF ITS LICENSE
PLATE READ AT READER DATA IN
RESPONSE TO CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
RECORDS ACT SO THE NEWSPAPER
OURS TECHNICAL GOT SEVERAL YEARS
WORTH OF THIS RAW DATA.
WE ONLY ASK FOR SEVEN DAYS SO WE
CAN ANALYZE IT AND WE
IMMEDIATELY RECOGNIZE THE
PRIVACY IMPLICATIONS OF THEM
RELEASING IT IN THAT FORM.
WELL THANK UNIT I WOULD HOPE.
THOUGHT IT WOULD LOOK AT THE
LIFE SPAN OF THE DATA NO
SACRAMENTO MENTION THEY
DESTROYED AFTER A CERTAIN.
PERIOD OF TIME BUT I THINK
THAT'S THE LEGITIMATE PRIVACY
INTERESTS IS.
WHO ELSE MAY HAVE ACCESS TO THIS
DATA AND FOR WHAT PURPOSE ARE
THEY SEEKING TO ACCESS IT -- SO
WITH THAT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
I THINK RESTAURANT AT THIS TIME --
MOVED TO CENTER BORE JUSTIN TO
ASSEMBLY WOMAN RUBIO.
THANK CHAIRMAN -- I WANT TO KIND
OF FOLLOW ALONG THE LINE OF MY
COLLEAGUE FROM -- FROM CARMEL
[inaudible]
THE HOW MANY CITIES OR
JURISDICTIONS USE A. L. P. R.
RIGHT NOW.
I HAVE DOCUMENTED A MINIMUM OF A
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY BUT I
BELIEVE THAT'S A LOW NUMBER
THAT'S JUST BASED OFF OF US.
GOING WEBSITE BY WEBSITE LOOKING
FOR AUTOMATED LICENSE PLATE
READER POLICIES OR DIGGING
THROUGH PROCUREMENT DATA -- SO
IT'S THAT IS THAT IS THE LOW ONE
WE'VE RECEIVED RECORDS FROM
SIXTY AGENCIES WHICH ACCOUNTS
FOR MORE THAN A BILLION LICENSE
PLATE SCANS I WOULD ADD THAT --
WE'VE YET TO FIND -- SB THIRTY
THIRTY FOUR POLICY ON THE LOS
ANGELES POLICE DEPARTMENT'S
WEBSITE -- SO I JUST WANT TO
KNOW THAT THAT IS ONE OF THE
REASONS THAT WE ARE INTERESTED
IN SEEING THE OUTCOME OF AN
AUDIT OF THEM BECAUSE WE JUST
DON'T KNOW HOW THEY'RE USING IT
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT COMPLIANT IN
THAT REGARD.
IN HOW MANY -- ENTITIES USE
VIGILANT SOLUTION OR COMPARABLE.
TECHNOLOGY.
WE DON'T KNOW I THINK THAT --
THE WAY I THINK ABOUT IT IN THE
SPECTRUM OF COKE AND PEPSI THEY
TEND TO BE THE COKE AND THEN
THERE IS NO PEPSI IT JUST KIND
OF GOES DOWN TO MAYBE THERE'S AN
RC COLA ISN'T SOME SAFE WAY
BRAND.
BUT BUT THEY TEND TO HAVE THE
THE LARGEST MARKET SHARE AND ONE
REASON FOR THAT IS THAT THERE'S
ONLY ONE IT CERTIFIED TRAINING
BY THE PEACE OFFICER STANDARDS
AND TRAINING COMMISSION. FOR
LICENSE PLATE READER TRAINING
AND VISUAL SOLUTIONS HAS VAT.
CERTIFICATION THEY'RE THE ONLY
ONES ABLE TO GIVE THAT TRAINING
AND THEREFORE IT IS DIFFICULT
HAVE OTHER VENDORS COMING IN
BECAUSE POLICE ARE ONLY GETTING
TRAINED ON ONE SYSTEM WHICH
OFTEN TENDS TO BE A SORT OF
MARKETING SEMINAR SLASH TRAINING
SEMINAR.
OKAY ANNA AND CENTER I THINK ONE
OF THE AS YOUR SERVICE HEARING
THERE IS A LACK OF SORT OF
COMPREHENSIVE DATA JUST BASIC
INFORMATION EVEN HOW MANY CITIES
ACTUALLY DO IT -- AND SO ONE OF
THE PURPOSES OF THIS AUDIT IS TO
DO THE STATE WIDE SAYS GENERAL
LOG SO WE CAN GET A LAY OF THE
LAND.
AND THEN DO THE DEEP DIVE INTO
AND A SUBSET.
AND THAT'S REALLY WHERE I'M
GOING WITH -- WITH MY MY MY
QUESTIONS I'M NORMALLY A FIERCE
ADVOCATE.
A PROPONENT OF ASKING QUESTIONS
GETTING INFORMATION.
HI.
THERE'S A LITTLE BUZZING IN MY
EAR ON THIS ONE THOUGH.
AND I DON'T KNOW IF IT'S IF IT'S
BECAUSE FRESNO WAS CHOSEN AS A
LOCATION -- RIGHT NOW WE'RE
LOOKING AT LA AND FRESNO I THINK
YOU MENTIONED SACRAMENTO AND
MORAN.
BUT THE TWO CITIES ARE THAT WE
ARE GONNA BE LOOKED AT IN MORE
DETAIL EARLY IN FRESNO.
AND THAT KIND OF PEAKS MY
INTEREST IN THE PEAKS MY
INTEREST BECAUSE IT'S NOT
UNCOMMON IT'S NOT UNCOMMON
KNOWLEDGE THAT FRESNO -- HAS HAD --
POLITICAL LEADERSHIP -- IN THE
PAST -- THAT HAS TRIED TO FIGURE
OUT THE ROLE OF THE SHERIFF.
AND LAW ENFORCEMENT LAW ON
IMMIGRATION RELATED ISSUES MY
COLLEAGUE FROM CARMEL POINTED
THAT OUT SPECIFICALLY.
ON THE VARIOUS CONFLICTS OF
INFORMATION SHARED BETWEEN.
OUR ENTITIES INVOLVING THE STATE.
AND THE RULES THAT PERTAIN AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL.
AND SO MY CONCERN IS THAT THIS
APPEARS TO BE A BIT NINE INQUIRY
INTO THIS AREA OF PRACTICE AND
STUDY.
IS THERE ANOTHER REASON THAT THE
THAT FRESNO WAS CHOSEN.
THAT -- IT HONESTLY HAVE TO
ANSWER THAT RIGHT NOW BUT IT IS
CAUSING ME SOME CONCERN -- THAT --
THIS IS BEING BACK TOWARD INTO
IMMIGRATION DISCUSSION NOT A
TRADITIONAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
PRIVACY RELATED TO REQUIRE
ANALYSTS MR MAS TO FOLLOW UP.
AS WOULD BE VERY TRANSPARENT
THAT ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WE'RE INTERESTED IN IS.
COORDINATION WHERE WITH ICING
USE OF THIS DATA.
IN TERMS OF ICE SO EVEN THAT WAS
AND I REQUEST WE'RE NOT HIDING
FROM THAT THAT'S NOT THE PRIMARY
REASON WE'RE DOING THIS THIS IS
JUST.
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT OVERALL
HELLO WHERE IS THIS BEING USED
HELL HELL PREVALENT IS THE OUR
CITIES COMPLYING.
AND COUNTIES AND AGENCIES
COMPLYING WITH SB THIRTY FOUR
ARE THERE ANY CHANGES IN THE LAW
WE NEED TO MAKE THAT'S THE
PURPOSE OF IT BUT ALL I HAD
LITTLE TO MR MAS SO IT IN THE
PROCESS SO FIRST WE WANT TO
SPREAD THESE AROUND HE STATE.
SO THAT WAS ONE OF THE REASONS
WE WONDERED AND SEVENTY
LOCATIONS USING RC COLA COKE AND
PEPSI EXACTLY SO FRESNO IS ON
THAT LIST SO WHEN WE STARTED
RESEARCHING THIS WE RECEIVED A
COPY OF THE DATA SHARING REPORT
FROM.
THE HAWTHORNE POLICE DEPARTMENT
WHICH INDICATED THE DATA FROM
HAWTHORNE WAS BEING SHARED WITH
SOMETHING CALLED THE FRESNO
FASHION MALL A FASHION MALL
SECURITY WE DIDN'T KNOW WE DON'T
KNOW WHO IS RECEIVING A STATE IT
SOUNDED LIKE A PRIVATE ENTITY.
WHEN WE ASKED HAWTHORNE THEY
SAID WE DON'T KNOW TALK TO
FRESNO POLICE DEPARTMENT SO BOTH
EFF AND THE CENTER FOR HUMAN
RIGHTS AND PRIVACY?
PASSED FRESNO OVER AND OVER
AGAIN WHAT IS THE DEAL WITH THIS
AND WE NEVER RECEIVED ANY KIND
OF RESPONSE.
SO THAT WAS ONE OF THE THE
EVIDENCE ON WHITE HIGHLY FRESNO
HAD NOTHING TO DO WITH
IMMIGRATION BUT BECAUSE WE
WANTED TO UNDERSTAND WHETHER
THERE WERE SECURITY GUARDS AT A
MALL RECEIVING THIS DATA WHETHER
THERE WAS A POLICE SUBSTATION AT
THE MALL THAT WAS RECEIVING THIS
DATA.
I MEAN BECAUSE CERTAINLY I THINK
WE'D ALL BE CONCERNED IF THERE
WERE MALL COPS WHO WERE ABLE TO
SEARCH.
YOU KNOW PEOPLE'S LOCATIONAL
DATA WITHOUT ANY OVERSIGHT FROM
THE POLICE DEPARTMENT HELLO ALL
IN MY QUESTIONS HERE I THINK I
WOULD FEEL CERTAINLY MORE
COMFORTABLE.
THAT IF YOU HAD A STRONG URBAN
INST AND RURAL -- SAMPLE.
AND YOU CRATER THRESHOLD AND
ESSENTIALLY -- LOTTERY DID IT AS
A DECISION -- I WOULD FEEL FOR
MORE COMFORTABLE YOU KNOW -- NOT
THROWN BAKERSFIELD IN THE BUS
BUT BUT SOMETHING ALONG THOSE
LINES -- ONLY BECAUSE THE
SELECTION OF OF THIS AREA GIVEN
THE POLITICAL HISTORY -- I IS OF
CONCERN.
RIGHT THANK YOU AND YOU KNOW AND
MY UNDERSTANDING IS WORKING WITH
THE AUTHOR AS WELL AS AS WE'RE
TRYING TO GET REGIONAL --
SAMPLES FROM ACROSS THE STATE
[inaudible]
ROLL URBAN.
SO WITH THAT WE LIVE TO ASSEMBLY
WOMAN RUBIO AND THEN TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PATTERSON.
THANK YOU FOR ME -- THIS IS NOW
MY THIRD YEAR SITTING ON THE
COMMITTEE I ALSO SEE IT AS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE DEPARTMENTS
TO HIGHLIGHT HIGHLIGHT.
THEIR THEIR GOOD PRACTICES IT'S
NOT ABOUT A GOTCHA -- WE FOUND
THAT SOME -- ENTITIES THAT WE'VE
AUDITED IN THE PAST HAVE HAVE
BEEN SQUEAKY CLEAN SO THAT WE
CAN SAY HEY WE WERE AUDITED BY
THE STATE AND WE WERE PERFECT
BUT ALSO TO USE.
THE MODELS OF THE THE AGENCIES
THAT ARE DOING WELL AS YOU KNOW
KIND OF A THE MODEL FOR THE REST
OF THE AGENCIES THAT ARE USING
AND SOUL.
YOU KNOW I KNOW IT'S A DIFFICULT --
THING.
TO HEAR IS THAT THAT YOU'RE
BEING AUDITED BUT SOMETIMES YOU
CAN USE THAT AS A POSITIVE IF IT
IN FACT.
ALLEY PD HAS IN ALL OF THESE
PRACTICES AND YOU HAVE.
MANAGED TO TO FOLLOW THE LETTER
OF THE LAW AND REALLY HAVE A
GOOD PRACTICE GOING IT WOULD BE
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR OTHER
AGENCIES THROUGHOUT THE OF WHAT
THE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY ONE TO
BE ABLE TO USE.
YOUR PRACTICES AS AN OPPORTUNITY
TO IMPROVE THEIR SYSTEM SO I
ALWAYS TRY TO LOOK AT THE
POSITIVE AND IF NOTHING COMES
OUT OF IT THE AGENCIES CAN
CERTAINLY.
BLASTED ALL OVER THE INTERNET
THAT YOU KNOW THEY WERE SQUEAKY
CLEAN THE BY GOT AUDITED AND
THEY'VE GOT A GREAT REPORT SO I
ALWAYS TRY TO LOOK AT THE
POSITIVE OF THAT.
IT IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR YOU TO
LOOK AT YOUR PRACTICE SAYS AND
IF YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY CLEAN THEN
BLASTED ALL OVER THE INTERNET
AND SAY HOW AMAZING YOU GUYS ARE
BECAUSE THE AUDITOR CAME AND YOU
KNOW SHE FOUND NOTHING WRONG SO.
FOR ME THAT'S ALWAYS -- THE
REASON -- TO TO FOLLOW THROUGH
ON SOME OF THESE OUT ITS OWN
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
THANK YOU WITH OUR MOVING TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PATTERSON AND
THEN TO SENATOR GONZALEZ.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR UP.
CAN I HAVE ASK YOUR FRESNO COULD
EXPLORE.
THE PROCESS.
GET THE AUDIT IS GOING TO
BASICALLY LOOK AT THE PRACTICES
AND ARE YOU -- IN COMPLIANCE
WITH THE PARTICULAR UNDERLYING
LAW CAN YOU LAY OUT HOW FRESNO.
THE INITIATED TO THE TECHNOLOGY
WENT THROUGH THE IMPLEMENTATION.
AND HIGHLIGHT IF YOU CAN.
THAT PROCESS AS BEING IN KEEPING
WITH THE UNDERLYING LAW.
SURE SO IN IN FRESNO LIKE I I
MENTIONED WE WE'VE HAD -- P. R..
FOR I THINK ABOUT A DECADE I WAS
A PART OF THAT BUT WE HAD AN OP
OUR SYSTEM THAT WE USED IN
CONJUNCTION WITH CLOVIS PD.
AND ALL THAT DATA WAS WAS HOSTED --
AT CLOVIS BUT IT WAS A
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN THE TWO
AGENCIES.
AND THEN MORE RECENTLY AS THE
TECHNOLOGY EVOLVED -- WE TESTED
DIFFERENT TECHNOLOGIES DIFFERENT
LPR SOLUTIONS -- WITH YOU KNOW
FIX READERS AND MOBILE READERS.
AND FOR FRESNO WE DECIDED THAT
MOBILE READERS WOULD -- GET US
THE MOST BANG FOR THE BUCK
BECAUSE AS YOU KNOW FRESNO IS
HUNDRED FIFTEEN SQUARE MILES
IT'S JUST SPREAD OUT. TO GET ANY
KIND OF COVERAGE OF FIXED
READERS -- WOULD HAVE BEEN A
HUGE EXPENSE SO WE WENT WITH THE
MOBILE READERS.
AND ALSO WITH THE INTENTION OF
USING THOSE TO ASSIST US WITH
SOME OF OUR OUR INVESTIGATIONS --
SO WE HAVE A LARGE -- CRIME
SCENE -- WE CAN ALWAYS ROLE AN
LP OUR CAR THROUGH THAT SCENE TO
ASSIST THE INVESTIGATORS LATER
ON WITH -- WITH ANY VEHICLES
THAT WERE IN THE AREA AT THE
TIME OF THE CRIME.
IT CETERA.
SO WE DISCOVERED -- THE COMPANY
VIGILANT SOLUTIONS THIS BEEN
MENTIONED -- THE THE VALUE FOR
US WITH -- MOVING FORWARD WITH
VIGILANT WAS THE AMOUNT OF DATA
THAT THEY BROUGHT TO THE TABLE
AND PROVIDED.
SO IN THE WHAT I'LL CALL THE
GREATER FRESNO AREA -- THAT YOU
KNOW INCLUDES THE SMALLER CITIES
SURROUNDING FRESNO -- THEY DO
AROUND A MILLION DETECTIONS A
MONTH.
IS WHAT VIGILANT PUTS INTO THE
SYSTEM.
SO IN ADDITION TO THAT -- THE
DETECTIONS -- THAT OR A
COLLECTED BY THE FRESNO POLICE
DEPARTMENT CAMERAS ALSO ARE ARE
ALL SEARCHABLE WITHIN THE SAME
DATABASE -- USING THE SAME USER
INTERFACE.
SO THAT THAT HAD A LOT OF VALUE
TO US HAVING ALL OF THAT
INFORMATION IN ONE PLACE IN
ADDITION WE HAD ACCESS TO
VIGILANT SOLUTION DETECTIONS
FROM ACROSS THE NATION SO.
SO ALL OF THAT DATA WAS IN ONE
PLACE -- YOU PAY A SUBSCRIPTION
TO HAVE ACCESS TO THEIR DATA AND
THEN -- YOUR DATA CAN GO INTO
THE SAME SYSTEM -- THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT DATA THAT GOES INTO
THEIR SYSTEM I IT WAS MENTIONED
EARLIER THAT DATA BELONGS -- TO
THE LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY --
AND THAT'S NOT CO MINGLED WITH
THE COMMERCIAL DATA -- FROM THE
VIGILANT SIDE -- IT WAS
MENTIONED BUT SENSE THAT THERE
IS A SEPARATION THEN.
BETWEEN TYPES OF DATA.
YES AND THAT THE PROPRIETARY
RESPONSIBILITY OF THAT DATA
RESTS WITH THE FRESNO POLICE TO
PARK -- YOU HAVE IT AND DO WHAT
WITH IT I I DON'T OUR DATA IS IS --
SENT TO THEIR SERVERS -- BUT THE
DATA IS NOT -- COMMINGLED ARE
MIXED.
SO THE LAW ENFORCEMENT DATA IT
REMAINS LAW ENFORCEMENT DATA
IT'S NOT AVAILABLE TO THE
COMMERCIAL SIDE -- I SUPPOSE
UNLESS THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCY CHOOSES TO SHARE THAT
WITH THE COMMERCIAL SIDE -- BUT
THE COMMERCIAL DATA IS AVAILABLE
TO LAW ENFORCEMENT SO IN THAT
CASE THAT WAS MENTIONED EARLIER
WITH THE FRESNO FASHION FAIR --
SECURITY I APOLOGIZE YOU DIDN'T.
SOMEHOW REACH ME I DON'T KNOW
HOW YOU CAN REACH ME I WOULD
HAVE RESPONDED BUT BUT THOSE ARE
CAN YOU RESPONSIBLY TO THAT AND
WHILE YOU'RE HERE -- CERTAINLY
SO YEAH APPARENTLY HAWTHORNE
CHOSE TO SHARE THEIR DETECTIONS
WITH THE FRESNO FASHION FAIR
MALL SECURITY.
THE FRESNO FASHION FAIR MALL
SECURITY THEY HAVE A LICENSE
PLATE READER CAMERAS I BELIEVE
IN ONE OF THE VEHICLES.
AND THEY USE -- VIGIL SOLUTIONS
AND THAT INFORMATION GOES INTO
THE VIGILANT SO -- SOLUTION
SYSTEM -- BUT THAT BUT THAT.
THAT WAS NOT AN ACT OF THE
FRESNO POLICE DEPARTMENT NO WE
HAVE NO THIS WAS NO.
NO WE DON'T THING ELSE HAPPENING
SOMEPLACE ELSE CORRECT WE DON'T
SHARE DATA WITH FASHION FAIR GOT
IT -- NINE JUST A FOLLOW UP VERY
QUICKLY THERE ARE.
ELEMENTS OF THE LAW WITH RESPECT
TO HOW YOU.
UP ANNOUNCE IT -- ALL OF THAT
CAN.
CAN YOU STEP US THROUGH.
THE PROCESS THAT PRESENT NO.
AND OTHER AGENCIES AYE AYE I
SUPPOSE USED TO COMPLY WITH THE
LAW AND HOW CLEAR IS THAT
INFORMATION -- SO WITH REGARD TO
THE PUBLIC HEARING REQUIREMENTS --
I KNOW PRIOR -- TO MOVING
FORWARD WITH THIS WE DID HAVE --
SEVERAL DIFFERENT -- A COMMUNITY
MEETINGS WITH COMMUNITY LEADERS%
ETCETERA NOT SPECIFICALLY -- FOR
LICENSE PLATE READER BUT MORE
GENERALLY TO DISCUSS ALL OF THE
TECHNOLOGIES THAT WE'RE GOING TO
BE A USER WE WERE LOOKING AT
USING IN OUR CRIME CENTER -- BUT
LPR WAS DEFINITELY ONE OF THOSE --
BUT ULTIMATELY WE WENT -- TO
CITY COUNCIL -- WITH THE REQUEST
FOR THE HEARING A CITY COUNCIL.
AND THAT WAS AN EIGHT EIGHT
EIGHT PUBLICLY ANNOUNCED THE
HEARING -- AGENDA AND FULLY IN.
INFORMED PEOPLE YES A REGULAR
COUNCIL SAYS INTEREST.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WILL JUST CENTER
GONZALEZ PLACE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH -- FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD AS SENATOR
WIENER AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY EACH OF YOU AT THE
FROM THE AGENCIES PARTICULARLY
LAPD BEING IN MY BACKYARD AS
WELL.
IT'S REALLY GREAT TO KNOW -- ALL
OF THE GOOD WORK YOU'RE DOING A
BEING FROM TECHNOLOGY IN MY PAST --
IT'S GOOD TO KNOW THE CG -- THE
SUGGESTS THAT CERTIFICATION THE
OVERLAY IN SOFTWARE WHICH IS
YOUR HEAD IT SEEMS LIKE IN THE
OF THE CURVE -- I HAVE IN THE
PAST WORKED WITH OTHER AGENCIES
THAT HAVE NOT BEEN SEE JUST
CERTIFIED.
WILL NOT SAY WHO BUT I THINK
THIS PROVIDES AN OPPORTUNITY ON
THE SECURITY SIDE TO BE ABLE TO
ENSURE THAT THE DATA IS NOT ONLY --
BUT IT'S THAT IT'S JUST
PROTECTED -- ENCRYPTED AND
SECURE THAT IT'S NOT YOU KNOW WE
DON'T HAVE ANY BREACHES ON THAT
SIDE.
I'M ALSO INTERESTED IN THE
PUBLIC NOTIFICATIONS AND
HEARINGS WHICH I THINK IS NOT A
STANDARD ACROSS THE STATE TO BE
GOOD TO KNOW ABOUT -- HOW THAT
WILL?
COME ABOUT AND THEN I THINK JUST
IN GENERAL -- AS SENATE I'M
SORRY ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO AND
MENTIONED -- I THINK THIS IS A
GREAT OPPORTUNITY -- TO LOOK AT
VARIOUS AGENCIES NOT NECESSARILY --
AWAY TO POLITICIZE THIS BUT
REALLY TO LOOK AT VARIOUS
AGENCIES AND WHAT THE PROCEDURES
AND PROCESSES ARE AND HOW THE
PUBLIC WILL.
IN TAKE THAT AS WELL SO THANK
YOU AGAIN.
THANK YOU IF I MAY PLEASE SO
THANK YOU FOR COMMENTS AND I
JUST WANNA BE CLEAR FROM THE LOS
ANGELES PART SIDE SO WE
ABSOLUTELY WELCOME OF THIS
COMMITTEE DECIDES TO MOVE
FORWARD WHERE WE'RE HAPPY TO
PARTICIPATE IN WOULD.
FULLY PARTICIPATE -- WE FEEL
AGAIN THAT WE'RE AHEAD OF WHAT
IS HAPPENING TODAY.
AND THERE ARE I JUST WANT TO
LEAVE YOU WITH THE SENSE THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT RECOGNIZES THE
IMPORTANCE AND THE SENSITIVITY
OF THE NATURE OF THIS --
INFORMATION AS WELL WE SHARE
THROUGH THE INTERNATIONAL
ASSOCIATION CHIEF OF POLICE WE
HAVE CONFERENCES AND WE HAVE
BEST PRACTICES COMMITTEES THAT
DISCUSS LICENSE PLATE
RECOGNITION HOW WE SHARE IT DATA
SECURITY RETENTION ALL THOSE
DIFFERENT ITEMS.
ALSO ADD THAT FROM THE LOS AS
POLICE DEPARTMENT SIDE WE ARE
CURRENTLY INVOLVED IN A PENDING
LOGIC ONGOING LITIGATION WITH
THE ACLU AND THE EFF ON LICENSE
PLATE RECOGNITION WE HAVE GOT --
WITHOUT GOING INTO THE DETAILS
BECAUSE I'M NOT ALLOWED TO BUT
WE HAVE CERTAINLY IN PUBLIC FORM
AND THROUGH THE COURTS HAVE
SHARED ALL THE DATA THAT WERE
REQUIRED TO SHARE WITH THEM.
ABSENT THE DATA OF THE LICENSE
PLATE READS THEMSELF WE HAVE
BEEN VERY PROTECTIVE OF THE DATA
AND STILL ARE AND THAT'S AN
ONGOING LITIGATION TODAY BUT WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THE THE SECURITY
AND THE THE SHARING OF THE DATA
IS THE MOST IMPORTANT PIECE AND
WE'VE TAKEN A VERY VERY.
STRONG LINE ON THAT THE CITY HAS
AND WE CONTINUE TO SO.
IN RESPECT TO THE AUDIT AND WHAT
WOULD BE ALLOWED FROM AN
INVESTIGATIVE STANDPOINT WE
WOULD BE LIMITED IN TERMS OF
WHAT WE COULD OF DEFAULT AS THE
INVESTIGATIVE SIDE BECAUSE
THAT'S THE ONLY REASON THAT WE
USE THE OPR DATA THAT POINT
[inaudible]
JUST UP.
I JUST WANTED TO ASK I'M NOT
GONNA BE ABLE TO VOTE FOR THIS
I'M GONNA LAY OFFOF IT.
FOR SOME OF THE REASONS
EXPRESSED EXPRESSED HER BUT I
DID WANT TO SAY SOMETHING WITH
RESPECT TO THE AUDITOR AND WITH
RESPECT FRESNO.
MY SENSE IS THIS GOING TO MOVE
FORWARD -- AND I HAVE FULL AND
COMPLETE CONFIDENCE IN THIS
ORDER. TO GO ABOUT DIGGING INTO
THIS INFORMATION AND GETTING IT --
PUT TOGETHER AND I ALSO KNOW --
FROM -- EIGHT YEARS OF BEING
MAYOR FRESNO -- THE FRESNO
POLICE DEPARTMENT IS DOING IT
RIGHT I THINK IT'S GOING TO BE
DEMONSTRATED THAT THEY ARE DOING
IT RIGHT IN THE PROCESS.
BUT I AM CONCERNED SIMILAR WITH
WHAT US SENATOR BOARD JUST MIGHT
HAVE RAISED HERE -- I I I AM A
LITTLE SUSPICIOUS ABOUT WHY
FRESNO AND WHY NOT SOMEPLACE
ELSE.
BE THAT AS IT MAY FULL
CONFIDENCE IN THIS AUDITOR WHEN
SHE GOES AFTER THE FACT SHE
FINDS THEM.
AND I AGREE WITH THE OTHER
MEMBERS UP HERE WHO HAVE
SUGGESTED.
THAT WHEN YOU WHEN YOU GET THE
UP.
THE LANE HOW SEAL OF APPROVAL IS
PRETTY GOOD.
ONE THAT I REALLY OF ENCOURAGE
ALL OF THE AFFECTED AGENCIES UP.
WORK WITH HER -- THIS IS THIS
WILL BE A STATE A SOLUTION IN
THE MAKING I THINK.
MY OTHER CONCERN THOUGH IS WHAT
WE DO AFTER THE FACT WE GET THE
AUDIT BACK IN THERE ARE SOME
SUGGESTED.
LEGISLATION -- MY HOPE IS THAT
WE'RE NOT LOOKING TO FIND SOME
KIND OF A REASON TO OUTLAW THE
TECHNOLOGY -- CONSTRAINING
RESTRAINING THE DISSEMINATION OF
IT THOSE KINDS OF THINGS MAKES A
LOT OF SENSE -- SO I I CAN'T
SUPPORT IT FOR REASONS STATED
HERE BUT I CAN'T SUPPORT THIS
AUDITOR.
PERSONALLY AND PROFESSIONALLY I
WOULD ENCOURAGE EVERYBODY
THOUGHT IT GOES FORWARD PLEASE
COOPERATE YOU'LL FIND HER
WONDERFUL TO WORK WITH.
THANK YOU MISTER SUN WILL GO TO
MOVE TO MISTER VOEPEL
[inaudible]
YES -- I HAVE A QUESTION TO THE
STATE AUDITOR AND THEN ALSO
SHORT COMMENT.
QUESTION IS.
YOU STATED EARLIER THAT RIGHT
NOW YOU HAVE CAPACITY FOR SIX
AUDITS WITH YOUR TEAM AND THEN
DOWN THE ROAD NINE AUDITS.
OF WILL.
COME A LITTLE BIT LATER.
TODAY I'M LOOKING AT EIGHT
AUDITS ON OUR SCHEDULE HERE.
THREE OF ALREADY BEEN PASSED.
ON CONSENT CALENDARS SO THAT
WOULD BE IN THREE MORE AUDITS
ARE AVAILABLE THAT YOU CAN GO ON
SO [inaudible]
IF.
WE'RE BEYOND YOUR CAPACITY TO
AUDIT.
DO YOU SIMPLY PUT IT DOWN ON
YOUR QUEUE FOR A LATER AUDIT SO
IT BECOMES A TIME MATTER.
YES -- IF IF THE COMMITTEE
DECIDES TO PROVE MORE THAN SIX
AUDITS TODAY WHAT WE WOULD DO IS
AS SOON AS ADDITIONAL TEAMS FREE
UP -- WE WOULD ASSIGN STAFF TO
PARTICULAR ARTISTS AND THE WAY
WE GO ABOUT ASSIGNING PARTICULAR
AUDITS IS WE'RE LOOKING AT THE
COMPLEXITY OF THE WORK AND THE
RESOURCES THAT ARE AVAILABLE SO
I WOULD PUT.
ON SOME OF THESE AUDITS MORE
SEASONED FOLKS THAN -- LESS
EXPERIENCED SO WE GO THROUGH
THOSE ANALYSES -- WITH MY
EXECUTIVE TEAM SO IF -- AGAIN
MORE THAN SIX AUDITS ARE
APPROVED TODAY WILL BE ABLE TO
START.
MY SIX AUDITS BETWEEN JULY AND
AUGUST -- THE NEXT COUPLE OF
MONTHS AND THEN SUBSEQUENT TO
THAT WE HAVE SOME WORK GOING OUT
IN SEPTEMBER OCTOBER NOVEMBER SO
WE'LL BE ABLE TO COMMENCE ANY
ADDITIONAL LOT IT'S THEIR PROOF
TODAY.
IN THOSE MONTHS.
THANK YOU AND THEN WITH THAT IN
MIND -- I'M.
I HAVE.
GREAT RESPECT FOR THE AUTHOR.
BUT I'M NOT QUITE SURE IN MY
MIND HOW BADLY THIS AUDIT IS
NEEDED.
AND HERE'S MY LOGIC ON THAT.
IF I WANT TO LOOK AT MY HOUSE OR
MY NEIGHBORHOOD I GOT GOOGLE
EARTH WE HAVE ZILLOW WE HAVE
AMAZON ANOTHER THREE HUNDRED AND
SIXTY DEGREE RECORDINGS.
WE HAVE CAMERAS EVERYWHERE FOR
ONE LOOK IN MY BACKYARD IT'S
HERE ON MY PHONE -- SOAP CELL
PHONE GPS.
THEY CAN SUBPOENA WHERE YOU BEN.
WHERE YOU'RE GO ON?
FOREVER ALL RIGHT EVEN MY WIFE
KNOWS WHERE I'M AT SO.
WITH GREAT RESPECT.
I WOULD IF THIS BODY APPROVES
THIS I WOULD PUT IT.
IN A HOUSE RESPECTFULLY THAT IT
GO DOWN ON YOUR PRIORITY LIST --
BECAUSE I I PERSONALLY JUST
DON'T SEE ANY GREAT NEED FOR
THIS [inaudible]
SPECIFIC SAMPLING.
RIGHT THANK YOU WITH THAT LET ME
ASK THERE'S ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS FROM THE DíAS.
HEARING IN SAYING THAT -- MAY
JUST ASK MADAM AUDITOR AT MISS
HOW.
YOU KNOW EARLIER I THINK IT WAS
THE STATUS IT STATED THAT THEY
TERMINATED -- USING THIS THIS
THIS -- TECHNOLOGY BACK IN
NOVEMBER OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN IF I
HEARD THAT CORRECTLY.
AND IF THAT ISTHE CASE IN FACT
THIS WOULD NARROW -- THE SCOPE
OF THE OUT IT WOULD BE MY WAS IT
WOULD BE WHAT I WOULD GAS WOULD.
DO YOU.
CONCUR THAT'S CORRECT I MEAN IF
IF IN FACT WE WOULD WANT TO
CONFIRM THAT THEY HAVE NO LONGER
THERE THE DEPARTMENT HUMAN.
ASSISTANCE IN SACRAMENTO IS NO
LONGER USING THAT TECHNOLOGY IF
THERE'S SENATOR WIENER IS
COMFORTABLE WITH THAT WHERE WE
WE DON'T LOOK BACK AND SEE WHAT
THEY HAD DONE IN THE PAST
BECAUSE WE CONFIRM OR VERIFY
THAT THEY'RE NO LONGER USING --
THE TECHNOLOGY THEN THAT WOULD
REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF HOURS AND
NECESSARY TO COMPLETE THE JOB
OBVIOUSLY BECAUSE WE'RE WE'RE
NOT LOOKING AT THAT PARTICULAR
ENTITY -- ROUGHLY THAT WOULD
SAVE -- PROBABLY A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY HOURS -- AS AS FAR AS THE
THE BUDGET ITSELF BECAUSE THE
VAST MAJORITY OF THE HOURS WERE
GOING TO EXPAND.
OUR ON OBJECTIVE THREE WHICH IS
DRILLING DOWN AT EACH OF THOSE
ENTITIES OF COURSE I SPOKE ABOUT -
THE OBJECTIVE RELATED TO THE
SURVEY SURVEYING -- LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT THROUGHOUT THE STATE
BUT IT WOULD ABSOLUTELY REDUCE
THE AMOUNT OF TIME AND CERTAINLY
THE COST OF THE AUDIT.
HAVE I MIGHT JUST.
ADD ON THAT SO SACRAMENTO COUNTY
VARIOUS AGENCIES -- USE OR HAVE
USED -- TO INCLUDING -- THE
HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY WHICH JUST
TERMINATED THEIR CONTRACT I
BELIEVE LAST MONTH -- AND THERE
HAVE BEEN SOME ISSUES IN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY -- SOME BOAT
BELIEVER.
POTENTIAL VIOLATIONS OF SB
THIRTY FOUR OZ ROBERT HAVE A
CONVERSATION WE CERTAINLY DON'T
WANT ON THE LISTS AUDITING BUT
IF THERE WAS A TERMINATE A
CONTRACT WHERE THERE WAS.
AN ACTUAL VIOLATION THAT WAS
HAPPENING THAT MAY HAVE
POTENTIAL EVEN LED TO THE
TERMINATION -- THAT'S USEFUL
INFORMATION AS WELL SOBRE WHAT
RAPID TO HAVE A CONVERSATION
WITH THE AUDITOR OKAY UNDERSTOOD --
WITH THAT LET'S GO TO MOVE TO
PUBLIC COMMENT FROM ASK THERE'S
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS ITEM.
AND IF YOU COULD PLEASE BE
CONCISE WITH YOUR COMMENTS AND
OKAY [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
HEARING AND SEEING NO PUBLIC
COMMENT AT THIS TIME.
LET ME ASK IF US SENATOR YOU'D
LIKE TO CLOSE ON THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND I WANT TO
THANK CALLERS FOR VERY
THOUGHTFUL -- CONVERSATION I TO
BE CLEAR MY MY GOAL IS NOT TO
BAN THIS TECHNOLOGY THIS
TECHNOLOGY CAN BE VERY VERY
USEFUL IN A VARIETY OF CONTACTS.
ON BUT WHAT I THINK WE CAN ALL
AGREE KNOWLEDGE THAT WE WANTED
TO BE USED THE WAY IT'S SUPPOSED
TO BE USED -- AND NOT -- ABUSE
WHETHER INTENTIONALLY OR
UNINTENTIONALLY THIS IS NOT
ABOUT THE SERVE OUT PEOPLE DOING
THINGS MALICIOUSLY BUT WE ALL
KNOW AND GOVERNMENT -- AND IT I
AM IN THE CORPORATE SECTOR
THINGS CAN BE DONE JUST AN
ADVERT AND LIKE WE DON'T REALIZE
WHAT'S HAPPENING.
AND THE PURPOSE OF THIS AUDIT AS
NOT TO POINT TO POINT FINGERS --
THE IT IS TO JUST MAKE SURE THAT
THE LAW IS BEING FOLLOWED THAT
THE PROCEDURES ARE CORRECT AND
IF THERE ARE ISSUES THAT WE CAN
HELP.
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS COMPLY OR IF
WE NEED TO IMPROVE THE LAW THAT
WE CAN DO THAT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
SENATOR -- WITH THAT -- I DO
HAVE A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION ON
THIS -- DO BELIEVE YOU'RE TRYING
TO PROTECT OUR PRIVACY AND CIVIL
LIBERTIES AND SEE WHICH ENTITIES
ARE COMPLYING WITH SENATE BILL
THIRTY FOUR WHICH WAS SIGNED BY
THE GOVERNOR.
AND WITH THAT -- MISTER
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
I NEED A MOTION [inaudible]
YEAH.
MOTION BY ASSEMBLY WOMAN RUBIO
SECOND BY.
MISS BRUNNER **** BATH EARLIER.
THEY WERE ON A QUICKLY MISTER
MIND.
OKAY WITH THAT WE'RE GOING TO
CALL THE ROLL THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AUDIT NUMBER TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN DASH ONE EIGHTEEN BY
SOME ARE BY SENATOR WIENER THE
SUBJECT IS CALIFORNIA LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES AUTOMATIC
LICENSE PLATE READERS.
SOME EVER SALAS HI SALAS HI
BOERNER HORVATH.
BOERNER HORVATH HI DEEP
[inaudible]
PATTERSON.
PATTERSON NOT VOTING
[inaudible]
RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE VOEPEL.
VOEPEL NOT VOTING WHAT.
WHAT I CENTER ROTH?
ROTH I BORDERS [inaudible]
GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG
[inaudible]
MONNING.
MONNING I AM [inaudible]
MORE LIKE [inaudible]
WIENER I WIENER AYE.
OKAY.
WHAT THAT WALL THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU --
THANKS FOR THE PRESENTATION WITH
THAT WE'LL GO AHEAD AND MOVE --
TO MISS BURNER **** BATH.
I DON'T SEE JONES SAWYER RIGHT.
WE'RE MOVING TO REGULAR CALENDAR
THIS IS AGENDA ITEM NUMBER FOR
AN AGENDA ITEM NUMBER.
FIVE GEN ITEM NUMBER FOUR IS
TWENTY NINETEEN DASH ONE ONE
THREE THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA MISSION POLICIES AND
PRACTICES.
AND THEN AFTER THAT WE WILL
BEGIN WITH NUMBER FIVE TWENTY
NINETEEN DASH ONE ONE FOR
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY.
CAMPUS BASED STUDENT FEES --
MISS FOR BATH WHEN YOU'RE READY
FOR PRESENT ON AGENDA ITEM
NUMBER FOUR PLACE YES GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THE
COMMITTEE'S APPROVAL OF AN AUDIT
OF THE UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA.
ADMISSIONS POLICIES AND
PRACTICES INCLUDING EFFORTS TO
DETECT AND ADDRESS FRAUD IN THE
MISSIONS PROCESS.
NEWS ARTICLES OVER THE LAST FEW
MONTHS HAVE REPORTED ON A NATION
WIDE STREET SCANDAL IN WHICH
HUNDREDS OF INDIVIDUALS
COMMITTED FRAUD. TO GAIN
EMISSIONS TO SOME OF THE
NATION'S TOP ACADEMIC
INSTITUTIONS LET'S BE CLEAR
WE'RE VERY LUCKY IN CALIFORNIA
THE SOME OF THE NATION'S TOP
INSTITUTIONS ARE PUBLIC HIGHER
EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS AND THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. TO
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
CAMPUSES HAVE BEEN CONNECTED
WITH EMISSIONS CHEATING SCANDAL
UCLA MEN'S SOCCER COACH WAS M. --
INDICTED AS PART OF OUR IT IS
INDICATED AS PART OF THE F. B.
I.'S WIDESPREAD CORRUPTION
INVESTIGATION.
AND CHARGED WITH ALLEGEDLY
ACCEPTING TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN BRIBES FOR
FACILITATING THE ENROLLMENT.
OF STUDENTS A SOCCER PLAYERS
EVEN THOUGH THEY DID NOT
COMPETITIVELY PLAY THE SPORT.
AT UC BERKELEY A PARENT IS
ALLEGED TO HAVE PAID SOME ONE TO
TAKE THE SAT TEST IN PLACE OF A
SON WHO IS A MINUTE TO BERKELEY.
I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE SWIFT
AND DECISIVE ACTION OF PRESENT
APOLOGY NO AND THE WORK OF THE
UC ON CONDUCTING ITS OWN
INTERNAL INVESTIGATION INTO
THESE CRIMES.
I AGREE WITH PRESIDENT OF ALL
TIME WHEN SHE SAID ILLEGAL
INAPPROPRIATE AND UNETHICAL
MEANS TO GAIN ADMISSION AT THE
EXPENSE OF DESERVING APPLICANTS.
IS ANTI IT SET A GOAL TO EVERY
ASPECT OF OUR MISSION AND VALUES.
AS A PUBLIC INSTITUTION ONE OF
THE MOST HIGHLY REGARDED IN THE
WORLD I CALLED THE NUMBER ONE
PUBLIC UNIVERSITY IN THE WORLD --
I WENT TO UC BERKELEY GO BEARS --
WE ARE DEDICATED TO ENSURING
LEVEL PLAYING FIELD FOR EVERY
APPLICANT -- I'M SAT IN AS AS A
UC BERKELEY GRAD OF THE RECENT
SCANDAL BUT I'M OPTIMISTIC THAT
AN A STATE AUDIT PERFORMED BY
OUR INDEPENDENT AUDITOR.
CAN.
A HELP ASSURE CAL IF
CALIFORNIANS THAT THE UC IS
DOING ALL THAT IT CAN DO TO
ENSURE THAT MERITOCRACY IN
DIVERSITY THAT WE VALUE IS
RETAIN WITHIN OUR HIGHER
EDUCATION PUBLIC INSTITUTIONS
CALIFORNIA. TO THIS END I
REQUEST OF THE STATE AUDITOR
CONDUCT AN AUDIT WITH THE
FOLLOWING SCOPE.
REVIEW AND ASSESS UC SYSTEM WHY
POLICIES AND PRACTICES REGARDING
EMISSIONS.
REVIEW AND ASSESS THE UC
ADMISSIONS POLICIES AND
PROCESSES FOR THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA BERKELEY.
UCLAA UCSD.
PROVIDING THE FOLLOWING
INFORMATION REGARDING UC AUDIBLE
STUDENTS ADMITTED TO THE THREE
CAMPUSES UNDER THE UC SPECIAL
MISSIONS POLICY OVER THE LAST
THREE YEARS WITH A FOCUS ON
STUDENTS ADMITTED TO THE
IDENTIFICATION OF A SPECIAL
TALENT OR TREATMENT.
INCLUDING BUT NOT LIMITED TO
ATHLETIC ARTISTIC TALENT.
AT WHAT SHE MEANT.
REVIEW AND ASSESS UC AND UC
CAMPUS POLICIES AND PRACTICES
REGARDING RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
THEM THE COLLEGE BOARD AC T. AND
PRIVATE EMISSIONS CONSULTANTS.
WARM WORK RELATED TO AN AUDIT
REPORT REQUESTED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GIPSON TITLED THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA IT'S
EMISSIONS AND FINANCIAL
DECISIONS HAVE.
DECIDED.
DESERVE AND CALIFORNIA RESIDENT
STUDENTS.
REPORT FROM.
TWENTY FIFTEEN TO TWENTY
SEVENTEEN INCLUDE A THOROUGH
REVIEW OF THE UC'S EFFORT TO
IMPLEMENT THE STATE AUDITOR'S
RECOMMENDATIONS RELATED TO THE
MISSION OF NON RESIDENT
APPLICANTS.
AS WELL AS ANALYSIS OF THE
TRENDS RELATED TO THE MISSION OF
NONRESIDENT AND RESIDENT
STUDENTS SINCE TWENTY TWO AND
TWENTY ELEVEN BECAUSE THE UC IS
CURRENTLY CONDUCTING ITS OWN
REVIEW.
I WANT TO BE SENSITIVE TO ALSO
THE CAPACITY WITHIN THE
AUDITOR'S OFFICE.
AS THE STATE AUDITOR BEGAN HER
AUDIT AFTER THE UC FINISHES ITS
REVIEW OR SIX MONTHS FROM THE
DATE OF THE COMMITTEE APPROVES
THIS AUDIT REQUEST WHICHEVER
OCCURS FIRST.
AGAIN WHY KNOWLEDGE THE WORK OF
THE UC ON CONDUCTING ITS OWN
INTERNAL INVESTIGATION INTO
THESE CRIMES.
THE AUDIT CONDUCTED BY THE UC IS
BEING CONDUCTED BY CAMPUS
AUDITOR'S AND THE UC PRESIDENT
REGION'S AUDITOR'S IT'S AN
INTERNAL AUDIT IT IS NOT AN
OBJECTIVE STATE ON IT.
I BELIEVE THE MOST.
EFFECTIVE INCREDIBLE WAY TO
RESTORE OUR PUBLIC FAITH IN OUR
HIGHER EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS AS
A WITH A WITH A FAIR AN
INDEPENDENT STATE ON IT.
I ENCOURAGE THE UC'S TO CONTINUE
WORKING SYSTEM WIDE TO ADDRESS
THEIR ISSUES AND WORK WITH THE
STATE AUDITOR.
IN HER INVESTIGATION THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AND ATTENTION TO
THIS REQUEST THIS MORNING
MEMBERS AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS AUDIT
REQUEST.
THANK YOU MISS BURNER **** BATH
SIGNAL WITNESSES AT THE TABLE
WILL MOVE TO THE STATE AUDITOR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AS
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BURNER HARDCORE
VAST INDICATED.
SOME OF THE OBJECTIVES ARE
RELATED TO SYSTEM WIDE POLICIES
ARE WITH RESPECT TO ADMISSION
POLICIES AND PRACTICES BUT
REALLY.
SHE'S ASKING US TO DRILL DOWN AT
THOSE THREE INDIVIDUAL CAMPUSES
BERKELEY UCLA AND UC SAN DIEGO
AND LOOKING AT A VARIETY OF
ISSUES.
LOOKING DETERMINE WHETHER THERE
ARE PARTICULAR FACTORS -- THAT
ARE CONSIDERED WHEN DECIDING TO
ADMIT -- APPLICANTS TO THE
RESPECTIVE CAMPUSES IDENTIFYING
ANY RISKS ASSOCIATED LOOKING AT
THE PROCESS ITSELF ARE THERE
RISKS.
IN THAT PROCESS OUR WEAKNESSES
IN THAT PARTICULAR PROCESS IN
ADDITION SHE IS ASKING US TO
LOOK AT THE EXTENT TO WHICH
DONATIONS A LEGACY ADMISSIONS
ARE OR ANY OTHER TYPE OF
INFLUENCE IS FACTORING IN SOME
OF THOSE ADMISSION DECISIONS --
AGAIN AS SHE INDICATED SHE IS
ASKING US TO LOOK AT A THREE
YEAR WINDOW REALLY AGAIN
DRILLING DOWN AND DETERMINING
HOW MANY STUDENTS AT THOSE THREE
RESPECTIVE CAMPUSES WERE
ADMITTED UNDER A SPECIAL
ADMISSIONS POLICY -- WHO WAS
INVOLVED IN THAT DECISON MAKING
AND DID THEY FOLLOW THE THAT THE
POLICIES AND PROTOCOLS OF THEIR
RESPECTIVE CAMPUS -- ALSO WHEN
WE IDENTIFY THOSE STUDENTS --
WHAT CATEGORIES ARE THE AND ARE
BY THE PRIMARILY ATHLETES ARE
THERE SOME THAT WERE ADMITTED
BECAUSE THEY HAVE A SPECIAL GIFT
WITH RESPECT TO THE ARTS?
THAT SORT OF THING ALSO ASKING
US TO DETERMINE WHAT KIND OF
FOLLOW UP ARE THE UNIVERSITY
CAMPUS IS DOING TO ENSURE THAT
THOSE STUDENTS CONTINUE TO
PARTICIPATE IN A PARTICULAR
ATHLETIC.
ON THE ATHLETIC TEAMS -- ARE
THEY CONTINUING TO PARTICIPATE
AND THEN THE ACTIVITY THAT FOR
WHICH THEY WERE GIVEN SPECIAL
ADMISSION.
AND THEN WITH RESPECT -- TO ONE
MORE THING RELATED TO ADMISSIONS
IS AS AS SHE INDICATED ANY
INTERACTIONS BETWEEN NOW THE
SYSTEM AND OR THOSE CAMPUSES
WITH A C. T. COLLEGE BOARD AND
PRIVATE CONSULTANTS.
WITH RESPECT TO THE PREVIOUS
AUDIT WE HAD ISSUED -- BACK IN
MARCH OF TWENTY SIXTEEN THAT WAS
RELATED TO NON RESIDENT --
ADMISSIONS AND RESIDENT AND THAT
MORE NON RESIDENT STUDENTS HAD
BEEN ADMITTED TO CALIFORNIA OUR
UNIVERSITIES SHE'S ASKING US TO
LOOK AT THE EFFICIENCY AND
ESSENTIALLY WHATIS YOU SEE DONE
TO REACT TO THE RECOMMENDATIONS --
THAT WERE MADE IN THAT REPORT
BUT SHE'S ALSO ASKING US TO LOOK
AT TRENDS OVER THE LAST FEW
YEARS TO DETERMINE WHETHER IT'S
THERE HAS BEEN ANY CHANGE.
AS TO THE NUMBER OF RESIDENTS
STUDENTS ADMITTED TO UC SCHOOLS
ARE COMPARED TO NON RESIDENT
STUDENTS ON THE BUDGET FOR THIS
SITE IT'S ABOUT THIRTY FOUR
HUNDRED HOURS.
AGAIN THAT'S BECAUSE WE'RE GONNA
DO SOME WORK SYSTEM WIDE I KNOW
THERE HAS BEEN A RECENT REPORT
ISSUED BY THE UC AUDITOR I KNOW
HE'S IN THE AUDIENCE I'M NOT
GOING.
TO SPEAK TO IT TO THE SPECIFICS
OF HIS PARTICULAR REPORT I DID
REVIEW IT IT'S BASICALLY JUST
LOOKING TO SEE ABOUT THE
EXISTENCE OF POLICIES IT'S KIND
OF A CONTROL REVIEW.
LOOKING AT WHAT POLICIES TO EACH
OF THE CAMPUSES HAVE ARE THEIR
WEAKNESSES IN THOSE POLICY SO TO
THE EXTENT WE CAN RELY ON THAT
WORK IN THE EVENT DECIDED IS
APPROVED.
THAT WOULD REDUCE SOME OF THE
AMOUNT OF TIME WE WOULD HAVE TO
SPEND DOING THAT BUT I THINK THE
LION'S SHARE OF WHAT.
MS BOERNER HORVATH ASKING US TO
DO IS GET OUT TO THOSE THREE
CAMPUSES AND REALLY DRILL DOWN
AND UNDERSTAND WHAT'S OCCURRING
AT THOSE THOSE PARTICULAR
INSTITUTIONS -- AND AGAIN THAT'S
WHY THE HOURS ARE ARE.
SUCH THAT THEY ARE BECAUSE WE
WOULD WE WOULD NEED TO BE ON
EACH OF THOSE RESPECTIVE
CAMPUSES AND REALLY LOOKING AT
HOW MANY STUDENTS WERE ADMITTED --
WHAT WAS THE DECISION MAKING DID
THEY FOLLOW PROTOCOLS AND ARE
THEY FOLLOWING UP?
WITH RESPECT TO THOSE INDIVIDUAL
STUDENTS WITH THAT MISTER CHAIR
I WILL ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
MEMBERS MAY HAVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU MISS
BOERNER HORVATH -- FOR YOUR
COMMENTS ABOUT THE VALUE OF AN
EXTERNAL -- AUDIT AS WELL WITH
THAT LET'S GO TO MOVE TO THE
AFFECTED AGENCIES I INVITE AT
THIS TIME -- REPRESENTATIVES OF
ANY OF THE AFFECTED AGENCIES
WHICH WOULD BE THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA IN THIS CASE -- TO
THE TABLE FOR TESTIMONY.
IF YOU COULD PLEASE BE CONCISE
WITH YOUR COMMENTS WOULD
APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN SALAS AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR THE RECORD
MY NAME IS HAN MI YOUN WILL I'M
THE INTERIM ASSOCIATE VICE
PRESIDENT FOR UNDERGRADUATE
ADMISSIONS AT THE UC OFFICE OF
THE PRESIDENT.
AS THE CHIEF ADMISSIONS OFFICER
FOR THE UC SYSTEM MY ROLE IS TO
ASSIST IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF
SYSTEM WIDE ADMISSION POLICY AND
PRACTICES TO ENSURE THEY ARE.
FAIR AND SURE THERE IMPLEMENTED
IN A FAIR AND TRANSPARENT MANNER.
THE ADMISSION OFFICES AT ALL
NINE UNDERGRADUATE CAMPUSES HAVE
BEEN WORKING DILIGENTLY OVER THE
PAST SEVERAL MONTHS WITH THEIR
CAMPUS INTERNAL AUDIT TEAMS.
AS WELL AS WITH MY OFFICE AND MY
COLLEAGUE ALEX BUSTAMANTE'S
OFFICE TO IDENTIFY AND CLOSE
GAPS IN OUR ADMISSIONS PROCESS
SEES.
I BELIEVE THAT WE HAVE DONE SO
THOROUGHLY AND WITH GENUINE
DESIRE TO ENSURE THAT THE
ADMISSION PROCESS AS WORKING AS
WAS INTENDED.
I WANT TO DEFERRED THE MAJORITY
OF OUR TIME TO ALEX BUT I WANTED
TO BE PRESENT AT THIS HEARING
TODAY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THAT YOU MIGHT HAVE REGARDING
THE ADMISSIONS PROCESS.
THANK YOU PLEASE THE TIONAL
TESTIMONY.
GOOD MORNING SHERMAN CELLS AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME HERE AS
WELL MY NAME'S ALEX BUSTAMANTE
AND THE VICE PRESIDENT SENIOR
VICE PRESIDENT.
AND CHIEF COMPLIANCE NOT OFFICER
FOR THE UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA.
WITH ME TO MY RIGHT IS -- MATT
HICKS THE SYSTEM Y. DEPUTY AUDIT
OFFICER FROM MY OFFICE.
I'M RESPONSIBLE FOR DEVELOPING
AND MAINTAINING THE UNIVERSITY'S
ETHICS COMPLAINTS ABOUT A
PROGRAMS.
I'VE SERVED IN THIS CAPACITY FOR
ABOUT TWO YEARS HE WAS BROUGHT
IN AS AN INDEPENDENT VOICE TO
BOTH IDENTIFYING PROVIDE
SOLUTIONS.
AND TO IMPROVE OUR INTERNAL
PROCESSES.
MY PRIOR ROLES INCLUDE SERVING
AS AN INSPECTOR GENERAL IN A
FEDERAL PROSECUTOR AND AS SUCH
MY BACKGROUND IS PROVIDED ME THE
EXPERIENCE NECESSARY TO
COMPREHENSIVELY PERFORM THIS
FUNCTION.
SHORTLY AFTER NEWS OF THE
MISSION SCANDAL BROKE PRESIDENT
APARTADO ASK MY OFFICE. TO
PERFORM AN INDEPENDENT
ASSESSMENT OF NOT ONLY THE
ATHLETICS ADMISSIONS PRACTICES
BUT TO ALSO REVIEW ALL ASPECTS.
OF THE CAMPUS ADMISSIONS PROCESS
SEES.
MY TEAM IMMEDIATELY ENGAGED
APPROXIMATELY.
THIRTY UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA
INTERNAL AUDIT STAFF TO CONDUCT
THE AUDIT AND VALUE TO THE
INTERNAL CONTROLS OVER EVERY
UNDERGRADUATE CAMPUSES
ADMISSIONS PROCESS.
SPECIFICALLY REVIEW THE DESIGN
CONTROLS OVER UNDERGRADUATE
ADMISSIONS INCLUDING CONTROLS
OVER THE ADMISSIONS OF STUDENT
ATHLETES IN NON STANDARD
EMISSIONS.
THIS PAST THURSDAY.
MY OFFICE RELEASED THIS AUDIT
THE REPORT OUTLINED SEVERAL
STEPS THE UNIVERSITY CAN TAKE TO
FURTHER STRENGTHEN OUR SYSTEMS.
AND THEREBY MINIMIZE EVERY
OPPORTUNITY THERE IS FOR BAD
ACTUALLY TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
POTENTIAL GAPS IN OUR SYSTEMS.
WE MADE OVER THIRTY
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE OVERSEEN
CAMPUSES IMPLEMENTATION OF ALL
OF THEM.
THESE RECOMMENDATIONS INCLUDE
ENHANCEMENTS TO DOCUMENTATION
SUPPORTING ADMISSIONS DECISIONS.
ADDITIONAL PROVE ALSO
DOCUMENTATION REQUIREMENTS FOR
SPECIAL TALENT ADMISSIONS.
AND NEW POLICIES AND PROCEDURES
TO ADDRESS CONFLICTS OF INTEREST
AMONG OTHERS.
THIS WAS JUST THE FIRST OF TWO
AUDITS THE MY TEAM WILL CONDUCT.
THE SECOND AUDIT IS NECESSARY TO
EVALUATE THE EXTENT OF YOUR
ORGANIZATIONS IT HEARINGS TO
POLICIES AND CONTROLS OVER
UNDERGRADUATES MISSIONS.
IT WILL ALSO INCLUDE A DETAILED
ANALYSIS OF ADMISSIONS DATA
INCLUDING CATEGORIES OF STUDENTS
ADMITTED BY EXCEPTION.
MY TEAM ONE ISSUE THE SECOND
AUDIT NEXT MONTH AND WE INTEND
COMPLETED EARLY NEXT YEAR.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO KNOW THAT THE
REPORT THAT I REPORT DIRECTLY TO
THE REGION SOME FUNCTIONS AND
INDEPENDENT AUTHORITY. TO REVIEW
AUDIT AND EVALUATE UNIVERSITIES
COMPLIANCE WITH LAW REGULATION
POLICY UNETHICAL PRINCIPLES.
MY TEAM AND I TAKE OUR
INDEPENDENCE IN OUR OBLIGATIONS
QUITE SERIOUSLY.
MY JOB IS NOT TO DOWNPLAY ISSUES
WITH THE UNIVERSITY'S ADMISSION
PROCESS SEES.
MY JOB IS CALL BALLS AND STRIKES
IRRESPECTIVE OF THE PERCEIVED
CONSEQUENCES.
I'M CONFIDENT MY TEAM'S ABILITY
TO PROVIDE INDEPENDENT OVERSIGHT
OVER OUR OPERATIONS AND TO
ENSURE THAT THE ISSUES WE
IDENTIFIER CORRECTED.
UPON COMPLETION OF THE SECOND
AUDIT MY OFFICE WILL ADDRESSED
ALL OF THE FRAUD RISKS DISCUSSED
IN THE REQUEST LETTER TO THE
STATE AUDITOR'S OFFICE.
ADDITIONALLY WE WILL HAVE CHIEF
EVEN GREATER COVERAGE OF THE
UNIVERSITY'S ADMISSIONS PROCESS
AS WE EXAMINE EXAMINING ALL NINE
UNDERGRADUATE CAMPUSES.
WE'VE MADE SIGNIFICANT
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR IMPROVEMENT
IN THE REPORT BEFORE YOU INTEND
TO START THE NEXT PHASE OF OUR
AUDIT TO THE ADMISSIONS PROCESS
NEXT MONTH.
THE UNIVERSITY WILL FOCUS ON
IMPLEMENTING THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS IN A TIMELY
MANNER SO AS TO FURTHER
STRENGTHEN STRENGTHEN OUR
ADMISSIONS PROCESS.
WELL MY TEAM AND I PERFORM THE
SECOND PHASE OF OUR AUDIT.
YOU CAN EXPECT THE SAME CANDOR
INDEPENDENCE FOR ME IN THAT
SECOND AUDIT.
AND THANK YOU AND I'M AVAILABLE
TAKING QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU APPRECIATE THE
TESTIMONY -- LET ME.
LET ME JUST ASK A QUICK QUESTION
KIND OF BASED OFF OF THE
RESEARCHERS ARE DOING.
HOW LONG HAS THE THE INTERNAL
AUDIT SHOP CALLING OF YOU GUYS
BEEN IN EXISTENCE? TEN YEARS
ABOUT TEN YEARS THIS ARE OKAY
WITH THAT WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO
QUESTIONS FROM THE DíAS --
SENATOR ROTH PLEASE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR USE THE WORD --
CANDOR AND I HAVE TO SAY I DID
REVIEW YOUR FIRST REPORT -- AND
I AM IMPRESSED WITH THE CANDOR
WITH WHICH YOU AND YOUR
OPERATION ADDENDA FIDE
WEAKNESSES -- IN THE UC SYSTEM
AN ADVERSE INDIVIDUAL CAMPUSES
THAT'S SOMETIMES UNUSUAL IN
STATE GOVERNMENT AND I COMMEND
YOU FOR DOING SO -- I I DID
NOTICE THAT IN IN YOUR REPORT
CAMPUSES IN CERTAIN
CIRCUMSTANCES APPEAR TO HAVE
LOCAL OPTIONS WITH RESPECT TO
ADMISSIONS PRACTICES AND
PROCESSES THAT ARE IN PLACE.
AND I'M I'M WONDERING.
WHY WE DON'T STANDARDIZE SOME OF
THOSE PROCESSES BUT I GUESS I
LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR SECOND
REPORT?
A TO SEE HOW YOU DEAL WITH THAT --
IT WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT CONTROLS.
I ASSUME THAT -- WHEN YOU ISSUE
THESE TWO REPORTS THAT THERE'S
BACKUP DATA THAT'S ATTACHED TO
THEM AS WOULD BE TRUE IN A
STANDARD AUDIT SITUATION?
THAT'S CORRECT.
SO WHEN YOU COMPLETE THE NOT
ONLY THIS YOU'VE COMPLETED THIS
FIRST REPORT WHEN YOU COMPLETE
YOUR SECOND REPORT.
A WILL WILL YOU BE IN A POSITION
TO PROVIDE BOTH REPORTS AND THE
BACKUP DATA SUPPORTING YOUR
FINDINGS AND CONCLUSIONS TO OUR
STATE AUDITOR.
WE WOULD YES OKAY.
SO.
I COMMEND THE AUTHOR -- IN TERMS
OF RAW -- RESPECTING THE PROCESS
AND AND ALLOWING THE INTERNAL
AUDIT TO PROCEED -- TO GO TO ITS
COMPLETION -- SO WE DON'T
DUPLICATE EFFORT AT UNLESS IT'S
NECESSARY TO DO SO.
AND THANK YOU MADAM STATE WATER
AUDITOR FOR YOUR COMMENTS I
WOULD ASK THAT -- WHEN YOU
RECEIVE A BOTH AUDIT REPORTS
THAT YOU TAKE A LOOK AT THEM
YOUR STAFF IN THE BACK OF DATA?
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE IF THIS
AUDIT IS APPROVED AND PROCEEDS.
FORWARD THAT WE DON'T DUPLICATE
EFFORT WHEN IT'S NOT NECESSARY
TO DO SO HOWEVER THIS IS A VERY --
HIGH VOLTAGE ISSUE -- THAT NEEDS
TO BE ADDRESSED AND AND RESOLVED
AND SO I THANK YOU FOR AGREEING
TO TAKE ON OF THE TASK.
I THINK THAT IS ALL THAT I
WANTED -- TO TO SAY ON THIS
POINT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
RIGHT.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
FROM THE DIET SENATOR MINING
PLACE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
I ALSO WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR THE WILLINGNESS.
TO KINDA STAGER SEQUENCE --
INITIATION OF A STATE ON IT I
GUESS PURSUING THEIR LITTLE
LITTLE BIT MORE.
IT'S HARD TO KNOW WE WE WE DON'T
KNOW WHAT'S GOING TO BE RETURNED
IN THIS SECOND INTERNAL AUDIT --
IN WELL -- SENATOR ROTH
SUGGESTED.
ADAPTING A STATE AUDIT BASED ON
GAPS OR AREAS FOR FURTHER
INQUIRY -- I'M JUST WONDERING IF
IF WE WILL HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY.
IN IN THE OPERATION OF OF OF
THIS LEGISLATIVE AUDIT COMMITTEE.
TO ALSO HAVE ACCESS TO THAT
SECOND ON IT.
AND HAVE A TOUCH POINT
POTENTIALLY THE FUTURE MEETING
IN THE FALLWHERE THERE'S SOME
CONSENSUS.
PRIORITIZATION WOULD THAT BE
MAYBE I'LL DIRECT THIS QUESTION
TO THE AUDITOR HAVE YOU FACED A
CIRCUMSTANCE LIKE THIS.
IN THE PAST.
THE CLOSEST CIRCUMSTANCE TO
SOMETHING LIKE THIS IN THE PAST
IS IS WAITING OR DELAYING
COMMENCING AN AUDIT BECAUSE
THERE'S THERE'S EITHER ON ON
THERE'S LITIGATION OR THERE'S ON
GOING ON AT WORK AND AND TO
ANSWER SENATOR ROSS QUESTION OR
COMMENT.
WE ARE REQUIRED BY STANDARDS TO
CONSIDER ANY WORK THAT'S ALREADY
BEEN DONE WHAT WE WOULD LOOK AT
IN THOSE WORK PAPERS IS HOW THEY
WENT ABOUT CONDUCTING THEIR WORK --
HAVE GREAT RESPECT FOR MISTER
BUSTAMANTE I DON'T KNOW A LOT
ABOUT THE INTERNAL AUDIT
FUNCTIONS AT THE VARIOUS
CAMPUSES -- I KNOW WHAT MY STAFF
CAN DO -- BUT AS FAR AS YOUR
QUESTION SENATOR THE THE ONLY
REALLY PRECEDENT FOR SOMETHING
LIKE THIS IS DELAYING THE
COMMENCEMENT OF A PARTICULAR
AUDIT I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
SCOPE OF THIS SECOND REVIEW THAT.
THE UC AUDITOR AND AND THE
INTERNAL AUDITORS INTEND TO DO --
AS AS IS BOERNER HORVATH SAID
SHE SPECIFICALLY ASKING US TO
DRILL DOWN AT THREE PARTICULAR
CAMPUSES -- I DON'T KNOW AGAIN I
I CAN'T SPEAK TO BECAUSE I DON'T
KNOW WHAT THE SCOPE OF THE ON
IT'S GONNA BE IS AS FAR AS WHAT
THE UC IS INTENDING TO DO -- BUT
AS FAR AS PRESIDENT IT'S REALLY
BEEN MORE OF A DELAY -- IN
DETERMINING.
IF THE COMMITTEE WOULD APPROVE A
REQUEST AND THEN ASK US TO DELAY
COMMENCING THE AUDIT.
IT IS PART OF THAT DELAY YOU
WOULD A DAT TO THE INFORMATION
IT'S AT YOUR DISPOSAL.
ABSOLUTELY AT AND AGAIN AT UC
HAS ASSERTED THEY WILL SHARE THE
INFORMATION WITH US I MEAN WE
WOULD HAVE ACCESS TO THE
INFORMATION SO I WOULD MAKE SURE
WE GET IT -- BUT I KNOW HE WOULD
FULLY COOPERATE SO WE WOULD LOOK
AT AS I DID I MEAN I REVIEWED
THE FIRST REPORT BECAUSE I
WANTED TO BE PREPARED FOR
TODAY'S HEARING TO DETERMINE.
WHAT WAS THE SCOPE AND AS HE
INDICATED IT WAS REALLY LOOKING
AT WHAT POLICIES EXIST OUT THERE
WHAT CONTROLS AND ARE THEIR
WEAKNESSES AND SOME OF THOSE
POLICIES BECAUSE THERE IS
DISCRETION AT VARIOUS CAMPUSES --
THERE IS SOME -- BORDER REGION
POLICY OUT THERE AS FAR AS THAT
THE PERCENTAGE OF INDIVIDUALS
CAN THAT CAN BE ADMITTED UNDER
THIS PARTICULAR -- SPECIAL
ADMISSION BY EXCEPTION AND HE
INDICATES IN HIS REPORT THAT
THERE WAS AT LEAST ONE CAMPUS
THAT EXCEEDED THAT THAT DIDN'T
COMPLY WITH THAT POLICY SO I
WOULD REALLY BE INTERESTED IN
UNDERSTANDING THE SCOPE OF THE
NEXT REVIEW WE WOULD ABSOLUTELY
LOOK AT THIS ONE WANT TO LOOK AT
THE WORK.
PAPERS IN DETAIL ON THIS ONE AS
SOON AS THEY ISSUE THE NEXT
REPORT ON MY STAFF WOULD CALL
THROUGH THAT REPORT LOOK AT THE
WORK PAPERS AND DETERMINE IF WE
CAN RELY ON THE WORK WE WILL
BECAUSE WE DON'T WANT TO
DUPLICATE.
IF WE CAN'T THEN WE'RE GONNA GO
OUT AND DO THE WORK OURSELVES
THANK YOU AND FOR THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER.
YOU'VE SELECTED THESE THREE
CAMPUSES FROM.
I GUESS.
FIRST QUESTION WHY THOSE THREE
CAMPUSES FOLLOW UP.
BASED ON THE ORDER REPORT
INTERNAL HONORED REPORT NOT YET
RECEIVED -- WOULD THERE BE ANY
PROSPECT OF CHANGING THE FOCUS
OF THE CAMPUSES BASED ON WHAT
YOU MIGHT LEARN.
ON THE INTERNAL ON IT SO THE
THREE CAMPUSES WERE CHOSEN
BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY UC BERKELEY CA
LAYING UCSD -- BOTH HAVE HIGH
LEVELS OF EMISSIONS UNDER -- THE
SPECIAL.
SPECIAL ADMISSIONS NATIONAL
EMISSIONS PROCESS THAT'S WHY
THEY WERE CHOSEN FOR THAT.
THANK YOU MOM THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR NO FURTHER QUESTIONS THANK
YOU WITH THAT WILL GO TO MOVE
BACK TO SENATOR OFFICE AMANDA
MARTYR WHAT IWOULD ASK IS AFTER
YOU COMPLETE YOUR REVIEW OF THE
INTERNAL AUDIT REPORTS IN THE
BACK OF DATA.
WOULD YOU NOTIFY THE CHAIR AND
THE VICE CHAIR -- TO THE EXTENT
THAT YOUR AUDIT NEEDS TO BE
MODIFIED THE THE SCOPE OF THE
OTHER NEEDS TO BE CHANGED --
THERE HASN'T BEEN PRESIDENT FOR
THAT IN THE PAST THAT THE
CONCERN THAT I WOULD HAVE -- IS
WELL THAT WOULD BE YOUR CALL.
RIGHT I JUST WANTED TO MAKE SURE
IF IF WE DECIDE WE NEED TO
COMMENCE AN AUDIT ONCE AN AUDIT
IS COMMENCED WHAT WE'RE DOING IS
CONFIDENTIAL BUT CERTAINLY -- HI
BY THIS IS THAT THERE IS YOU
ALWAYS ASK DIFFICULT WELL TO THE
CENTER. FOR WHAT IS NOT
CONFIDENTIAL.
ARE THE ISSUES THAT YOU'RE
LOOKING AT AND SO MY QUESTION IS
IF THOSE ISSUES NEED TO BE
MODIFIED. FOR EXAMPLE THERE SIX
AND YOU YOU CAN DELETE NUMBER
SIX AND WORK ON FIVE THAT'S WHAT
I WOULD BE ASKING NOT. TO KNOW
WHAT YOU'RE DOING IN YOUR AUDIT
OR WHAT YOU FOUND AS A
PRELIMINARY MATTER.
MY ONLY INTEREST IS IN AVOIDING
DUPLICATION SO IF YOU REVIEW
BOTH REPORTS IN THE BACK OF DATA.
AND THE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS AS FOR
FIVE POINTS AND YOU ONLY NEED TO
LOOK AT FOR BECAUSE THE FIFTH
ONE IS COVERED.
THAT'S WHAT I WOULD ASK THAT YOU
NOTIFY THE CHAIR AND THE VICE
CHAIR BUT DOES THAT WORK YES
CENTER ABSOLUTELY CAN DO THAT.
THANK YOU MISTER THANK YOU WE
ASK THERE'S ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
FROM THE DíAS.
HEARING AND SEEING -- NINE Là
BE GOOD TO MOVE TO PUBLIC
COMMENTS.
SO AT THIS TIME WE INVITE PUBLIC
COMMENTIF YOU PLEASE STATE YOUR
NAME YOUR POSITION ON THE AUDITS.
AND IF YOU COULD PLEASE BE
CONCISE WITH YOUR REMARKS.
HEARING AND SEEING.
NO PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS ITEM --
MISS BERNHARDT BOTH WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH COLLEAGUES --
I RESPECTFULLY ASK OF FOR
SUPPORT OF THE STATE ON IT IT'S
CRUCIAL THAT WE RESTORE PUBLIC
TRUST IN OUR EXCELLENT PUBLIC A
HIGHER EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU FOR THAT AT
THIS TIME -- WE'RE GOING TO TURN
BACK TO THE DíAS.
AND WE WILL ASK FOR A A VOTE ON
THIS ITEM BUT FIRST LET ME FIRST
STATE -- THAT WE DO APPRECIATE --
MISSED POLISARIO AND YOU SEE
ACTUALLY DOING THEIR INTERNAL
INVESTIGATIONS -- OBVIOUSLY WE
READ A LOT OF HEADLINES -- FROM
MANY PAPERS UP AND DOWN STATE
AND ACROSS THE COUNTRY --
IDENTIFYING SOME OF THE ISSUES
APPRECIATE THE UC LOOKING INTO
IT -- I KNOW MISS BERNHARDT
ABOUT DID STATE IN HER OPENING
COMMENTS THE VALUE OF AN
EXTERNAL AUDIT.
AND WHAT THAT BRINGS IN TERMS OF
ACTUALLY TRUST.
RING THAT TRUST BACK TO THE
SYSTEM INTO THE UNIVERSITY SO
WE'D LIKE TO COMMEND THE UC. FOR
FOR THEIR FOR THEIR WORK.
AND AND WHAT THEIR AUDIT BUT
ALSO -- SEE THE VALUE IN THE
EXTRA AND GOT HER COMING IN AS
WELL -- WITH THAT MR HARD BATH
IN HER LETTER DID -- ASK.
FOR MY GUESS AT THIS TIME IT'S
INNER YOUR LETTER BUT ALSO AT
THIS TIME I GUESS I'D ASK FOR A
MOTION -- TO MOVE THIS BERNHARDT
US AUDIT BUT WITH THE
STIPULATION OF WHEN THE UC
FINISHES ITS REVIEW OR SIX
MONTHS FROM APPROVAL OF TODAY'S
COMMITTEE.
JUST MAKE IT CLEAR.
SO WITH THAT ASK FOR A MOTION.
MOTION BY CENTER GONZALEZ SECOND
BY MISTER PATTERSON -- WITH THAT
MR SECTOR CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO APPROVE AUDIT
NUMBER TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
DASH ONE ONE THREE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA ADMISSION POLICIES
AND PRACTICES BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BERNHARDT ABOUT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS HI.
SALAS HI BOERNER HORVATH HI
BOERNER HORVATH HI DEEP
[inaudible]
PATTERSON.
PATTERSON I RUBIO [inaudible]
VOEPEL.
VOEPEL I WOULD [inaudible]
WHAT I [inaudible]
SENATOR ROTH.
ROTH HI GORGEOUS [inaudible]
GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG.
MORNING.
MONNING AYE MOORLACH
[inaudible]
SENATOR WIENER [inaudible]
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT.
WELL HOLD THAT WELL THE ROLE
OPEN ON THAT ITEM -- MISS
BOERNER HORVATH IF YOU'D LIKE TO
MOVE ON TO AGENDA ITEM NUMBER.
FIVE TWENTY NINETEEN DASH ONE
ONE FOUR CSU STUDENT FEES.
YES UGH GOOD MORNING CHAIR I
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE AUDIT
COMMITTEE APPROVE A STATE AUDIT
TO EXAMINE.
THE INCREASE IN THE NUMBER OF
AND THE AMOUNT OF CAMPUS BASED
STUDENT FEES FOR SELECT
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
CAMPUSES.
WE ALL KNOW THAT COLLEGE
AFFORDABILITY IS A SIGNIFICANT
CONCERN FOR STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES IN CALIFORNIA. FOR THE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN TWENTY NINETEEN
ACADEMIC YEAR TUITION FOR FULL A
FULL TIME UNDERGRADUATE CSU
STUDENT IS 500-070-0402 DOLLARS.
HOWEVER IN ADDITION TO THE COST
OF CSU TUITION THERE'S BEEN AN
INCREASE IN THE LAST THREE YEARS
OF CAMPUS BASED FEES.
INCLUDING BUT NOT LIMITED TO
STUDENT SUCCESS FEES MATERIALS
SERVICES.
YEAH MATERIALS SERVICES THE
FACILITY FEES AND STUDENT CENTER
FEES.
THESE ADDITIONAL FEES COULD ADD
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS TO THE
TOTAL COST OF ATTENDANCE.
AT CAL POLY SAN LUIS OBISPO FOR
EXAMPLE THESE ADDITIONAL FEES
REYES STUDENTS COST OF A TO BUY
ADDITIONAL FOUR THOUSAND SEVENTY
FOUR DOLLARS PER YEAR OVER THE
BASE TUITION. TO A TOTAL OF NINE
THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED SEVENTY
SIX DOLLARS.
AND THESE ARE THE NUMBERS THAT
DO NOT EVEN INCLUDE HOUSING
BOOKS OR ANY OTHER COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH ATTENDING
COLLEGE.
THIS IS ALSO ENVIRONMENT WERE
RECENT RESEARCH INDICATES THE
41% OF CSU STUDENTS REPORT OF
FOOD INSECURITY AND TEN POINT 9%
OF STUDENTS REPORTED
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS.
AT ONE OR MORE TIMES IN THE LAST
TWELVE MONTHS.
EVERY PENNY COUNTS FOR MANY OF
OUR STUDENTS AND SO IT'S
CRITICAL THAT THE CSU PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL TRANSPARENCY.
ON CAMPUS BASED FEES STUDENT
FEES. TO THIS END I AM A
QUESTION THE STATE WATER FOCUS
ON FOUR CAMPUSES DISTRIBUTED
THROUGHOUT THE STATE INCLUDING
CSU CHICO CSU SAN LUIS OBISPO
CSU SAN DIEGO.
AND SEE IF YOU SAN JOSE STATE.
AND CSU SAN JOSE.
IN PREPARING FOR THIS REQUEST IT
WAS DISCOVERED THAT THERE ARE
SIX CATEGORIES OF COMMON CAMPUS
BASED FEES OFTEN POSED ON
STUDENTS.
THESE FEES CATEGORIES INCLUDE
HEALTH FACILITIES HEALTH
SERVICES.
INSTRUCTION UP A CONSTRUCTION
LEE RELATED ACTIVITIES MATERIAL
SERVICES AND FACILITIES STUDENT
SUCCESS AND STUDENT CENTER.
THE AUDIT SHOULD PROVIDE
INFORMATION ON HOW OFTEN AND BY
HOW MUCH FEES WERE INCREASED
OVER THE LAST FIVE YEARS.
IN EACH OF THE SIX AVAILABLE
CATEGORIES IN EACH OF THE CAL
CAMPUS THE SELECTED FOR THE
AUDIT.
AND ANSWER SOME BASIC QUESTIONS
INCLUDING WHAT IS THE PROCESS
FOR ORIGINATING APPROVING AND
IMPLEMENTING A STUDENT FEE.
DO ANY OF THESE CAMPUSES REQUIRE
A STUDENT VOTE TO ADOPT THESE
FEES.
HOW MUCH DO STUDENT FEES ADD TO
THE TOTAL COST OF ATTENDANCE?
AT THESE SPECIFIC CAMPUSES.
ARE ANY OPTIONAL ARE THEY
COVERED BY FINANCIAL AID.
ARE THE FUNDS GET COLLECTED KEPT
IN A SEPARATE MISSION SPECIFIC
ACCOUNTS OR ARE THEY COMMINGLED.
WHAT SAFEGUARDS ARE IN PLACE TO
ENSURE FUNDS ARE EXPENDED ON
WHAT THEY WERE INTENDED?
FOR THIS CSU HAVE A SYSTEM WHY
PAUL SYSTEM MY POLICIES IN PLACE
GOVERNING THE ADOPTION OF THE
STUDENT FEES.
THIS REQUEST COMES AT A TIME
WHEN RECENTLY COMPLETED STATE
AUDIT BY THE STATE AUDITOR WE
FEEL THAT SEAT REVEALED THAT CSU
HAD ACCRUED A PREVIOUSLY
UNREVEALED SURPLUS OF OVER ONE
POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS.
WELL STUDENT TUITION OVER THE
SAME PERIOD CONTINUE TO INCREASE.
THE CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
IS THE LARGEST SYSTEM OF HIGHER
EDUCATION IN THE COUNTRY WITH
TWENTY THREE CAMPUSES FIFTY
THOUSAND FACULTY AND STAFF.
OF FOUR HUNDRED AND EIGHTY FOUR
THOUSAND STUDENTS.
WE OWE IT TO THE STUDENTS AND
THEIR FAMILIES TO ENSURE THAT WE
DO EVERYTHING WE CAN TO MINIMIZE
ACOSTA SODI ASSOCIATED WITH
HIGHER EDUCATION.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
ATTENTION TO THIS REQUEST THIS
MORNING MEMBERS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT ON THIS ON A REQUEST
HERE TODAY TO SUPPORT THE AUDIT
REQUEST THIS IS AN GREEN.
A FACULTY MEMBER FROM CSU CHICO.
THANK YOU WILL MOVE TO YOUR
WITNESS AND SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR SALAS AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS SUSAN GREEN AND I'M A FACULTY
MEMBER CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY CHICO.
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FACULTY ASSOCIATION WHICH
REPRESENTS TWENTY NINE THOUSAND
FACULTY FROM CAMPUSES ARE FROM
ALL TWENTY THREE OF OUR CAMPUSES
AND CALIFORNIA STATE.
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM WE'RE HERE TO
SUPPORT THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BORDER HER GRAPHS AUDIT REQUEST
OF CAMPUS BASED STUDENT FEES IN
THE CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY.
I WANTED TO DRAW YOUR ATTENTION
TO A SIMPLE CHART THAT WAS
CREATED BY THE CSU WHICH WERE
PROVIDED TO MANY OF YOUR STAFF
AND TO SOME OF YOU IN PERSON.
OUR AS WE DISCUSS THIS AUDIT
YOU'LL SEE THAT AT LEAST ONE
CASE THE CAMPUS BASED STUDENT
FEES ARE SO HIGH THAT THEY
ALMOST DOUBLE THE TUITION FOR
THE SAN LUIS OBISPO CAMPUS WHICH
THE MEMBER JUST MENTIONED.
I ALSO WANT TO POINT OUT THE AT
IF WE LOOK AT THAT SAME CHART IT
SHOWS THAT SOME CAMPUSES A
CHARGE SOME TYPE OF FEES AND
OTHERS DO NOT. FOR EXAMPLE THE
STUDENT SUCCESS BE CAN BE AS
HIGH AS A HUNDRED FIFTY FOUR
DOLLARS AT SAN LUIS OBISPO. SIX
HUNDRED AND FIFTY FOUR DOLLARS
AT SAN JOSE WHILE SOME CAMPUSES
CHARGE ZERO WHY IS THAT.
I ALSO WANTED TO PROVIDE A MORE
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE STORY I'M A
FACULTY MEMBER AT CHICO STATE
AND IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE
CAMPUS ADOPTED THREE CAMPUS
BASED STUDENT FEE INCREASES. FOR
HEALTH SERVICES STUDENT LEARNING
AND ATHLETICS OVER THE REJECTION
OF THE STUDENTS.
GOVERNOR BROWN PROVIDED
ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO THE SYSTEM
DEPENDENT ON NO TUITION
INCREASES IN.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN TWENTY NINETEEN
AND STUDENTS NATURALLY ASSUMED
THAT THIS WOULD INCLUDE CAMPUS
BASED FEES IN THE SAME SPIRIT.
BUT THAT WAS NOT THE CASE.
STUDENTS WERE LEFT QUESTIONING
WHETHER THE FEES WERE NECESSARY
AND HOW THEY WERE SPENT
PARTICULARLY IN REGARDS TO
MENTAL HEALTH ACCESS AND WAIT
TIMES WHICH DID NOT IMPROVE
DESPITE THE INCREASED REVENUES
FROM ALL SOURCES.
AS YOU ARE AWARE THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE AUDIT.
THEY CAME OUT LAST WEEK OF THE
CSU -- HAVE ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS IN OUTSIDE
ACCOUNTS RAISES QUESTIONS FOR
THE LEGISLATURE AND FOR US AS
WELL.
THE CSU MAY NOT HAVE DONE
ANYTHING WRONG BUT CLEARLY
DEMONSTRATES THE NEED FOR
GREATER TRANSPARENCY AND
COMMUNICATIONS SURROUNDING
REVENUES.
THE STUDENTS THEIR PARENTS THE
TAXPAYERS ARE YOU YOURSELVES
DESERVE MORE THAN OPEC CHAU
GAMES FROM THE CSU.
WE ASK THAT YOU ADOPT THIS AUDIT
SO THAT AT A MINIMUM WE HAVE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY
IN REGARDS TO CAMPUS BASED
STUDENT FEES.
AND THE AUDIT MAY SHED A LIGHT
ON SOMETHING THAT THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE PUBLIC WOULD
LIKE TO TAKE FURTHER ACTION ON
TO CORRECT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WITH THAT WE WILL GO
TO MOVE TO THE STATE AUDITOR'S
PRESENTATION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AS ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BERNHARDT BATH INDICATED -- WE'D
BE LOOKING AT THE CSU SYSTEM
STARTING OUT LOOKING AT BOTH THE
BOARD OF TRUSTEES IN THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE WITH RESPECT
TO THE ADOPTION ANY POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES ARE GUIDES THAT COMES.
FROM HEADQUARTERS ESSENTIALLY
ARE TO THE CAMPUSES BUT THE
AGAIN THE FOR INDIVIDUAL
CAMPUSES IS WHERE WE WOULD DRILL
DOWN AND GO OUT AND LOOK AT EACH
OF THOSE CAMPUSES SHE'S ASKING
US TO LOOK AT A FIVE YEAR WINDOW.
AND LOOK AT THE PROCESS FOR
ORIGINATING APPROVING
IMPLEMENTING A FEE IF THERE HAVE
BEEN FEE INCREASES HOW DID THAT
HAPPEN.
IN THE EVENT THERE NEEDED TO BE
A STUDENT REFERENDUM DID THAT
OCCUR -- IF THE STUDENTS
REJECTED THE THE PARTICULAR FEE
INCREASE WAS IT WAS IT.
SATISFIED IN SOME OTHER WAY.
IS A QUESTION SHE'S ASKED
CERTAINLY ASKING ABOUT THE
IMPACT AND THE IMPLICATIONS WITH
RESPECT TO THE COST OF ATTENDING
THOSE FOR PARTICULAR
INSTITUTIONS -- TO THE EXTENT
POSSIBLE WE WILL DETERMINE
WHETHER OR NOT STUDENTS ARE ABLE
TO USE FINANCIAL AID TO IT TO
PAY FOR SOME OF THE SPECIES.
AND LOOKING AT SOME OF THE
BACKGROUND MATERIALS TO PREPARE
FOR THE HEARING I SAW THERE ARE
SOME INSTANCES WHERE STUDENTS
CANNOT USE FINANCIAL AID.
SO THERE ARE CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE
STUDENTS ARE HAVING TO PAY THIS
OUT OF POCKET AND WE WOULD BE
ABLE.
TO CONDUCT THAT TYPE OF ANALYSIS
DETERMINE WHICH FEES OUR
STUDENTS CAN USE FINANCIAL AID
TO PAY FOR AN AND THOSE FOR
WHICH THEY CANNOT -- WHAT
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES ARE EACH
OF THE CAMPUS'S ENGAGING IN TO
MAKE SURE THAT IF THE FEE
REVENUE IS GENERATED FOR A
PARTICULAR PURPOSE THAT THE
EXPENDITURES AND WE WOULD TEST
EXPENDITURES TO MAKE SURE?
THAT THOSE CAMPUSES WERE ONLY
USING THOSE FUNDS FOR THOSE
PARTICULAR PURPOSE IS TO PROVIDE
ASSURANCE KNOWING TO STUDENTS
AND PARENTS BUT THE GENERAL
PUBLIC THAT.
THE INSTITUTIONS ARE BEING
FISCAL STEWARDS OF THESE FUNDS
ARE THE REVENUES THAT ARE
GENERATED -- AND THEN A COUPLE
OF FINAL OBJECTIVES DETERMINE
WHETHER THE CAMPUS BASED
REVENUES ARE FUNDING PROGRAMS OR
SERVICES. FOR THAT WERE NOT
INCLUDED IN THE PARTICULAR RIFF
REFERENDUM SO IS MONEY BEING
GENERATED AND USED FOR OTHER
PURPOSES SIMILAR TO THE
EXPENDITURE TESTING WE'RE DOING
BUT HOLISTICALLY LOOKING AT AT
AT SOME OF THE STUDENT FEES.
ARE AND THEN WHAT KIND OF
MECHANISMS DO THE CAMPUSES
ENGAGE AND TO INFORM STUDENTS
NOT JUST ABOUT THE A PARTICULAR
A FEE THAT MAY BE.
NEEDING STUDENT APPROVAL OR AND
ARE INCREASING BY.
THE USE OF THOSE FUNDS OF THE
STUDENTS IMPROVE THEIR THE
REFERENDUM AND THAT THERE IS NOW
AN ADDITIONAL FEE.
HOW WELL DO THOSE RESPECTIVE
CAMPUSES COMMUNICATE WITH THE
STUDENT BODY AS TO HOW THAT
MONEY IS BEING USED -- AND WHAT
BENEFITS ARE BEING DERIVED FROM
THAT PARTICULAR REVENUE -- THE
HOURS FOR THIS AUDIT THIRTY TWO
HUNDRED HOURS AGAIN WE'RE GONNA
VISIT FOUR CAMPUSES WE'RE GONNA
GO THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE DOWN
IN LONG BEACH -- CERTAINLY HAVE
SOME INFORMATION ARE GATHERING
WITH RESPECT TO DECISIONS AT THE
BOARD OF TRUSTEES HAVE MADE AND
WHAT GUIDANCE THEY'VE PROVIDED
TO THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE AND
CERTAINLY -- TO THOSE FOUR
CAMPUSES WE WERE WE WERE
REFERRING TO WITH THAT MISTER
CHAIR I WILL ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS MEMBERS HAVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION
AT THIS TIME WE'RE GONNA GO TO
MOVE TO THE AFFECTED AGENCIES OF
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY IS
HERE.
PLEASE BEGIN BY STATING YOUR
NAME. FOR THE RECORD WOULD
APPRECIATE THAT.
PLEASE PROCEED WITH TESTIMONY.
A GOOD MORNING ON BEHALF OF THE
CSU OFFICE OF THE CHANCELLOR
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE THE UNIVERSITIES
PERSPECTIVE.
AS YOU CONSIDER AN AUDIT ON CSU
CAMPUS BASED FEES.
MY NAME IS RYAN STORM HIGH IN
THE SYSTEM VICE CHANCELLOR FOR
BUDGET FOR THE OFFICE OF THE
CHANCELLOR WITH ME AS ASSOCIATE
VICE CHANCELLOR -- FOR BUSINESS
FINANCE BRED WELLS WHO'S HERE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS ALONG WITH
ME -- ON YOUR ON THIS -- ON THIS
AUDIT -- FOR MYSELF I'M.
A PARTICULAR RESPONSIBLE FOR
MATTERS RELATED TO STUDENT FEES --
AS ALL DESCRIBING A MOMENT THERE
ARE MANY TYPES OF FEES OF THE
SEA ISSUE.
AND IT IS IMPORTANT NOTE THAT
FEES PAY FOR DIRECT SERVICES AND
RESOURCES SUCH AS THE USE OF
STUDENT RECREATIONAL FAILITIES.
HEALTH SERVICES AND INSTRUCTION
RELATED ACTIVITIES.
OUR STUDENTS RECEIVE -- DIRECT
BENEFITS FROM THESE FEES THEY
ENHANCE OR SUPPLEMENT THE
EDUCATIONAL EXPERIENCE OF THIS
ISSUE.
WITH THAT SAID A GOAL OF OURS IS
TO KEEP COLLEGE AFFORDABLE FOR
OUR STUDENTS.
SALOME TO CLARIFY SOME OF THE
QUESTIONS THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED
AS YOU CONSIDER THIS AUDIT.
WHEN THE QUESTIONS WAS DOES THE
BOARD OF TRUSTEES HAVE POLICIES
IN PLACE FOR THE ADOPTION OF
CAMPUS BASED STUDENT FEES OR THE
IS DETERMINED?
ON A CAMPUS BY CAMPUS BASIS SO
THE ANSWER IS YES ABSOLUTELY THE
TRUSTEES HAVE A COMPREHENSIVE
STUDENT FEE POLICY DATING. TO
NINETEEN NINETY SIX BUT GOVERNS
THIS PROCESS AS WELL AS OTHER
TYPES OF FEES.
THE MOST CURRENT VERSION OF THAT
STUDENT FEE POLICY IS IN
EXECUTIVE ORDER.
ONE THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED TWO AND
CAN BE FOUND ON OUR INTERNET
SITE.
ANOTHER QUESTION THAT WAS POSED
A WHAT ARE THE CATEGORIES OF
FEES AND FOR WHAT SPECIFIC
PURPOSES CAN THOSE FUNDS BE
EXPENDED.
NOT A STUDENT FEE POLICY
ESTABLISHES SIX CATEGORIES OF
FEES WHICH IS NOT TO BE CONFUSED
WITH THE SIX TYPES OF CAMPUS
BASED FEES THAT ARE CITED HERE
SOME TALKING ABOUT THE SIX
CATEGORIES.
RUNNING FROM MOST SYSTEM WIDE
ALL THE WAY DOWN -- TO VOLUNTARY
FEES SO FIRST.
THERE ARE COMMON SYSTEM WHY
TUITION AND FEES THAT ALL
STUDENTS WAS PAY REGARDLESS OF
THE CAMPUS THEY TEND SUCH AS A
SYSTEM WIDE TUITION.
A SECOND THERE ARE CAMPUS BASED
MANDATORY FEES SPECIFIC TO EACH
CAMPUS THAT ALL STUDENTS ON THAT.
CAMPUS MUST PAY.
SUCH AS CAMPUS HEALTH SERVICES
OUR STUDENTS UNION FEES -- THIRD
COURSE FEES ARE FOR MATERIALS
AND SERVICES ONLY FOR STUDENTS
ENROLLED IN THOSE SPECIFIC
COURSES SO OFTEN BECOME A FAD
THE FACULTY MEMBER WHO'S
REPRESENTING HERE TODAY HAS A
PARTICULAR COURSE THAT REQUIRE
SUPPLEMENTAL -- SUPPLIES ARE
MATERIALS IN THERE ARE
PARTICULAR FEES FOR THOSE
PARTICULAR COARSENESS -- FOURTH
THERE ARE ADMINISTRATIVE FEES
FOR SUCH ITEMS AS ENROLLMENT
DEPOSITS FOR LIBRARY FINES AND
IF YOU PARTICIPATE IN AN
INTERNATIONAL PROGRAM -- FIFTH
CATEGORY ARE FEES FOR SELF
SUPPORT PROGRAMS THESE ARE
THINGS SUCH AS PARKING FOR
HOUSING.
AND FOR PROFESSIONAL CONTINUING
EDUCATION.
LASTLY THERE IS A SIX SYSTEM
WIDE VOLUNTARY FEE.
AND THAT SUPPORTS THE ACTIVITIES
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE STUDENT
ASSOCIATION -- THE
REPRESENTATIVE ENTITIES OF
STUDENTS AT THIS ISSUE.
SIR THERE ARE SEVERAL OTHER
QUESTIONS INCLUDED IN THIS AUDIT
REQUEST.
AND I DO NOT WANT TO TAKE
ANYMORE OF YOUR TIME TODAY SO I
WILL I WILL LEAVE YOU WITH THIS --
MANY OF THE ANSWERS TO THOSE
QUESTIONS ARE READILY AVAILABLE --
ON THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE AS
WELL AS CAMPUS INTERNET SITES.
IN THE RARE INSTANCE IN WHICH
DETAILS ARE NOT READILY
AVAILABLE ONLINE -- THE
INFORMATION CAN BE EASILY
PROVIDED BY CHANCES OFFICE MY
OFFICE.
OR CAMPUS STAFF AND TAKE YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT.
THANK YOU -- WITH THAT WE WILL
GOOD IN RETURN BACK TO MEMBERS
ON THE DíAS. FOR QUESTIONS BUT
LET ME JUST -- BEGIN BECAUSE I
HEARD SOME COMMENTS ON THIS BUT
LET ME ASK -- THE
REPRESENTATIVES FROM CSU.
AT DOES FINANCIAL AID COVER THE
FEES.
WE SURE DO -- THEIR NUMBER OF
FINANCIALLY PROGRAMS -- YOU HAVE
A YOU HAVE.
CAL GRANTS THAT WILL COVER --
ACROSS THE BOARD TUITION BUT
THEN THERE ARE OTHER ELEMENTS OF
THE CAL GRANT PROGRAM WHERE --
THEY THEY CALL IT AND THAT AND
ACCESS WARDER AND FOR LACK OF
BETTER TERM -- THOSE WILL COVER
FEES YOU HAVE FEDERAL -- FEDERAL
PROGRAMS WHERE THOSE WILL COVER
FEES YOU ALSO HAVE THE STATE
UNIVERSITY GRANT PROGRAM SO
THERE ARE MYRIAD OF FINANCIALLY
PROGRAMS THAT WILL COVER THOSE
FEES.
GOT IT SO.
THERE ARE PROGRAMS LIKE COVER
SOME OF THE FEES ARE OUR MOST
THE FEES.
OKAY I HAVE AN ADDITIONAL
QUESTION BUT ALL FIRST OF FOR TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHAT.
THANK YOU MISTER THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I'M I'M LOOKING AT
THIS LIST AND I'M A LITTLE.
A LITTLE STE SURPRISED -- OF ONE
OF THE UNITS KELSEY UNIVERSITIES
I REPRESENT THAT SENT --
ACTUALLY THE ONLY ONE I
pREPRESENT IS NUMBER FOUR ON THE
LIST FOR FEES.
AND ANOTHER THAT A LOT OF
STUDENTS ARE COME FROM MY
DISTRICT TO GO TO SOME OF THE
STATE UNIVERSITY IS IS RIGHT UP
THERE AS WELL SO. TO TO THE TOP
FOR FEES.
AREAS ARE ARE ARE NEAR AND DEAR
TO MY CAN MY CONSTITUENTS --
THERE SEEMS TO BE GREAT
DISPARITY ACROSS THESE AS FAR AS
THE AMOUNTS FOR TWO PARTICULAR
FEES.
I GUESS WHEN I THINK OF IN
STRUCTURAL INSTRUCTION ONLY
RELATED ACTIVITIES I THINK THOSE
ARE THINGS THAT FEEL LIKE THEY
SHOULD BE WRITTEN PARTY YOUR
TUITION.
I UNDERSTAND COURSE MATERIALS
BECAUSE I UNDERSTAND THAT AS
SOMEONE WHO HAD A SCIENCE --
BACKGROUND THE BOOKS WERE MORE
EXPENSIVE IN THE LABS WERE MORE
EXPENSIVE.
BUT I ALWAYS THOUGHT THAT
INSTRUCTION ONLY RELATED
ACTIVITIES WERE LIKE THINGS LIKE
CLASSES AND THINGS LIKE THAT SO
I'M A LITTLE PUZZLED BY THAT
ALSO I'M DISAPPOINTED TO SEE THE
REAL HIGH COST OF HEALTH
SERVICES BUT ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT
I AM IN A HEALTH MANPOWER
SHORTAGE AREA AND THAT.
IS A WHOLE NOTHER ISSUE WHICH WE
COULD TALK ABOUT FOR A LONG TIME --
SO -- I THINK ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE WE KEEP
HEARING I KEEP HEARING FROM MY
STUDENTS.
IN MY IN MY FROM HUMBOLDT STATE
UNIVERSITY IN PARTICULAR IS THAT
IT IS REALLY REALLY EXPENSIVE TO
GO TO SCHOOL THERE AND PEOPLE
THINK BECAUSE IT'S A SMALL
UNIVERSITY.
IN A RURAL AREA IT WOULDN'T BE
BUT IT'S NOT.
THERE EVERYTHING IS HIGHER
TRANSPORTATION COSTS ARE HIGHER
FOOD IS HIGHER RENT CAN BE HIGH
GASOLINE IS HIGH AND SO THE SUIT
STUDENTS ARE STRUGGLING.
SO PART IS WHAT I LIKE THIS
MAKES ME FEEL A LITTLE BIT LIKE
IT'S ALMOST LIKE THE AIRLINES
WERE YOU GOT TO PAY FOR YOUR
BAGS.
YOUR YOU YOU KNOW YOU GET
PEANUTS BUT YOU GOT TO BY ANY
OTHER FOOD -- SO -- I'M REALLY
LOOKING FORWARD TO THIS SIDE X.
SIDE I THINK THIS STUDENTS OF
HUMBOLDT STATE UNIVERSITY IN THE
OTHER UNIVERSITIES -- DESERVE TO
KNOW WHAT THESE FEES ARE FOR
WHERE THEY'RE GOING ESPECIALLY
IN LIGHT OF THE FACT THAT WE'VE
GOT AND HOW THIS ALL PLAYS INTO
THAT ONE POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS SURPLUS IT SITTING OUT
THERE SO.
THANK YOU ABSOLUTELY I THINK
THAT'S A WERE MY LINE OF
QUESTIONING WAS GOING AS WELL
JUST BY MY QUICK MATH I WAS
LOOKING AT SAN LUIS OBISPO --
STUDENT FEES IF THIS IS CORRECT
FOUR THOUSAND SEVENTY FOUR
DOLLARS FOR STUDENT FEES BUT
TUITIONS FIVE THOUSAND SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FORTY TWO QUICK MATH
SAYS IT'S US ABOUT 71%.
OF YOUR TUITION COSTS IT WAS
STUDENT FEES.
SO LET ME ASK YOU KNOW AND AND I
AM ON THE OTHER AND YOU LOOK AT
CAL STATE LOS ANGELES WHICH AS A
STUDENT FEES OF A LITTLE OVER A
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
AND WHEN YOU DO THE MATH ON
THAT'S ABOUT 18% -- SO LET ME
JUST ASK A CSU WHY SO MUCH
DISCREPANCY WERE ONE UNIVERSITY
WOULD CHARGE APPROXIMATELY 18%
OF WHAT TUITION IS.
IN STUDENT FEES WERE ANOTHER
WOULD CHARGE NEARLY 71%.
WELL THE ANSWER CAN BE AS
DIVERSE AS THE THE OPTIONS THAT
YOU HAVE LAID OUT IN FRONT OF
YOU I HAVE A DIFFERENT CHART I
DON'T I WAS IN PROVIDED THAT.
THE MATERIALS THAT YOU HAVE IN
FRONT OF YOU BUT I DO HAVE A A
SIMILAR CHART.
IT GENERALLY SPEAKING I WOULD
SAY THAT -- IF YOU GO BACK.
IN TIME TO DECADES AGO THE
STRUCTURE OF THE SEA ISSUE IS
GENERALLY THIS THAT THE STATE
WOULD PROVIDE ACCESS TO THE
UNIVERSITY WOULD HIRE THE
FACULTY THE INSTRUCTIONAL.
US SUPPORT FOR THAT FOR STUDENTS.
IN AND FEES.
WERE AN ADDITIONAL.
SERVICE THAT DISTINGUISH
PARTICULAR NEED IF A STUDENT
NEEDED HOUSING.
THEY WOULD BY HOUSING SEPARATELY
FROM.
ACCESS TO THE UNIVERSITY IF THEY
NEEDED TO BUY A PARKING PASS
BECAUSE THEY WERE DRIVING
CURRENT CAMPUS SAME SORT OF
THING RIGHT
SINCE THAT TIME SINCE THE
PERFECT MODEL WAS LAID OUT
DECADES AGO WE HAVE MANY
RECESSIONS MANY CHANGES IN
GENERAL FUND AMOUNTS.
AND WHAT IS ULTIMATELY HAPPENED
IS YOU HAVE A SITUATION WHERE
THIS UNIVERSITY YES NEARLY HALF
FUNDED BY STATE GENERAL FUND.
NEARLY HALF FUNDED BY TUITION
AND FEES.
IT TO YOUR PARTICULAR QUESTION
ABOUT THE VARIANCE IN IN
CAMPUSES.
SEND US OBISPO FOR EXAMPLE THEY
ARE AND AND ADD IN AN
EXPERIMENTAL PROGRAM RIGHT.
HI HIGH LEVEL OF NUMBER OF
STUDENTS ARE ENGINEERS.
THEIR AGRICULTURALIST THERE IS A
MUCH GREATER EMPHASIS ON ON
LEARNING BY DOING AND BECAUSE OF
THAT THE REQUIRES ADDITIONAL
EQUIPMENT.
REQUIRES DISTANT DISH
EDUCATIONAL SUPPLIES IN SOME OF
THOSE FEES ARE RELATED TO THAT
SORT OF EDUCATIONAL EXPERIENCE --
THE OTHER THING TO TO TO POINT
OUT AS WELL IS THAT -- THE WAY
THAT OUR CAMPUS BASED FEES AND
THAT'S PROBABLY THE CHART THAT
YOU HAVE IN FRONT OF YOU -- THE
WAY THAT OUR POLICY WORKS IS
THAT A CAMPUS BASE FEE NEEDS TO
BE ORIGINATED AT THE CAMPUS
LEVEL.
BY STUDENTS THE ADMINISTRATION
BY THAT CAMPUS.
THAT IS THEN FORWARDED TO THE
UNIVERSITIES -- HEADQUARTERS TO
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE AND
THERE IS WHERE ALSO A RIGOROUS --
REVIEW OF THAT FEE IS.
IS TAKING A LOOK AT AND
ULTIMATELY APPROVED OR DENIED BY
THE CHANCE AT THAT LEVEL NOW
THERE ARE A BATTERY OF WAYS IN
WHICH THESE CAMPUS BASED FEES
CAN BE CREATED IT CAN BE --
CREATED BY REFERENDUM OF
STUDENTS -- FROM THEIR INSIGHT
IT CAN BE ORIGINATED BY THE
PRESIDENT.
THROUGH SOMETHING THAT WE CALL
ALTERNATIVE CONSULTATION YOU'LL
SEE THAT PROBABLY IN THE PRODUCT
OF THE OF THE AUDIT REPORT.
WHERE IT'S NOT ALWAYS THE
PERFECT -- SITUATION. TO HAVE
JUST A GENERAL VOTE ABOUT A
PARTICULAR FEE -- ONE STRATEGY
FOR EXAMPLE THAT WE HAVE FOUND
TO BE A VERY GOOD.
ONE IS.
WHAT PARTICULAR CAMPUS WAS
INITIATING A PARTICULAR FEE FOR
THEIR ENTIRE CAMPUS AND IN ORDER
TO DO BUSINESS AS A STUDENT
THROUGH THE?
PORTAL OF THAT PARTICULAR CAMPUS.
STUDENT HAD TO ON THREE SEPARATE
OCCASIONS DECLINE TO LOOK.
AT FOR LET ME PUT IT THIS WAY
THEY HAD TO REVIEW BEFORE THEY
CAN MOVE ON TO BUSINESS THEY HAD
TO REVIEW.
A PROPOSAL IN FRONT OF THEM HEY
THERE'S THIS FEE THAT IS IN
FRONT OF YOU ARE YOU INTERESTED
IN LEARNING MORE ABOUT IT IF NOT
TO THESE OTHER OPTIONS OVER HERE
WE CAN LOOK AT AND CONSIDER THIS.
ARE ALL THAT IS IN FEES APPROVED
BY THE STUDENT BODY.
NO THEY ARE NOT.
NO THEY'RE NOT BY STATUTE -- A
STUDENT ASSOCIATION FEE IS
CREATED BY STATUTE ARE BY BY A
STUDENT REFERENDUM -- THERE ARE
ALSO A RECENTLY THERE WAS A LOT
THE PAST THAT -- THAT REQUIRED A
STUDENT VOTE FOR A STUDENT
SUCCESS FEES -- BUT OUR FEE
POLICY LARGELY ROUTE.
LARGELY RECOMMENCED THE FIRST
APPROACH WHICH IS THAT YOU
RECEIVE A VOTE OF ADVICE FROM
STUDENTS IN TERMS OF WHETHER
THIS FEE MAKES SENSE OR NOT.
AND THEN IT IS UP TO THE
PRESIDENT ON A CAMPUS BASED FEE
BASIS TO TAKE IT FORWARD TO THE
CHANCE SIR FOR APPROVAL WITH
THAT INPUT IN MIND.
AND ALSO OTHER ITEMS SO YOU HAVE
CAMPUS WORKSHOPS YET.
MEETINGS THOSE SORTS OF THINGS
IT'S IT'S AT LARGE BATTERY OF
INFORMATION COMES INTO OUR HAD
QUIT.
COMES INTO THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE TO REVIEW THOSE FEES. FOR
CONSIDERATION FOR APPROVAL.
THANK YOU ORDER TO MOVE TO
CENTER DEMONIC THAT SENATOR ROTH.
THANK YOU A MISTER CHAIR.
IN THE SENATOR WOULD ALLUDED TO
THE MEDIA COVERAGE OF A ONE
POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLAR
SURPLUS -- I GUESS FOR THE
REQUEST JOURNAL AND OR FOR THE
AUDITOR WOULD LOOKING IT
AVAILABLE SURPLUSES FACTOR INTO
THIS ON IT.
THAT WASN'T PART OF THE SCOPE OF
THE AUDIT BUT IT WAS A LOOKING
AT ARE THE FUNDS PUT IN SEPARATE
ACCOUNTS AND ARE THEY USE FOR
THE PURPOSES THEY WERE INTENDED.
BY COULD JUST COMMENT ON THAT
CENTER MONNING OUT WE ARE TWO J.
LACK IN A NUMBER OF THE POLICY
COMMITTEES IN BOTH HOUSES
LOOKING AT HOSTING A HEARING.
ON THAT PARTICULAR ISSUE --
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF INTEREST
FROM THE POLICY COMMITTEES AS
WELL.
AND WE ARE COORDINATING THE
TIMES IT LOOKS LIKE IT'S RIGHT
WE GET BACK FROM BREAK THANK YOU
I APPRECIATE THAT SO I WON'T BE
LABOR AT THAT.
I DO UNDERSTAND -- FROM THE CSU
PERSPECTIVE THAT WHEN WE LOOK AT
FEES SOMEWHERE SET -- IN THE
SYSTEM WIDE AND THEN MANY OR
DEVELOPED [inaudible]
CAMPUS SPECIFIC -- ARE THE
DECISIONS MADE AS TO SYSTEM WIDE.
FEES OR COST BASED ON THE
OVERALL BUDGET OF THE SEA ISSUE
REVENUES IN.
EXPENSES OUT.
CERTAINLY THE THE FEE THAT
YOU'RE YOU'RE WOULD BE THE FEE
THAT WOULD BE MOST APPLICABLES
TO WHETHER THE GENERAL FUND IS
UP OR DOWN FOR THE C. ISSUE
WOULD BE SYSTEM WIDE TUITION.
THAT'S A THAT'S A DECISION THAT
IS HELD BY THE BOARD OF TRUSTEES
AND THEY MAKE THE FINAL DECISION
ON WHETHER TUITION WERE TO GO UP
AND DOWN DEPENDING ON THE AMOUNT
OF GENERAL FUND IN WITH THE
BOARD OF TRUSTEES BE MADE AWARE
OF A ONE POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLAR.
SURPLUS THEY HAVE BEEN REGULARLY
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR OFF PLEASE YOU
KNOW THIS -- CHART THAT WE WERE
PROVIDED I REALIZE YOU DON'T
HAVE THE BENEFIT OF HAVING IT SO
I APOLOGIZE HOPEFULLY YOUR SHIRT
HAS THE SAME DATA -- MAYBE
SOMEONE CAN PROVIDE ONE TO YOU
IF THEY HAVE.
ONE THANK YOU OF THINK I HAVE
ONE NOW.
SO FOR EXAMPLE THE ONE I'M
LOOKING AT UNDER THE CATEGORY OF
CAMPUS MANDATORY FEES MATERIAL
SERVICES AND FACILITIES WE HAVE
CAL POLY POMONA.
WAS.
ZERO AND WE HAVE CAL POLY SAN
LUIS OBISPO WITH TWELVE HUNDRED
AND TEN DOLLARS.
NOW CAN SOMEBODY EXPLAIN TO ME
WHY THAT'S THE CASE GIVEN THE
FACT THAT.
MY RECOLLECTION IS ARE SOMEWHAT
SIMILAR IN TERMS OF THEIR
MISSION.
SO DO I MEAN I THIS IS NOT I
MEAN I THIS IS NOT KNOW YOUR
BIBLE I WILL THAT'S WHY WE HAVE
AN AUDITOR WHO MAY DO AN AUDIT
HERE IF IT'S APPROVED.
YEAH THE IT'S THE NAME SO SO
THAT THAT CATEGORY MATERIAL
SERVICES AND FACILITIES FEE.
IS DERIVED FROM THE STATUTORY
AUTHORITY FOR THAT SPECIFIC FEE
SO DEPENDING ON HOW THE CAMPUS
PROPOSES A FEE FOR EXAMPLE.
IT MAY OR MAY NOT BE RECORDED IN
THAT CATEGORY -- SAN LUIS OBISPO
THE STUDENT SUCCESS FEE FOR
EXAMPLE IS CALLED OUT SEPARATELY --
THE BECAUSE THE AUTHORITY TO FOR
THAT PARTICULAR FEE WAS
SUBSEQUENTLY MODIFIED --
PURSUANT TO THE LEGISLATION THAT
RYAN SPOKE ABOUT EARLIER.
SO IT IT MIGHT BE WHAT ONE WAY
TO LOOK AT IS TO ADD IF YOU
THINK ABOUT -- INSTRUCTIONAL
RELATED ACTIVITIES WHICH IS
ANOTHER STATUTORY DEFINITION
MATERIAL SERVICES AND FACILITIES
AND STUDENT SUCCESS TOGETHER.
THOSE WITH MOST OFTEN BE FOR
THINGS THAT ARE SIMILAR -- I
WILL ACTUALLY I UNDERSTOOD THE
EARLIER COMMENT WHEN.
THE GENTLEMAN SPOKE ABOUT THE
FACT THAT SAN LUIS OBISPO IS
THERE'S AGRICULTURE IN THERE'S
ENGINEERING AND YOU KNOW MAYBE
YOU HAVE TO BUY THINGS BUT I AM
HAVING DIFFICULTY.
UNDERSTANDING THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN ZERO AND TWELVE HUNDRED
AND TEN AND AND AS TO THE
EQUIPMENT ISN'T SOME OF THAT
WOULDN'T SOME OF THAT BE FUNDED
BY THE GENERAL FUND
APPROPRIATION THAT WE PROVIDE --
TO TO SEE ISSUE IN GENERAL I
MEAN YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
PROVIDING AN EDUCATIONAL
EXPERIENCE AND I WOULD THINK
THAT YOU WOULD BUDGET FOR THAT.
IN YOUR BCP WOULD REFLECT THE
THE COST OF OF THAT SORT OF
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITY
CERTAINLY COULD COULD BE FOR
SURE -- I THINK ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE'VE
EXPERIENCED OVER THE YEARS IS
THAT -- WHEN WHEN GENERAL FUND
HAS BEEN REDUCED AND AND NOT
APPROPRIATELY BACK FILLED?
WITH EITHER TUITION ARE GENERAL
FUND IN THE FUTURE THAT THERE
HAS BEEN A NEED -- TO CONTINUE
TO PROVIDE ACCESS FOR STUDENTS.
AT OUR UNIVERSE IS AT THE SAME
TIME BE ABLE TO INVEST IN --
THEIR EDUCATION AND THE
INVOLVEMENT OF TECHNOLOGY IN
TERMS OF THEIR EDUCATIONAL.
IN TERMS OF THE SPECIFICS ABOUT
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN ZERO AND
ELEVEN HUNDRED TWELVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS THAT WOULD WHATEVER YOU
CITED -- IT WOULD REQUIRE US TO
GO BACK AND HAVE TO LOOK ON A
CASE BY CASE BASIS WHAT EACH OF
THOSE FEES ARE -- YOU KNOW WE WE
WE HAVE SEVEN I THINK I THINK WE
HAVE THAT WERE I THINK WE TALK
ABOUT THE SAME TABLE HERE SO I
THINK THIS IS ACTUALLY FROM MY
OFFICE IS WEBSITE THAT DEPICTS
THE CAMPUS BASED FEES.
BUT IF YOU DO THE MATH HERE --
JUST IN TERMS OF CATEGORIES
YOU'RE LOOKING AT A HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE DIFFERENT CATEGORIES
OF FEES BECAUSE YOU'VE TWENTY
THREE CAMPUSES AND HAVE -- SEVEN
SIX SEVEN A DIFFERENT FEES AND
THEN WITHIN THAT THIS ISN'T JUST
ONE PARTICULAR FEE IT COULD BE.
A COLLECTION OF THOSE SPECIFIC
FEES ON THE CAMPUS SO THERE
COULD HAVE BEEN ONE THAT WAS
CREATED FOR FIVE DOLLARS AND IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY AND THEN THERE
COULD HAVE BEEN ONE THAT WAS
SUGGESTED LATER.
SO WE HAVE TO GO BACK AND DO AND
MAYBE THAT'S PART OF THE THE
AUDITOR'S WORK IS THAT WHEN YOU
ARE LOOKING ON A CAMPUS BY
CAMPUS BASIS WHAT THOSE
PARTICULAR FEE DOLLARS ARE IN
TOTAL I DON'T HAVE ALL THE
ANSWERS FOR ALL OF THE CAMPUS IS
IN ALL.
OF THE FEES AT MY DISPOSAL RIGHT
NOW.
BUT OBVIOUSLY WE CAN FOLLOW UP
IF YOU HAVE A PARTICULAR -- HE'S
BEEN PHRASE YOU WANT ME TO TO TO
RESEARCHERS WELL WE'LL SEE WHAT
HAPPENS WITH THIS ORDER REQUEST
WE MAY ACTUALLY.
HAVE THE ANSWERS WHICH YOU WILL
PARTICIPATE IN THE FORM OF A
STATE AUDITOR'S REPORT SO.
THANK YOU FOR THE INFORMATION
THANK YOU MISTER.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
FROM THE DíAS.
A SENATOR GONZALEZ PLEASE.
AND I APOLOGIZE IF IT'S BEEN
ASKED THAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD --
WHEN WAS THE STUDENT SUCCESS BE
ENACTED?
WELL THIS TO SUCCESS FEE -- I
THINK THE EARLIEST ONE WAS WHEN
THAT FIRST OF ALL IS TO
SUCCESSFULLY IS A CAMPUS BASED
FEE THAT IS ORIGINATED BY EACH
CAMPUS.
FIRST ONE THE EARLIEST ONE THAT
WE CONSIDER A STUDENT SUCCESS
FEE.
AREAS WAS GREAT IN.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT THE LAST ONE
THAT WAS CREATED.
WAS IN TWENTY FOURTEEN MAY OF
TWENTY FOURTEEN SO LITTLE OVER
FIVE YEARS AGO -- AND THEY ARE
AND AND AND MAD MAD JUST LITTLE
BIT TO THAT.
THEY'RE VERY SIMILAR -- TO THE
INSTRUCTION RELATED ACTIVITIES
THAT WE'VE TALKED ABOUT HERE AS
WELL AS MATERIAL SERVICES AND
FACILITIES FEES IN FACT.
WE WOULD ARGUE THAT THEY ARE A
SUBSET OF THE MATERIAL SERVICES
FEE -- PAYS FOR A LOT OF THE
EDUCATIONAL EXPERIENCE AND THEN
THE INSTRUCTION RELATED
ACTIVITIES SORTS OF THINGS SO.
AND PERHAPS -- AND I KNOW WE'VE
SOME I TALKED ABOUT THIS BUT
PERHAPS THAT COULD BE OBVIOUSLY
LOOKED AT AND WITHIN THE AUDIT
TO SEE HOW.
SOME OF THEM MAY OR MAY NOT BE
SUBSETS AND WHY THEY MAY NOT BE --
ONE FEE AND A LITTLE BIT MORE IN
ALIGNMENT WITH EACH OTHER -- IF
IF I MAY ALSO WE DO WE ARE
STATUTORILY REQUIRED TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION ON STUDENT SUCCESS
FEES EVERY YEAR AND WE HAVE A
REPORT THAT WE ISSUE EVERY YEAR
AND IS AVAILABLE ONLINE AT ALL
TIMES.
SO IT WHAT THAT DOES IS IT
DETAILS OUT WHICH CAMPUSES HAVE
STUDENT SUCCESS FEES WHAT THEY
WHAT THEY PAY.
FOR AS WELL AS IF THERE ARE ANY
CHANGES TO THOSE FEES -- OR RICK
THE LIMITATIONS ARE CREATION OF
NEW ONES SO THAT INFORMATION'S
VERY READILY AVAILABLE.
GREAT AND I HAVE A QUESTION --
THE HEALTH FACILITIES AND HEALTH
SERVICES AND I KNOW -- THERE
SOME ZEROS -- VERY FEW BUT
THERE'S SOME OF THOSE HAVE THERE
BEEN.
ANY DISCUSSIONS ABOUT.
PERHAPS MAKING THEM NON
MANDATORY -- JUST GIVEN THE FACT
THAT SOME STUDENTS MAY OR MAY
NOT BE TRADITIONAL BUT HAVE
THEIR OWN HEALTH INSURANCE IN
MAY -- NOT NEED THIS --
PARTICULAR.
SERVICE NO WE HAVEN'T ANY
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT THAT.
OKAY -- THINK THOSE ARE ALL MY
QUESTIONS BUT I JUST.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
OPENNESS AND I LOOK FOR TO
APPROVING THIS TODAY.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU WITHOUT WILL
MOVE TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHAT.
YET THEN JUST TO FOLLOW UP ON
AND I AM.
FASCINATED BY THE STUDENT
SUCCESS FEE BECAUSE I WOULD HOPE
THAT THE UNIVERSITY'S MISSION IS
TO MAKE SURE ALSO STUDENTS FROM
OUR SUCCESSFUL.
AND I'M ALSO FASCINATED BY THE
FACT THAT SUMMER ZERO AND SOME
ARE VERY LARGE SO I GUESS SOME
PEOPLE WANT THEIR UNIVERSE THEIR
UNIVERSES BE EVEN MORE
SUCCESSFUL.
I'M CURIOUS ABOUT THE WIDE
REALLY VERY INTERESTED IN THESE
FEES AND HOW THEY ARE SPEND I
CAN.
I CAN SEE THAT IF YOU'RE
BOUNCING AROUND AND YOU'RE
CAUGHT USE YOU'RE LOOKING AT
SOME OF THESE MAY BE RELATED TO
INSTRUCTIONAL RELATED ACTIVITIES
WHICH ALSO THANK.
SHOULD BE PART OF TUITION.
ARE THEIR DISCLOSURES TO
STUDENTS UP FRONT.
BECAUSE I'LL GO BACK TO MY
AIRPLANE ANALOGY.
THIS FEELS LIKE HIS THIS IS
TUITION BUT YOU GOT ALL THESE
ADDITIONAL FEES THERE THEY GET
TACKED ON TO THE BILL.
AND YOU DON'T REALLY KNOW THAT
UNTIL YOU BUY THE TICKET.
SO HOW MUCH OF THIS IS TRULY
DISCLOSED UP FRONT TO FAMILIES
AND PROSPECTIVE STUDENTS SO THEY
ACTUALLY KNOW.
WHAT THEY'RE GETTING I WAS BEEN
A LONG TIME SINCE I'VE BEEN IN
COLLEGE I WAS A UC STUDENT AND I
RECOGNIZE THERE WERE FEES?
BUT I WILL TELL YOU OF THAT
PROPORTION TO THE TRADITION TO
TO THE TUITION AND WITH NOTHING
LIKE THIS.
NOT EVEN CLOSE.
SO IT JUST FEELS LIKE AN
EXPLOSION OF THESE ADDED ON FEES.
THAT ARE GOING SOMEWHERE WHICH
IS OBVIOUSLY WHY WE'RE GOING TO
DO THIS AUDIT -- FEDERAL LAW
REQUIRES ONLY THE UNIVERSITIES
ALL PROVIDE INFORMATION ABOUT
THE COST OF ATTENDANCE PRIOR --
TO PAYMENT OR REGISTRATION SO.
WELL PART OF THE ISSUES YOU'RE
LOOKING AT THESE IN AGGREGATE IF
YOU LOOK AT EACH CAMPUSES OF
WEBSITE YOU'LL SEE -- THE FEES
LAID OUT FOR THAT SPECIFIC
CAMPUS.
AND AGAIN T'S REQUIRED TO BE
DISCLOSED PRIOR -- TO AT AT THE
TIME OF APPLICATION AND THERE'S
NO I MEAN THERE THESE THINGS ARE
ALL OVER THE BOARD SO THERE'S NO
OVERSIGHT ABOUT THAT THIS IS
THESE ARE REASONABLE -- OR THE I
UNDERSTAND THEY DO GO THROUGH
REVIEW BUT IT IT FEELS LIKE.
CAMPUSES.
ARE PRETTY AUTONOMOUS.
YEAH EACH YEAR IS RYAN INDICATED
WE COLLECT THIS INFORMATION --
BOTH AFTER THE FEE HAS BEEN PASS
BUT ALSO WHILE EACH INDIVIDUAL
FEE IS BEING PROPOSED.
THAT DATA IS AGGREGATED AND
REPORTED TO THE BOARD OF
TRUSTEES ANNUALLY.
AND TYPICALLY BEFORE THE BUDGET
ACT BROUGHT PROCESS AND
COMPARISONS ARE MADE AMONGST
CAMPUSES AND BETWEEN CAMPUSES
AND OTHER NATIONAL COMPARISON
INSTITUTIONS.
SO IS THERE NO EFFORTS USE -- TO
USE THE BUYING POWER OF TWENTY
THREE UNIVERSITIES TO HELP WITH
SOME OF THESE.
IN FEE REDUCTIONS -- I YOU KNOW
I WOULD THINK THAT THERE MIGHT
BE OPPORTUNITIES OUT THERE --
THAT WERE UNIVERSITY COULD
ACTUALLY WORK IN CONCERT TO USE
THE POWER OF OF TWENTY THREE
VERSES THE POWER OF ONE YES -- I
WE CONSIDER THE POWER OF TWENTY
THREE TO BE TWENTY TWO
UNIVERSITIES TEND UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA AND OVER A HUNDRED
AND TEN COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND
WE ENGAGE IN -- COLLECTIVE
PURCHASING PROGRAM -- THAT'S
BEEN VERY SUCCESSFUL REPORTED TO
THE BOARD OF TRUSTEES LAST YEAR
SAVINGS IN -- OF THE IN EXCESS
OF TWENTY THREE MILLION JUST
FROM AGGREGATE CONTRACTS.
THE GOAL TODAY THIS YEAR'S MUCH
LARGER WILL BE REPORTING TO THE
BOARD -- ON THE SAVINGS
RESULTING FROM THOSE EFFORTS AND
JAN JANUARY I BELIEVE BECAUSE OF
GENDER JANUARY.
SO MAYBE THIS AUDIT MAYBE YOU
KNOW THIS WHAT IS THE CUMULATIVE
TOTAL OF THESE FEES FOR THE OVER
THE TWENTY THREE CAMPUSES
[inaudible]
IT'S YEAH IT'S A BIG AND I DON'T
HAVE AN EXAMPLE IT'S A REALLY
WHEN YOU SAID TWENTY THREE MATT
YOU'VE GOT.
Q. YOU'RE YOU'RE YOU'RE GETTING
SAVINGS OF TWENTY THREE MILLION
DOLLARS THAT FEELS LIKE A DROP
IN THE BUCKET TO WHAT THIS
NUMBER IS FOUR HUNDRED EIGHTY
FOUR THOUSAND STUDENTS --
THERE'S A THAT'S THIS IS A BIG
NUMBER IT'S A REALLY REALLY BIG
REALLY AND I THINK THAT'S
PROBABLY -- MISTER HART ABOUT
WHY SHE WANTS LOOK IN IT INTO A
WITH THE HOT IT DISCREPANCY NOT
ONLY IN THE STUDENT SUCCESS
BECAUSE WE WANT ALL STUDENTS TO
BE SUCCESSFUL.
BUT WHY SOME CAMPUSES ARE ZERO
OTHERS CHARGE A LITTLE BIT MORE
BUT EVEN THE FEES OVERALL LIKE
EARLIER JUST BY ROUGH MATH 71%.
OF THE TUITION COSTS WAS FEES
FOR SAN LUIS OBISPO FOR INSTANCE
WHICH ARE THE CSU RESPONDED TO
BUT HOPEFULLY.
THIS OUGHT TO GET APPROVED WHILE
WILL SHED A LITTLE MORE LIGHT ON
THAT.
THAT YOU HAD A COMMENT ON MR
WHICH QUESTIONS -- TO TO ADDRESS
THE ISSUE OF WHETHER STUDENTS
ARE INVOLVED IN UNDERSTANDING
WHAT THESE FEES ARE AND WHETHER
THEY'RE GOING UP OR DOWN OR
BEING ADJUSTED -- BYE BYE FEE
POLICY WE REQUIRE THAT CAMPUSES
HAVE A FEE ADVISORY COMMITTEE.
AND THE VAST MAJORITY OF THAT
FEE ADVISORY COMMITTEE IS
POPULATED BY STUDENT
REPRESENTATIVES.
SO.
THE MAN THE GENERAL CONDUCT OF
THIS THESE BE ADVISORY COMMITTEE
SAYS THERE'S IT'S A STANDING
ADVISORY COMMITTEE ON CAMPUSES.
IT'S PART OF THE ANNUAL BUDGET
DEVELOPMENT PROCESS ON THE
CAMPUSES.
AND THEY HOLD REGULAR MEETINGS
AND WHERE THERE ARE IDEAS IN AND
CONVINCED CONSIDERATIONS ABOUT
NEW FEES AND OR WHETHER THERE
ARE FEES THAT ARE STATIC --
THESE -- THESE ADVISORY
COMMITTEES ARE -- ARE DEFINITELY
INVOLVING STUDENTS -- AND AND
AND AND AND THEN -- ONE THING
THAT WELL THAT'S A THAT'S THAT'S
THAT'S IT I LOST MY TRAIN OF
THOUGHT HIM AS A COMPLEX.
THANK YOU -- WE HAVE SENATOR
MORE LIKE THAT SENATOR MINING
WITH ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS CENTER
MORE LIKE IF YOU MISTER CHAIR
JUST A QUICK QUESTION I MIGHT'VE
MISSED AT THE BEGINNING BUT OF
THE CATEGORIES YOU'VE YOU'VE GOT
SIX I'M JUST CURIOUS WHY PARKING
FEES WERE NOT INCLUDED.
YES CENTER MORE LOCK -- THERE'S
A STORM I WAS ASKING THE
ASSEMBLY WOMAN BUT THANK YOU FOR
MY DAD FOR JUMPING IN ARE YOU
SHE WROTE THE LETTER YEAH.
YES BECAUSE WE'RE LOOKING AT THE
STUDENT BASS FEES AND PARKING
WAS DONE IN THE PREVIOUS AUDIT.
I'M SUS IT AGAIN I'M SURE
HARKING FEES WERE LOOKED AT THE
PREVIOUS ON IT.
I WAS IN A PREVIOUS CITED OKAY
THANK YOU.
THAT IS GOOD TO SEE YOU AGAIN
RIGHT.
ALL RIGHT SUTTER MONNING PLACE
THANK YOU ON A QUICK FOLLOW UP
ON ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOODS
QUESTION -- THERE'S CURRENT
FEDERAL LAW THAT REQUIRES
WEBSITES TO SHOW SOME OF THE
COST OF TUITION AND FEES.
WE CURRENTLY HAVE SENATE BILL
FOUR SIXTY SEVEN BROUGHT TO US
BY STUDENTS FROM.
CAL POLY SAN LUIS OBISPO
SUPPORTED BY THE STATE WHAT
ASSOCIATION THAT WOULD REQUIRE
FURTHER INFORMATION INCLUDING
HOUSING COSTS. FOR TWO BEDROOM
IN ONE BEDROOM APARTMENTS.
AND ON CAMPUS HOUSING.
FORMER ASSEMBLYMEMBER CUT CHIU
ASIDE GENE HAS BEEN COUNSELLING
THE STUDENTS WHO BROUGHT THIS.
TO US AND IT WOULD ALSO REQUEST
THAT YOU SEE PROVIDE SIMILAR
INFORMATION WE CAN'T REQUIRE YOU
SEE TO DO IT SO -- JUST FOR YOUR
ATTENTION AS BEFORE.
SIXTY SEVEN MANDATE SEE ISSUE TO
PROVIDE IT REQUESTS YOU SEE TO
PROVIDE IT SO ALL STUDENTS CAN
NO.
CAMPUS SPECIFIC COSTS.
THANK YOU LET ME ASK AT THE
SILENT THERE ARE ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS FROM THE DíAS HEARING
AND SEEING NINE WAS GOOD IT OPEN
IT UP FOR PUBLIC COMMENTS ON THE
ASK AT THIS TIME IF THERE IS ANY
PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS ITEM.
HEARING AND SEEING NINE I WILL --
ASK MISS BURKHALTER BATH FOR IF
YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE YES THANK
YOU -- I THINK WE'VE HEARD FROM
TODAY'S TESTIMONY HOME PORN AND
WILL BE TO LOOK AT THAT AND GET
THAT TRANSPARENCY ACCOUNTABILITY
AND STUDENT BASED FEES AT CSU.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THE STATE AUDIT.
ALL RIGHT.
LET OUT IT'S BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR ROTH IT'S BEEN SECONDED
BY MISTER PATTERSON -- MISTER
HER ABOUT THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS MEASURE BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE I WILL BE SUPPORTING
THIS -- THE VARIANCES OF THE
INTERESTED IN AND UNDERSTANDING
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE VARIANCES
BETWEEN THE DIFFERENT CAMPUSES.
AS A SIDE OF MOVES FORWARD WITH
THAT -- MISTER SECTOR KALRA.
THE MOTION IS TO APPROVE WATER
QUEST NUMBER TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN DASH ONE FOURTEEN
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
CAMPUS BASED FEES BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BURNER HORVATH.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SALAS AYE.
SALAS AYE BOERNER HORVATH HI
BOERNER HORVATH HI DEEP
[inaudible]
PATTERSON [inaudible]
I RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE VOEPEL.
VOEPEL I WOULD [inaudible]
WOOD HI [inaudible]
SENATOR ROBB.
ROTH AYE FORGES.
GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG.
MINING.
MONNING AYE MOORLACH.
MOORLACH I WIENER.
OKAY WE'LL GO AHEAD AND LEAVE
THAT ROLE OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS TO ADD ON THANK YOU MISS
BOERNER HORVATH [inaudible]
OKAY.
SAYING NO ADDITIONAL AUTHORS
WILL GO AHEAD AND MOVE TO AGENDA
NUMBER AGENDA ITEM NUMBER SIX BY
TWO ZERO ONE NINE DASH ONE ONE
FIVE FOR MOTOR VEHICLES REAL ID
APPLICATION.
BY MYSELF IN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PATTERSON AND AT THIS TIME AGO
IT IN HAND THE GAVEL OVER TO OUR
VICE CHAIR MISTER RUFF
.
GERMAN THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT ON THIS ITEM TODAY --
BEFORE WE BEGIN I AM PREPARED TO
REMOVE QUESTION FIVE FROM THE
AUDIT LETTER.
GIVEN LAST WEEK'S ACTIONS ON THE
BUDGET MAKING THIS QUESTION.
A MOOT POINT -- I'D ALSO LIKE TO
INFORM THE COMMITTEE OF OUR
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION ON ACTUALLY
DELAYED IMPLEMENTATION TO ALLOW
THE STRIKE TEAM -- RESULTS TO
ACTUALLY BE IMPLEMENTED IN THE
AUDITOR'S -- FINDINGS ISSUE IF
THIS AUDIT SO MOVES FORWARD I
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
COMMITMENT TO OVERHAULING.
AND FIXING THE PROBLEMS AT DMV
THE THOUGHT OF REQUESTED ABOUT
FILLING OUR DUTY. TO MAKE
GOVERNMENT WORK BETTER FOR THE
CONSTITUENTS THAT WE ARE ELECTED
TO SERVE.
AND TO BE A PART OF THE SOLUTION.
MANY CALIFORNIANS ARE FRUSTRATED
AND ANGRY WITH THE SITUATION.
THAT THE DMV AND THEY HAVE EVERY
RIGHT TO BE.
HAD IT IS THIS COMMITTEE'S ROLE
IN PARTICULAR TO PROVIDE
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY
WHEN GOVERNMENT IS NOT WORKING
FOR THE PEOPLE.
THAT IS WHY I AM HERE TODAY
PRESENTING THIS REQUEST. TO
ENSURE THAT WE ARE JUST THROWING
MONEY AT A PROBLEM AND HOPING IT
GOES AWAY.
I VOTED TO SUPPORT THE BUDGET
BILL WITH ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
THE DMV BUT NOT WITHOUT SOME
APPREHENSION.
AND CONCERN.
AND WHILE I DID ALSO BELIEVE
VOTE FOR IT.
AND WAS PLEASED TO SEE THE
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS INCLUDED
IN THE BUDGET INDEPENDENT
OVERSIGHT IS NECESSARY TO ENSURE.
THAT PROBLEMS ARE BEING FIXED.
AND TO ASSURE THE PUBLIC THAT WE
ARE DOING WHAT IS RIGHT.
IN ADDRESSING THE PROBLEM AND
NOT SWEEPING IT UNDER THE RUG.
ISSUES OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
MOTOR VEHICLES HAVE BEEN OF
GREAT CONCERN TO ME AND MANY
CALIFORNIANS OVER THE PAST YEAR.
MEDIA HAS RIGHTFULLY FOCUSED HIS
ATTENTION ON THE DMV AND ITS
SHORTCOMINGS.
AND I'M SURE WE HAVE ALL HEARD
FROM CONSTITUENTS REGARDING
VARIOUS ISSUES AT THE DMV.
THE DMV HAS STRUGGLED IN MANY
WAYS OVER THE PAST YEAR.
BUT STRUGGLED WITH ISSUING
FEDERALLY MANDATED REAL ID'S.
WHICH WE WILL NEED -- TO BOARD
AN AIRPLANE BEGINNING IN OCTOBER
OF TWENTY TWENTY THE DMV ALONG
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY HAVE ALSO STRUGGLED
WITH THE DEVELOPMENT.
AND DEPLOYING THE MOTOR VOTER
PROGRAM.
A HUNDRED AND FIVE THOUSAND
REGISTRATION ERRORS HAVE BEEN
MADE SINCE APRIL.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND FOR LAST
YEAR ESPECIALLY THE DMV
STRUGGLED WITH PROVIDING
SERVICES TO CALIFORNIANS IN A
TIMELY MANNER. TO DEAL WITH
THESE ISSUES THE DMV HAS
REQUESTED AND THE LEGISLATURE
HAS ALLOCATED A LOT OF MONEY WE
RECENTLY APPROVED TWO HUNDRED
AND FORTY TWO MILLION IN
ADDITIONAL FUNDS FOR THE DMV.
THAT IS A 17% INCREASE FOR A
TOTAL DMV BUDGET OF ONE POINT
THREE SIX BILLION DOLLARS.
WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT THESE
ADDITIONAL FUNDS AS WELL AS THE
ENTIRE.
ALLOCATION TO DMV IS SPENT IN
THE MOST EFFICIENT AND
RESPONSIBLE.
MANNER POSSIBLE.
I REALIZE OTHER REVIEWS HAVE
ALREADY TAKEN PLACE REGARDING
THE DMV AND TEN TO FOR THIS
AUDIT REQUEST TO PICK UP WHERE
THE GOVERNOR STRIKE TEAM AND
OTHER REPORTS FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
AND ERNEST AND YOUNG LEAVE OFF.
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE IN ORDER TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE MOST RECENT
ACTIONS TAKEN BY THE DMV TO
ENSURE THAT OUR REAL IDEAS
COMPLY WITH THE FEDERAL
REQUIREMENTS.
ARE ADEQUATE AND ACCEPTABLE TO
THE US DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND
SECURITY.
I WOULD LIKE THE STATE AUDITOR
LOOK AT THE DMV IS RECENT
REQUEST.
FOR ACTUAL WERE STRIKING THAT
PART BECAUSE WE THAT'S A MOOT
POINT.
I WOULD LIKE TO THE I WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO STATE AUDITOR FORM SOME
WORK REGARDING THE MOTOR VOTER
PROGRAM.
OUR RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE
PRIOR REVIEWS BEING IMPLEMENTED.
HOW EFFECTIVE IS A TRAINING
PROVIDED TO DMV EMPLOYEES?
ALSO WOULD LIKE STATE AUDITOR TO
REVIEW THE DEPARTMENT
TECHNOLOGIES ROLE IN HELPING --
THE DMV DEVELOP IMPLEMENT AND
TEST SYSTEMS CONNECTED TO THE
MOTOR VOTER PROGRAM.
I LIKE TO THINK THE DMV THE
PARKING OF TECHNOLOGY FOR BEING
HERE TODAY.
HOPE CORRECTIVE ACTION IS BEING
UNDERTAKEN.
ALREADY I BELIEVE A REVIEW BY
THE STATE AUDITOR WILL ONLY HELP
IN THIS EFFORT.
LASTLY I BELIEVE IT IS CRITICAL
THAT WE ADDRESS THESE ISSUES AT
THE DMV TO PROVIDE CONFIDENCE TO
VOTERS.
AND DMV CUSTOMERS ALIKE --
MEMBERS SH THE SHORT OF IT IS I
BELIEVE THAT THERE'S VALUE IN
HAVING AN EXTERNAL AUDIT I THINK
WE SHOULD LOOK AT EVERY POSSIBLE
RECOMMENDATION INVITE
INDEPENDENT LOOK AT WHAT WE CAN
DO.
WE ARE LOOKING TO BE A PART OF
THE SOLUTION MOVING FORWARD AND
WITH THAT I'LL RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE IN A DO YOU HAVE
OPENING.
COMMENTS FROM THANK YOU.
MISTER PATTERSON MISTER CHAIRMAN
UP.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR IS THIS
WORKING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR IT FOR A
THE OPPORTUNITY TO JOINTLY UP UP.
UP PRESENT THIS WITH YOU AS
PREVIOUSLY STATED -- THIS IS A
LEGISLATURE HAS GIVEN ADDITIONAL
TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY TWO
MILLION DOLLARS TO ADDRESS THE
CHALLENGES IT REAL ID.
IMPLEMENTATION -- A 17% INCREASE.
BUT MEMBERS AYE I HAVE BEEN --
SUPPORTIVE OF GOVERNOR NEWSOME'S
DMB STRIKE TEAM AS THEY TRIED TO
FIX THIS CHRONICALLY MISMANAGED
DEPARTMENT.
HOWEVER I THINK ALL OF US HAVE.
BEEN SO INCLINED WITH THE
EXPECTATION THAT THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE ADMINISTRATION WOULD
ACTUALLY HOLD THE DEPARTMENT
ACCOUNTABLE AND WE WOULD SEE.
NOT SERIOUS AND QUANTIFIABLE
RESULTS.
I THINK THE TIME IS LONG PAST
DUE THAT THIS STATE AUDITOR
SHOULD HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY OF
TAKING A GOOD HARD LOOK AT THE
KINDS OF CONCERNS WE ALL.
HAVE HERE.
OTHER CHAIR -- AND I HAVE WORKED
TOGETHER TO CRAFT AN AUDIT THAT
DOES NOT RECREATE WHAT IS
ALREADY BEING DONE BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCES REPORT
FOR MARCH.
INSTEAD WE HAVE PURPOSELY
IDENTIFIED WAYS FOR THE STATE
AUDITOR TO BE THE MOST EFFECTIVE
AND REVIEW INFORMATION THAT
WOULD BE THE MOST BENEFIT.
NOT ONLY TO THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE BUT ALSO TO THE
MEMBERS OF THE GENERAL PUBLIC.
THIS -- AS OF THE CHAIR
SUGGESTED IT A TWO HUNDRED FORTY
TWO MILLION DOLLARS IS IS PART
OF THIS REVIEW.
WHICH WILL HELP GUIDE THIS
LEGISLATURE.
NOT IF BUT WHEN.
THEY NEXT COME BACK ASKING FOR
MORE MONEY [inaudible]
NEXT YEAR.
THERE IS AN ACCOUNTABILITY
EFFORT HERE THAT WE MUST BE ABLE
TO MAINTAIN.
AND I SUBMIT TO YOU THAT THE
MOST INDEPENDENT THE MOST
EFFECTIVE AND FAIR APPROACH TO
THIS.
IS TO HAVE OUR CALIFORNIA'S
STATE AUDITOR.
BOB BE ENGAGED IN IT.
AGAIN THIS AUDIT IS NOT
DUPLICATIVE IT IS NOT PREMATURE
IN FACT IT IS VERY MUCH PASSED
TO DO.
THAT IT IS ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY
THERE'S NO BETTER WAY.
OUT WE CAN SEE THIS THEN TAKING
A LOOK AT THE ISSUES PRESENTLY
WITH OUT REAL ID AND WITH THE
MOTOR.
VOTER PROGRAM.
JUST YESTERDAY WE HAD MORE
CONFUSION ABOUT REAL ID.
AND WHETHER OR NOT -- THAT
CONFUSION.
STAMPS TO A MISUNDERSTANDING --
BETWEEN THE GOVERNOR AND OUR OWN
ATTORNEY GENERAL WITH RESPECT TO
WHETHER OR NOT REAL IDEAS ARE
GOING TO BE NECESSARY -- FOR
PURCHASE OF AMMUNITION OR NOT --
THERE SEEMS TO BE.
CONTINUED A CONFUSION AROUND THE
DOCUMENTATION NECESSARY. TO GET
THE REAL ID BUT WE HELD WITH THE
DM THESE HELP LAST WEEK A WEEK
BEFORE -- VERY WELL ATTENDED --
OF WORKSHOPS ON REAL ID.
AND EVEN IN THE QUESTION AND
ANSWER PERIOD WHERE WE HAD DMV
EXPERTS IN THE ROOM.
THERE WAS OFTEN A WELL WE'RE NOT
SURE ABOUT THAT LET ME GET BACK
TO YOU.
THERE WERE LOTS OF QUESTIONS
FROM PEOPLE I HAVE A MILITARY ID
ARE I HAVE OTHER FORMS OF
FEDERAL ID.
AND SO.
I THINK IT IS WE CAN STIPULATE
THAT THERE IS SIGNIFICANT
CONFUSION.
AND I ALSO THINK THAT WE'VE GOT
TO TAKE IN AN A LOOK AS WELL.
WITH RESPECT -- TO THE PROBLEMS
WITH -- WITH MOTOR VOTER -- COME
TO FIND OUT THROUGH
INVESTIGATIVE JOURNALISM I WANT
TO UNDERSCORE THIS.
IT HASN'T BEEN BECAUSE WE ASK
THE AUDITOR TO LOOK AT THE MOTOR
VOTER PROBLEM.
OF PEOPLE BASICALLY SUGGEST WELL
THERE'S NOT REALLY A PROBLEM
HERE LET'S MOVE ON THE REALITY
HAS BEEN THROUGH INVESTIGATIVE
JOURNALISM.
THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY THE DEPARTMENT OF
MOTOR VEHICLES.
NEW THAT THE MOTOR VOTER PROGRAM
WAS NOT READY FOR IMPLEMENTATION.
BUT IT WAS PUSHED FORWARD RUSHED
FORWARD -- AT THE EXPENSE OF
OVER AFFECTING A HUNDRED
THOUSAND VOTERS.
MEMBERS WE HAVE SEVENTY SEVEN
THOUSAND REGISTERED ERRORS FROM
SOFTWARE ISSUE. TWENTY THREE
THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS BEING
INCORRECTLY REGISTERED TO VOTE
BECAUSE OF WHAT WAS CALLED AN
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCESSING ERROR.
AND FIVE THOUSAND TRANSMITTAL
ERRORS RIGHT BEFORE A MID TERM
ELECTION.
MEMBERS I I HAVE HAD
CONSTITUENTS NOT ONLY MY
DISTRICT BUT UP AND DOWN THE
STATE TO HAVE.
CALLED MY OFFICE TO TALK TO TO
US ABOUT THE CONCERNS THEY'VE
HAD OVER THEIR PARTY AFFILIATION
BEING CHANGED.
OTHERS WHO WERE REGISTERED TO
VOTE AFTER THEY HE EVEN OPTED
OUT AND OTHERS WERE -- AT WANTED
TO VOTE.
WERE NOT REGISTERED IN TIME FOR
THE ELECTION DUE TO THESE KINDS
OF ERRORS.
MEMBERS WHEN IT COMES TO REAL ID
AND WHEN IT COMES TO MOTOR.
VOTER WE HAVE TO HAVE A A
PERFECT BATTING AVERAGE.
THE YOU KNOW BATTING TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY ONE WE OUGHT TO BE
BATTING A THOUSAND IS REALLY
IMPORTANT.
THIS DEPARTMENT IS THE MOST
PUBLIC FACING ENTITY IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT TOUCHES
MILLIONS UPON MILLIONS OF PEOPLE.
PLACING THIS AUDIT.
AT THIS TIME IN THE HANDS OF OUR
AUDITOR.
PROVIDES HUGE RESOURCES AND AND
FAIRNESS AND EXPERTISE.
THAT QUITE FRANKLY.-WILL INFORM THIS LEGISLATURE AND
ALSO WILL HELP US UNDERSTAND
WHAT THE ADMINISTRATION SIDE IS
DOING WITH RESPECT TO THEIR
AUDITS.
SO THIS IS NOT ABOUT EITHER FOUR
WE THINK THIS IS ABOUT ALL OF US%
TOGETHER.
FINDING THIS PATHWAY THAT IS
GOING TO END UP.
CREATING THE TWENTY TH THAT DMV
OF THE TWENTY FIRST CENTURY. ONE
MORE POINT WITH RESPECT -- TO
CONCERNS WERE RAISED ABOUT MOTOR
VOTER -- MANY OUT.
SAID THAT THEN THAT.
THERE WAS GOING TO BE SOME
ISSUES THAT NON CITIZENS WOULD
FACE.
INCLUDING LAWFUL RESIDENTS WHO
WOULD BE MISTAKENLY REGISTERED
TO VOTE AT THE RISK OF THEIR
CITIZENSHIP.
AT IN AND SO WHAT HAPPENED. ONE
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED IN
ELIGIBLE VOTERS INCLUDING NON
CITIZENS WERE REGISTERED TO VOTE
LAST YEAR BECAUSE OF WHAT QUOTE
EIGHT PROCESSING.
ERROR WHEN WE REGISTER PEOPLE TO
VOTE WE HAVE TO HAVE A 100%.
RELIABILITY THERE IS NO -- GRAY
AREA WHEN IT COMES TO THE
IMPORTANT FRANCHISE OF OF
BUILDING TO MAKE SURE ALL PEOPLE
ARE ELIGIBLE HAVE THAT
OPPORTUNITY AND THAT WE HAVE A
PROCESS IN WHICH THE
REGISTRATION.
IS NOT MERELY ACHIEVED IT IS
PRECISE AND ACCURATE WE THINK
THAT THE AUDITOR WILL HELP US
GET TO THAT PLACE.
AFTER MONTHS OF MISTAKES WE HAVE
THOUSANDS OF EMBARRASSING ERRORS.
WE BELIEVE IT IS TIME FOR
NONPARTISAN INDEPENDENT AUDIT.
FOR THE MOTOR VOTER AND THE REAL
ID.
BECAUSE IT'S ESSENTIAL FOR THE
PEOPLE CALIFORNIA KNOWN
UNDERSTAND INCENSED ESSENTIAL
FOR US. TO HAVE A TRUST
WORTHINESS IN IN WHAT WE ARE.
GETTING FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
MOTOR VEHICLES ONE POINT TO ADD
ON TO THE CHAIR.
WE WE HEARD THE DISCUSSION --
WITH RESPECT TO SEQUENCING.
AND WE WE THINK THIS IS A AN AN
IMPORTANT AREA WHERE WE MAY BE
ABLE. TO HAVE THE AUDIT APPROVED
AND YET SEQUENCE IT IN SUCH A
WAY THAT WE INCORPORATE.
THE EXECUTIVE.
RANCHES INFORMATION BOB AND THAT
IS THE END THAT WILL.
IN MANY WAYS PROBABLY ANSWER
SOME QUESTIONS IT WILL PROBABLY
REDUCE THE THE TIME AND THE COST
NECESSARY AND WILL CERTAINLY.
MOVE THE CONCERNED THAT THIS
AUDIT YEAH -- IS SOMEHOW
DUPLICATIVE AND WITH THAT THE
THE CHAIR AND I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
WELL BEFORE WE GO TO THE STATE
AUDITOR COULD YOU SIMPLY CLARIFY
FOR ME THE SEQUENCING ISSUE
BECAUSE I DON'T UNDERSTAND IT
WHEN WHAT YOU'RE OUT ITS THIRD.
SO THAT'S SOMETHING WE WERE
TALKING WITH THE OTTER THE
ADMINISTRATION IS WE'RE LOOKING
AT A POTENTIAL DATE WE WERE
UNABLE TO REACH COMPROMISE BUT I
WOULD -- TO FOR PROBABLY TO THE
AUDITOR ONCE THE ERNST AND YOUNG
REPORT COMES OUT AND ALSO ONCE
THE STRIKE TURNER TEAM FINISHES
ITS REPORT WHICH WERE TOLD
SHOULD HAPPEN -- AT THE END OF
JULY SO EVEN IF WE DID
IMPLEMENTATION DATE OF SAY
AUGUST OR SEPTEMBER FIRST -- AND
I'M ALSO TOLD THAT THEY ARE
IMPLEMENTING SOME OF THOSE
CHANGES AS WELL SO THE AUDITOR
WOULD.
IN FACT HAVE A CHANCE TO LOOK AT
AND INFORM.
THE RECOMMENDATIONS WHICH ONES
ARE BEING EFFECTIVE IF THEY'RE
ALREADY.
IMPLEMENTING SOME OF THOSE HOW
THEY'RE IMPLEMENTING THOSE WHAT
WERE ULTIMATELY AIMED AT DOING
IS.
WE WANT TO BE A PART OF THE
SOLUTION WE WANT TO BE A PART OF
THE ANSWER.
AND WE DON'T WANT TO BE
DUPLICATIVE WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT EVERYTHING THAT THOSE
REPORTS ARE IDENTIFYING.
THAT WE'RE MOVING FORWARD ON
THOSE BECAUSE I THINK EVERY
CALIFORNIAN DESERVES -- YOU KNOW
A BETTER DMV A BETTER A BETTER
OUTCOME A BETTER EXPERIENCE AND
SO WE'RE HOPING -- WITH THEY
DELAYED IMPLEMENTATION IS WHAT
WE'VE ASKED HERE TODAY TO ALLOW
THOSE REPORTS TO COME OUT -- SO
THAT WE CAN MOVE FORWARD AND
FORMED THE PROCESS AND REMOVING
QUESTION NUMBER FIVE BECAUSE
THAT WAS DONE IN THE BUDGET.
THAT IT WILL REDUCE THE COST
ACTUALLY OF THE AUDIT -- AS WELL
IN THE HOURS REQUIRED -- TO COME
UP WITH RECOMMENDATIONS ANOTHER
INDEPENDENT LOOK AT THIS SO THAT
WE'RE ANALYZING EVERY ANGLE
POSSIBLE AN INDEPENDENT FORM. TO
SOLVE THESE ISSUES AT DMV.
I UNDERSTAND I SO IT'S A
FLOATING START DATE WHICH THE
AUDITOR GETS TO DETERMINE WHICH
IS SORT OF UNUSUAL FOR US TO
MONITOR.
THANK YOU THANK YOUR CENTER ROTH --
AS AS A MEMBERS INDICATED WE
WOULD BE LOOKING AT BOTH REAL ID
AND MOTOR VOTER -- A COUPLE OF
OBJECTIVES LOOK ASKING US TO
IDENTIFY AND EVALUATE CHALLENGES
CERTAINLY THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE ISSUE REPORT IN MARCH OF
TWENTY NINETEEN WE COULD LOOK AT
THE THE RECOMMENDATIONS THAT THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCE MADE -- TO
THE DMV AND DETERMINE WHAT THEY
WHAT ACTIONS THEY'RE TAKING TO
ADDRESS THOSE PARTICULAR
RECOMMENDATIONS BUT ALSO
IDENTIFY ANY OTHER CHALLENGES --
THAT DMV IS FACING WITH RESPECT
TO REAL ID AND AND OUR THE
STATE'S EFFORTS TO COMPLY WITH
FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS -- BUT ALSO --
THE MEMBERS ARE ASKING US TO
LOOK AT NOT JUST WHAT CALIFORNIA
DMV IS INTENDING TO DO TO REACH
COMPLIANCE WITH FEDERAL
REQUIREMENTS.
AND AND THE DEADLINE OF OCTOBER
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY FOUR REAL
ID'S TO BE.
YOU KNOW TO THIS FOR THE STATE
BE FULLY COMPLIANT AND FOR
INDIVIDUALS IN CALIFORNIA HAVE A
REAL ID BUT MOVING FORWARD -- IN
THE EVENT THERE INDIVIDUALS WHO
TAKE LONGER BECAUSE THEY USE
OTHER -- IDENTIFICATION NOW WITH
RESPECT TO CERTAIN OTHER FEDERAL
REQUIREMENTS BUT NOT JUST
LOOKING AT CURRENT BUT ALSO WHAT
DIEM VIS -- PLANS ARE FOR THE
FUTURE TO TO ENSURE CAN
CONTINUED COMPLIANCE WITH REAL
ID REQUIREMENTS WITH RESPECT TO
MOTOR VOTER.
AND WE DO UNDERSTAND THAT ERNST
AND YOUNG IS CONDUCTING SOME
WORK -- ONE OF THE OBJECTIVES IS
ASKING US TO SPECIFICALLY LOOK
AT THAT REVIEW AGAIN WE WOULD BE
INTERESTED IN LOOKING AT THE
SCOPE OF WHAT THEY DID THE
SUPPORT THEY HAVE FOR ANY
CONCLUSIONS THEY REACH WHATEVER
RECOMMENDATIONS THEY MAKE -- AND
THEN WHAT DMV'S INTENT IS AS FAR
AS OR WHAT THEIRPLANS ARE BOTH
DMV AND DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY
AND MOVING FORWARD TO ADDRESS
ANY ISSUES THAT WERE IDENTIFIED
IN THERE THE ERNST AND YOUNG
REPORT.
BUT IN ADDITION TO THAT -- WE
WOULD ALSO BE LOOKING AT WHAT
TYPES OF TRAINING HAVE BEEN
PROVIDED TO DMV EMPLOYEES WITH
RESPECT TO MOTOR VOTER ANY
FUTURE TRAINING THEY INTEND TO
TO PROVIDE -- AND THEN ALSO
LOOKING AT DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY AND WHAT THEIR
RESPONSIBILITIES AND ROLES WORK
ROLE WAS -- IN HELPING DMV
DEVELOPED THE PROGRAM AND THE
PROCESS IS -- FOR ESTABLISHING
DIEM THE MOTOR VOTER AND CERTAIN
ELECTRONIC FORMS THERE ARE
SPECIFIC FORMS THAT --
DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGY ASSISTED
IN DEVELOPMENT IMPLEMENTATION SO
THE MEMBERS ARE ASKING US TO TO
SPEND SOME TIME AT DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY AND ADDITIONAL
OBJECTIVE IS ASKING US TO LOOK
AT CONTROLS OVER THE SYSTEM. TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE
APPROPRIATE CONTROLS TO AVOID
ANY AUTHOR ON AUTHORIZED ACCESS.
TO DMV SYSTEMS -- AND IN THE
EVENT THAT THERE HAS BEEN THERE
ARE IDENTIFIED SECURITY
WEAKNESSES WHAT ACTIONS ARE
BEING TAKEN TO SHORE UP THOSE
PARTICULAR WEAKNESSES AS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS INDICATED
THERE IS ONE OBJECTIVE IN THE
AUDIT ANALYSIS.
THAT CORRESPONDS TO THE THE
NUMBER IN HIS LETTER WOULD BE
OBJECTIVE NINE WHERE WE WERE
BEING ASKED TO LOOK AT THE
REQUEST THAT -- DMV HAD
SUBMITTED.
RIGHT TO THE LEGISLATURE FOR
APPROVAL SINCE THAT.
GIVES ME HAS BEEN APPROVED WE
WOULD TAKE THAT OBJECTIVE OUT
NOT NEED TO DO THAT WORK.
SKEWS ME -- AND THAT WOULD SAVE
SOME TIME WOULD SAVE A LITTLE
OVER A HUNDRED HOURS BECAUSE WE
FELT THAT LOOKING AT THE THE B.
C. P. AND THEIR UNDERLYING
SUPPORT WOULDN'T TAKE OUR STAFF
A LOT OF TIME AND THEN CERTAINLY
SUPERISOR REVIEW.
SO THE HOURS WOULD BE REDUCED
AGAIN CENTER ROTH SIMILAR TO
YOUR QUESTION ON ON THAT
PREVIOUS AUDIT REQUEST TO THE
EXTENT WE CAN RELY ON ANY WORK
THAT ERNST AND YOUNG HAS BEEN
DONE AT THE HAS BEEN DONE BY
ERNST AND YOUNG.
AND HAS BEEN DONE BY DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE WE WOULD CERTAINLY DO
THAT.
BUT THE FOCUS TO THIS PARTICULAR
AUDIT IS OKAY ISSUES HAVE BEEN
IDENTIFIED WHAT ACTIONS ARE DMB
AND OR DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGY
TAKING A TO ADDRESS THOSE
CONCERNS.
THANK YOU AFFECTED AGENCY
[inaudible]
ANYONE HERE.
FROM D. M. V. [inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE.
COME ON DOWN
.
IDENTIFY YOURSELF FOR THE RECORD
PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS I
AM KATHLEEN WEB I AM THE ACTING
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
MOTOR VEHICLES WITH ME TODAY.
IS WEST COOPED UP THE DIRECTOR
OF LICENSING OPERATIONS DIVISION
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MEET WITH YOU.
PROVIDE A STATUS ON DMV'S EFFORT
SUPPORTING THE REAL IDEA MOTOR
VOTER PROGRAMS FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS.
TV HAS MADE A COMMITMENT
CONTINUES TO WORK WITH THE
SECRETARY OF STATE.
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE TO
IMPLEMENT CORRECTIVE ACTIONS AND
ENHANCEMENTS. TO APPROVE
PERFORMANCE OF BOTH A REAL ID
AND THE MOTOR VOTER PROGRAMS.
IN MARCH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE OF THE DEPARTMENT
FINANCE OFFICE THE STATE OUGHT
SENATE VALUATIONS.
COMPLETED AN AUDIT OF THE DMV
AND UNDERTOOK THE FOLLOWING.
ASSESS THE EFFICIENCY AND
EFFECTIVENESS OF DMV'S CURRENT
OPERATIONS AND MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO IMPROVE ITS
PRACTICES.
AND ENHANCE THE FIELD OFFICE
CUSTOMER EXPERIENCE AND EVALUATE
DMV'S INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
SYSTEM AND ITS IMPACT ON THE
FIELD OFFICE CUSTOMER EXPERIENCE.
DMV IS RESPONDED TO THE ART OF
FUNDING THROUGH A CORRECTIVE
ACTION PLAN IT PROVIDED TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AT THE END
OF MAY.
THE PLAN OR THE CAP IS IT'S
REFER TO CONTINUES A PROCESS OF
OVERSIGHT AND EVALUATION.
ON HOW DMV WILL DRESSING CORRECT
ALMOST ONE HUNDRED INDIVIDUAL
AREAS IDENTIFIED BY THE
AUDITOR'S FOR IMPROVEMENT.
ADDITIONALLY THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCES OVERSEEING AN
INDEPENDENT ASSESSMENT OF THE
DMV'S MOTOR VOTER PROGRAM BY
ERNST AND YOUNG.
THE RESULTS OF THIS INDEPENDENT
REVIEW IS EXPECTED TO BE
COMPLETED IN JULY.
TV ALSO CONTINUES TO WORK WITH
THE STRIKE TEAM OF FINDING
ADDITIONAL IMPROVEMENTS.
DESTRY MY OUR OPERATIONS IMPROVE
OUR CUSTOMERS EXPERIENCE AND
MODERNIZE THE DMV.
ADDITIONALLY SINCE LAST AUGUST
DMV'S PROVIDE A MONTHLY REPORTS
TO THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE BUDGET
BUDGET COMMITTEE.
ON ITS WAIT TIMES ANOTHER
OPERATIONAL IMPROVEMENTS TO
BETTER SERVE OUR CUSTOMERS.
THE REPORT PROVIDES
COMPREHENSIVE DATE ON EACH FIELD
OFFICE AND PROVIDES INFORMATION
OF PREVIOUS AN UPCOMING
MILESTONES.
FURTHER THE TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET WILL
REQUIRE ADDITIONAL PERFORMANCE
METRICS REPORTING.
TO ENSURE THAT FUNDING IS BEING
SPENT APPROPRIATELY.
WE ARE FULLY COMMITTED TO MAKING
THE DMV BETTER AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THE
COMMITTEE MAY HAVE [inaudible]
MEMBERS QUESTIONS [inaudible]
SIR MONEY.
THANK YOU MISTER VICE CHAIR I
WANT TO THANK THE MEMBERS FOR
MOVING THIS FORWARD -- ALTHOUGH
I DO HAVE SOME QUESTIONS ABOUT
TIMING IN.
NEED SO I GUESS A QUESTION.
FOR IN FROM DEPARTMENT DIRECTOR
THANK YOU FOR STEPPING UP IN.
HOW DO YOU ASSESS THE?
CORRECTIVE ACTION PLAN FROM
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ON IT IN%
THE ON GOING PARENTS TEN YOUNG.
DO YOU THINK THOSE ARE
COMPREHENSIVE IN PROVIDING.
DIRECTION HIGHLIGHTED AREAS FOR
IMPROVEMENT.
SO ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
TOOK UPON OURSELVES WHEN WE ARE
ALSO SUBMITTING OUR BUDGET
REQUEST ALL OF YOU IS TO DEVELOP
A COMPREHENSIVE WORK PLAN.
AND IN THE HOT COMPREHENSIVE
WORK PLAN WE HAVE IDENTIFIED
WHEN I CALL KIND OF A WORKING
SCHEDULE. TO ADDRESS ALL THE
THINGS THAT WE NEED TO DELIVER --
I AM A FIRM BELIEVER OF BEING
KIND OF THE RISK MANAGEMENT --
ELK AND ALSO ABOUT PERFORMANCE
MUCH MANAGEMENT.
IS THAT IF YOU DON'T ACTUALLY
DOCUMENT YOU DON'T MEASURE IT
OFTENTIMES DOESN'T GET DONE.
AND SO IT WAS REALLY CLEAR TO ME
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE CLEARLY
IDENTIFY ALL THAT NEED TO BE
DONE THE MILESTONES.
DEVELOP TIMELINES -- BE ABLE TO
ALSO MAKE APPROPRIATE COURSE
CORRECTIONS IF WE DETERMINE THE
PATH WE WERE TAKING WAS NOT THE
RIGHT PATH.
THOSE ARE ALL IMPORTANT IN
MAKING GOOD DECISIONS SO I FEEL
BETWEEN THE CORRECTIVE ACTION
PLAN.
THE WORK PLAN AND THEN --
DETERMINING WHAT THE ASSESSMENT
IS FROM ERNST AND YOUNG -- WILL
HAVE A GOOD HANDLE ON THINGS WE
NEED TO DO.
THAT BEING SAID I DON'T DISMISS
THE VALUE OF AN AUDIT I AM A
KIND OF A CHAMPION FOR AUDITS
AND APPRECIATE THE VALUE.
I THINK THE TIMING OF IT IS
PROBABLY WHAT'S MOST IMPORTANT.
IS IMPORTANT FOR US TO AT LEAST
ALLOW THE TIME TO IMPLEMENT WHAT
WE STARTEDTO ACTUALLY SEE THAT
THERE'S BEEN SOME MARKET
IMPROVEMENTS I WOULD TELL YOU
SAID SHE JUST APPROVE THE BUDGET.
WE HAVEN'T HAD A CHANCE EVEN
IMPLEMENT SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT YOU'VE ALLOWED US TO GO
AHEAD AND IMPLEMENT -- AND THEN
THE SO YOUNG ASSESSMENT IS GOING
TO BE INTERESTING BUT I WILL
ASSURE YOU.
THAT ON A WEEKLY BASIS WE ARE A
CONSTANT CONVERSATION WITH THE
SECRETARY OF STATE WITH REGARDS
TO THE PROGRAMMATIC ASPECTS OF
MOTOR VOTER -- AND IT'S ALSO
IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER THAT.
THE DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR VEHICLES
SERVES AS AN ADMINISTRATOR FOR
THE SECRETARY OF STATE.
WE PROCESS THE INFORMATION
MAKING THE DETERMINATION ON
THOSE THAT ARE ELIGIBLE TO VOTE
IN REGISTERING IN THE ROLES THAT
STILL LIES WITH THE SECRETARY OF
STATE.
SO I THINK THAT'S ALSO PART WHEN
YOU CONSIDER WHAT YOU'RE GOING
TO BE EVALUATING.
THANK YOU FROM.
THE THE THE PROPOSED BUDGET
ALLOCATION FOR NINETEEN TWENTY
DOES THAT PROVIDE YOU SUFFICIENT
RESOURCES TO IMPLEMENT YEAR
STRATEGIC.
WORK PLAN.
AT THIS POINT TIME BASED ON OUR
ASSESSMENT AND TRYING TO ALSO BE
EXTREMELY GOOD STEWARDS OF THE
MONEY SO THE CALIFORNIANS WE
BELIEVE IT DOES -- I THINK WHEN
YOU LOOK AT THE VOLUME OF
CALIFORNIANS THAT DO HAVE
DRIVER'S LICENSE AND
IDENTIFICATIONS AND THEY ONE OF
THE LARGEST STATES TO GO AHEAD
AND UNDERTAKE THIS OFFER -- IT
IS A SIGNIFICANT AND I THINK AS
I SAID EARLIER IT'S A STARK AN
UNPRECEDENTED FOR THE CALIFORNIA
FOR THE DMV.
BUT I DO BELIEVE WE HAVE THE
RESOURCES I THINK MORE
IMPORTANTLY IT'S NOT JUST ONE
SET OF THINGS WERE LOOKING OUT
TO IMPROVE IT.
IT'S HOW DO WE USE OUR WEBSITE
IN A MORE EFFICIENT WAY IT'S HOW
DO WE DEPLOY MORE CHAOS SO THAT
WE CAN SERVE MORE PEOPLE THROUGH
THE VEHICLE REGISTRATION PROCESS.
HOW DO WE CREATE MORE CAPACITY
THAN IN OUR FIELD OFFICES TO
HANDLE THE DRIVER'S LICENSE AND
IDENTIFICATION?
PROCESSING THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE
SO I THINK AT THIS POINT TIME WE
FEEL CONFIDENT BUT I ALSO KNOW
WILL BE REPORTING TO YOU ON A
REGULAR BASIS.
AND THE FUNDING YOU'VE GIVEN US
IS FOR A TWO YEAR PERIOD OF TIME
SO WE'LL BE ABLE TO GET IN.
CONTINUE TO ASSESS HOW WE ARE
APPROPRIATELY FORECASTED WHAT WE
NEED HELP WE ARE PROBABLY
FORECAST AT THE DEMAND -- AND
HAVE WE ANTICIPATED THE POSITIVE
RESULTS FROM THE OTHER THINGS
THAT WE THINK WE'RE GOING TO BE
DOING. TO HELP ADDRESS CUSTOMER
NEEDS.
THANK YOU -- SO [inaudible]
AND YOU'VE SUGGESTED A
WILLINGNESS TO COOPERATE SHOULD
THERE BE A STATE ON IT BUT GIVEN
WHAT YOU ARE SEEKING TO
IMPLEMENT RIGHT NOW -- THE
TIMING OF THAT ON IT I THINK YOU
ALLUDED TO IT BUT WHAT IT DIVERT
INTERNAL RESOURCES THAT WOULD
IMPEDE YOUR ABILITY TO ACHIEVE.
CURRENTLY IDENTIFIED OBJECTIVES.
WELL I THINK -- I CAN ASSURE YOU
IN MY SHORT TENURE AT DMV --
WITH A NUMBER OF AUDIT SICK IT
DONE ON THE DMV I AM CONSTANTLY
DIVERTING RESOURCES. TO SUPPORT
THE AUDIT ACTIVITY -- THAT JUST
COMES WITH THE TERRITORY SO BUT
I CAN'T TELL YOU WHAT THE
RESOURCES WOULD BE BECAUSE THAT
WOULD DEPEND ON THE SCOPE OF THE
AUDIT.
BUT THERE WOULD BE A DIVERSION
OF RESOURCES TO SUPPORT THE
AUDIT ACTIVITY.
INTO ASKED THAT ANOTHER WAY --
WOULD IT BE MORE USEFUL. TO
SERVING THE PUBLIC INTEREST. TO
HAVE AN AUDIT THAT CAME.
LATER AFTER THE RETURN OF THE
ERNST AND YOUNG ON IT IN YOUR
ABILITY TO PURSUE SOME OF THE
CURRENTLY STATED A REFORM SENATE
CHECKED OF STATE YOU'RE WORKING
ON I WOULD APPRECIATE THAT -- I
I THINK IT WOULD ALLOW US TIME.
TO UNDERSTAND WHAT THE CITY
YOUNG FOLKS HAVE IDENTIFIED AS
SOME IMPROVEMENTS THAT COULD BE
MADE -- AND AGAIN IT'S IT'S
THROUGH A PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
SECRETARY OF STATE THAT WE'D BE
LOOKING AT IMPROVEMENTS THAT
COULD BE MADE -- BUT I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT NOT TO MAYBE --
OVER AUDIT OR OVER ANALYZED --
TO I THINK WE NEED ALLOW SOME
THINGS TO HAPPEN IN TO
MATERIALIZE TO LET US UNDERSTAND
WHAT IT MEANS FOR US.
I THINK PROGRAM MEDICALLY
THERE'S A LOT OF PEOPLE VESTED
IN DMV DOING REALLY REALLY WELL --
INCLUDING MYSELF IN THE GOVERNOR
ON THE GOVERNOR'S STRIKE TEAM.
AND I THINK WE LIKE A CHANCE TO
REALLY TRULY IMPLEMENT SOME OF
THESE THINGS WE BELIEVE WILL
MAKE A DIFFERENCE BUT I
CERTAINLY DON'T DISMISS.
THE REQUESTED I THINK I'M.
AS YOU'VE ALL POINTED OUT WE
TOUCH MORE CALIFORNIANS THAN
ALMOST ANY OTHER DEPARTMENT --
AND WE TAKE THAT RESPONSIBILITY
VERY SERIOUSLY BUT I ALSO
APPRECIATE -- DOING AUDITS TO
CHECK THE INTEGRITY OF OUR
SYSTEM AND HOW WE'RE DELIVERING
I THINK THAT'S A GREAT
MEASUREMENT FOR THE DMV AS WELL.
BUT I REALLY WOULD APPRECIATE US
THINKING ABOUT THE TIMING OF IT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR IF I
MAY YES PLAN -- AND THAT'S WHY
WE WERE TRYING TO NEGOTIATED
DELAYED IMPLEMENTATION SO THAT
WE HAVE THE RIVER.
THE ANSWERS FROM NOT ONLY THERE
TO SEND YOUNG REPORT BUT EVEN
THE STRIKE FORCE TEAM YOU KNOW
SO I APPLAUD THEIR EFFORTS IN
DOING THAT BUT WE DON'T WANT TO
BE DUPLICATIVE OF THAT BUT
WANTED TO ALLOW THE AUDITOR TO
COME IN.
ONCE WE RECEIVE THOSE AND THAT
WAS WHY WE WERE PUSHING FOR A
DELAYED IMPLEMENTATION SO WE CAN
INCORPORATE THOSE -- MOVING
FORWARD AS WELL THANK YOU AND I
APPRECIATE THAT CLARIFICATION.
I HAVE NO FURTHER QUESTIONS
RIGHT NOW MISTER CHAIR THANK
CENTER.
COLLEAGUES FOR THE QUESTIONS.
MOVE THE MOVE THE AUDIT. FOR A
SECOND.
LET ME -- LET ME MAKE A COMMENT
HERE -- FIRST I WANT TO COMMEND
THE AUTHORS -- THERE COULD BE.
TWO NO FINER AUTHORS FOR THIS
PARTICULAR REQUEST -- AND I WANT
TO SAY THAT I CERTAINLY VALUE
EXTERNAL AUDIT CERTAINLY BY OUR
SUPERB STATE AUDITOR.
WHO DOES AN OUTSTANDING JOB IN
FACT THE LAST TIME THIS MATTER
CAME BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE -- I
VOTED FOR IT.
NOW IT DIDN'T MAKE IT THROUGH
THE HOOP -- BUT SINCE THAT TIME --
THE THE CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF
STATE AUDITS CONDUCTED IS HAS
BEEN REFERENCED -- ON AUDIT OF
THE DMV AND ISSUED A REPORT.
TOWARD THE END OF MARCH OF TWO
THOUSAND AND NINETEEN AND WHAT
WE FOUND WAS THIS IS NO SIMPLE
MATTER HERE IN THE DMV THE ISSUE
IS A VERY VERY COMPLEX.
WE HAVE IT ISSUES BOTH IN TERMS
OF THE SYSTEM WE HAVE STAFFING
ISSUES IN TERMS OF NUMBERS OF
PEOPLE IN THE TRAINING PROVIDED.
WE HAD SIGNIFICANT LONG STANDING
FUNING ISSUES.
I IN THE DMV PROVIDING THE DMV
WITH ENOUGH MONEY. TO DO THE
VERY VERY IMPORTANT.
JOB IS THAT WE OF TEST DMV WOULD
DOING BOTH AT THE STATE LEVEL ON
THE FEDERAL LEVEL.
AND WE CERTAINLY IDENTIFIED
PUBLIC COMMUNICATION ISSUES IN
TERMS OF WHAT'S REQUIRED FOR
ALMOST ANYTHING AND HOW TO GET
THAT INFORMATION OUT OR WHETHER
WE HAVE THE SYSTEMS.
INSIDE THE DMV AND OUTSIDE TO
FOR TO PUSH THAT INFORMATION OUT
[inaudible]
WELL.
WE STARTED WORKING ON THOSE AS
YOU ALL KNOW AND IT'S BEEN
REFERENCED WE'VE APPROPRIATED
SEVERAL HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS --
IN LONG OVERDUE FUNDING FOR THE
D. M. V. TO START.
WORKING THESE ISSUES WHETHER
IT'S I. T. UPGRADES FOR HIRING
AND TRAINING THE RIGHT THE RIGHT
PEOPLE TO DO THE JOB.
OF THE GOVERNOR DESIGNATED A
STRIKE TEAM -- WITH THE HEAD.
OF THE SECRETARY OFOF GOV OPS --
WHO IS -- ABSOLUTELY THE MOST
OUTSTANDING PUBLIC SERVANT I
THINK I'VE EVER HAD THE PLEASURE.
OF THE WORKING WITHIN.
IN THIRTY TWO YEARS OF MILITARY
SERVICE AND ALL OF THE REST OF
THE TIME THAT I'VE PUT IN IN AND
OUT OF THE SERVICE.
WE HAVE AN ERNST AND YOUNG OF
STUDY THAT'S GOING ON THAT'S
BEEN REFERENCED IT'LL BE ISSUED
IN.
HOPEFULLY A FEW MONTHS -- TO
DEAL WITH SOME MORE OF THESE --
MORE OF THESE PROBLEMS.
AND IDENTIFY SOLUTIONS.
SO AT THIS POINT WHILE I
CERTAINLY VALUE AN EXTERNAL
WATER THAN I THINK AT SOME POINT
IN TIME WE DO NEED -- TO
AUTHORIZE AND APPROVE.
AN AUDIT BY OUR STATE AUDITOR TO
GO IN AND SEE WHAT THE FIXES ARE
THAT HAVE BEEN IMPLEMENTED AND
WHETHER THOSE HAVE BEEN WORKING
I'M NOT SURE FRANKLY THAT THIS
IS.
THE RIGHT TIME TO DO SO FROM A
PERSONAL PERSPECTIVE I THINK WE
NEED TO LET THIS PROCESS
CONTINUE WE NEED TO LET THE
ERNST AND YOUNG REPORT SURFACE.
WIENER WINDOW AT THE STRIKE TEAM
WORKS THROUGH THE LIST OF
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WERE
IDENTIFIED BURKE CALIFORNIA
OFFICE OF STATE AUDITS.
AND ADDRESS THOSE THAT I HOPE
WERE FORTHCOMING AS PART OF THE
YEAR AND JUSTIN YOUNG.
OF AUDIT.
AND ALLOW THOSE IMPLEMENTATIONS
TO OCCUR.
HOPEFULLY SUCCESSFULLY BEFORE WE
LAUNCH THE STATE HONOR IN THERE
SO THAT WHEN WE DO LAUNCH THE
STATE AUDITOR.
ON OF FORAY INTO THE DMV TO THE
TUNE OF ALMOST FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
THAT THE STATE AUDITOR HAS
SOMETHING NEW TO LOOK AT SO THAT
WHEN SHE ISSUES A REPORT SHE
ISSUES OF REPORT BASED ON THE
CHANGES THE SOLUTIONS THAT HAVE
BEEN IDENTIFIED THE CHANGES THAT
HAVE BEEN IMPLEMENTED. TO TELL
US IN FACT WHETHER THOSE WORK OR
NOT SO I JUST WANTED TO PUT.
A MY POSITION ON THE RECORD TO
COMMAND THE REQUEST YEARS -- AT
FOR THEIR EFFORTS AND INDICATE
THAT -- I CERTAINLY WILL BE
SUPPORTIVE AT SOME POINT IN THE
FUTURE OF AN AUDIT OF OUR DMV.
pI'M NOT GONNA BE JUST BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT IT.
TO TODAY.
SO HAVING SAID THAT PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THIS ISSUE
[inaudible]
SEEING NONE [inaudible]
CENTER.
YES -- CAN I TO I DON'T WANT TO
SURPRISE ANYONE SO I YOU KNOW
AFTER REVIEWING -- ALL THE
INFORMATION AS WELL -- I TO WILL
BE OF THE SAME SENTIMENT OF
SENATOR ROTH -- IT.
I KNOW THAT YOUR BRAND NEW IN
YOUR COMING IN HERE I'M BRAND
NEW AS WELL AND I KNOW HOW
DIFFICULT IT MAY BE ON YOU WHEN
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF ATTENTION
AND I JUST TRUST THAT WE ARE
DOING AND PUTTING THE RIGHT
PROCEDURES IN PLACE TO ENSURE
THAT.
WE'RE GETTING ENOUGH INFORMATION
FIRST AND FOREMOST BEFORE WE
BEGIN ANOTHER AUDIT -- AND IN
REFERENCE TO THE FIFTEEN HUNDRED
OR SO NON ELIGIBLE PERSONS THAT
MAY BE UNDOCUMENTED TO VOTE.
THERE WAS NO MMHM -- MENTION
HERE OF WORK WITH SECRETARY OF
STATE AND SO I THINK THAT IF
THAT IS AN ISSUE THAT PERHAPS.
THAT COULD BE ADDRESSED ON THE
ROAD AS WELL -- SO WITH THAT.
THAT'S WHERE I STAND AT THIS
POINT.
COLLEAGUES IT'S BEEN MOVED AND
SECONDED OF LET'S CALL THE ROLL.
IF I MAY CLOSE YOU CERTAINLY MAY
I APOLOGIZE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- AND I
APPRECIATE THE DIALOGUE HERE
TODAY AND I APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS FROM BY THE VICE CHAIR
AS WELL.
AND MOVING FORWARD YOU KNOW IT.
AT THE END OF THE DAY WE'RE
TRYING TO DO IS CRAFTED MODERATE.
THAT WOULD BE RESPECTIVE OF THE
WORK THAT'S BEING DONE BY THE
ADMINISTRATION BY THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE A STRIKE TEAM --
GOVERNMENT OPS AN EARNEST YOUNG --
WHICH IS WHY WE TRY TO COME TO
THIS COMPROMISE OF PERHAPS A
DELAYED IMPLEMENTATION ONE
DAUGHTER WOULD GO IN -- MY IT'S
MY UNDERSTANDING THAT SOME OF
THOSE -- RECOMMENDATIONS
ACTUALLY BEING -- MOVED ON NOW.
SO.
I BELIEVE AUDITOR WOULD HAVE --
SOME MATERIAL ACTUALLY REVIEW --
WITH THAT I JUST THINK IT'S
INTUITIVE ON ALL OF US TO USE
ALL THE RESOURCES AVAILABLE TO
US AT THE STATE. TO TRY TO COME
UP WITH THE RECOMMENDATIONS TO
HELP SOLVE THE ISSUES AT DMV I
BELIEVE THE AUDITOR CAN PROVIDE
SOME OF THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS
WITH AN IN DEPTH LOOK.
AT HOW WE GET TO IMPROVING DMV
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS.
RIGHT WE KNOW THAT THERE'S BEEN
DOCUMENTED INSTANCES THAT I'VE
BEEN.
ACROSS NUMEROUS HEADLINES AND A
NUMBER OF NEWS REPORTS -- WE
HEAR IT ANECDOTALLY FROM OUR
CONSTITUENTS BACK HOME -- YOU
KNOW EVEN FOR FAMILY MEMBERS WHO
HAVE TOLD ME THEY WAITED IN LINE
FOR OVER EIGHT HOURS.
WHAT WE WANT TO DO IS WE WANT TO
TRY TO FIX DMV FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS WE THINK THE ODD IT
HELPS?
DO THAT MOVES US IN THAT
DIRECTION WE SEE THIS AS BEING A
PART OF THE SOLUTION NOT A
HURDLE.
IN ANY SENSE OF THE WORD BUT
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN DO
COLLECTIVELY WITH ALL OUR STATE
RESOURCES TO TRY TO IMPROVE IN
AND MAKE A DIFFERENCE.
AND WITH THAT I THINK -- MISTER
PATTERSON HAD ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS I'D APPRECIATE THAT
WANT TO REITERATE THAT THE
MANNER IN WHICH WE ARE
APPROACHING THIS.
IS TO PRECISELY DELAY THIS TO
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SEE THE ERNST
AND YOUNG AUDIT. TO COME FORWARD
A MAYBE THAT'S JULY OR AUGUST.
SOONER OR LATER I THINK WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO HAVE THE ARE
INDEPENDENT EYES OF THE STATE
AUDITOR ON THIS.
AND I AM NOT I DON'T REALLY WANT
TO IN INTER UP POLITICAL KINDS
OF THINGS BUT LET'S UNDERSTAND
WE HAVE A SEPARATE SEPARATION OF
POWERS.
AND THERE IS THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH THERE'S THE TO LET JUST
LET LEGISLATIVE -- SENATE.
AND ASSEMBLY AND THERE IS.
INHERENT IN THAT.
A DEGREE OF OF CONFLICT WHAT WE
HAVE IN OUR STATE AUDITOR.
IS AN INDEPENDENT.
NONPARTISAN.
HIGHLY SKILLED WITH A STAFF THAT
HAS REPEATEDLY COME FORWARD WITH
AUDITS THAT HAVE BEEN --
REVELATIONS POINTING AND
DIRECTIONS -- THAT WE DIDN'T
EVEN KNOW ABOUT THAT EVEN --
SURPRISED -- THAT THE
INSTITUTIONS OF THE WORK THAT.
ASSEMBLY TO THE AUDIT.
IT IS THE IMPORTANCE IT SEEMS TO
ME. TO HAVE AT THE TABLE AS SOON
AS POSSIBLE [inaudible]
AN INDEPENDENT.
A HIGHLY REGARDED [inaudible]
A PROFESSIONAL.
IT IS ALSO.
OF MY EXPERIENCE IN -- EIGHT
YEARS BEING A MAYOR FRESNO THAT
WITHOUT AUDITS YOU HAVE NO IDEA
WHAT'S GOING ON EVEN THOUGH YOU
ARE AT THE EXECUTIVE OF THE CITY
AND SO WE HAD.
LOTS OF STAFF AUDITOR'S IT HAD
TO DO THIS KIND OF KIND OF WORK.
THAT AGAIN ARE.
ASKING THOSE WHO ARE CONSIDERING --
NOT VOTING ON THIS OUGHT TO
RECOGNIZE THAT WHAT WE ARE DOING
HERE IS PRECISELY WHAT YOU'RE
ASKING WHICH IS.
SPUR SPACE THIS AWHILE WHAT
WE'RE SAYING IS LET'S NOT STE.
THAT'S NOT DO NOTHING.
LET'S HAVE THAT INFORMATION COME.
SEQUENCE AT THE WAY WE HAVE THAT
DECIDED EARLIER ON ON A ON A
DIFFERENT AUDIT.
AND ALLOW THE AUDITOR TO TAKE A
LOOK AND THEN.
MOVE FORWARD.
UP HAVING SAID THAT.
I ACTUALLY THINK THAT.
THERE'S GONNA BE A HIGH
PROBABILITY THAT THAT OVER TIME
WE WILL CONTINUE UNFORTUNATELY
TO SEE.
OUR PROBLEMS AND I THINK SOONER
OR LATER.
GIVEN A PERIOD OF TIME.
IT WOULD BE HELPFUL.
NOT IN A HINDRANCE NOT
DUPLICATION BUT HELPFUL. TO HAVE
A LANE HOUSE EYES ON THIS AS
WELL SO I I I SUSPECT THERE WILL
BE OTHER MEMBERS COMING FORWARD
UP WITH OTHER AUDIT.
IT'S SIMILAR AUDIT REQUESTS AS
WE MOVE FORWARD AND AT SOME
POINT I HOPE THOSE THAT ARE
READY.
TO MOVE THIS ONE FOUR WOULD
WOULD BE WILLING TO TAKE A LOOK
AT THE NEXT ONE THAT WE BRING
FORWARD.
WITH POP FOR THAT FOR THESE
REASONS I ASK FOR YOUR AYE BOAT.
THANK YOU GERMAN OF PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO APPROVE WATER
REQUEST NUMBER TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN DASH.
ONE FIFTEEN DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR
VEHICLES REAL IDEA
IMPLEMENTATION BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SALAS.
SOME MEMBER SALAS HI SALAS HI
BOERNER HORVATH [inaudible]
DEEP [inaudible]
PATTERSON [inaudible]
I RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE VOEPEL.
VOEPEL I WOULD [inaudible]
WHAT I?
SENATOR ROTH NO.
ROTH NO FORGES [inaudible]
GONZALEZ [inaudible]
GONZALEZ NOW [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
MONNING [inaudible]
MORE LAX.
MORE LIKE I WIENER.
LISTEN JOE WE HAVE A MEMBERS OF
BOTH HOUSES IN COMMITTEES AT
VARIOUS PLACES AROUND THE
BUILDING SO WE WILL HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
THANK.
OKAY AT THIS TIME WE'RE GOING TO
GO AHEAD AND MOVE TO AGENDA ITEM.
NUMBER SEVEN THIS IS TWO ZERO
ONE NINE DASH ONE ONE SIX
JUVENILE JUSTICE CRIME
PREVENTION ACT FUNDS BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JONES SAWYER.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER REGINALD BYRON
JONES SAWYER SENIOR YOU MAY
PROCEED -- WHEN YOU ARE READY?
OKAY -- GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
I AM RECESS I AM RESPECTFULLY
REQUESTING THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE
AUDIT COMMITTEE TO APPROVE AN
AUDIT TO EVALUATE TO SPENDING.
DECISION MAKING REPORTING AND
EVALUATION OF JUVENILE JUSTICE
CRIME PREVENTION ACT JJ CPA
FUNDS.
IN TWO THOUSAND THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE PASSED THE SHIFT
CARD IN THIS CRIME PREVENTION
ACT WHICH AUTHORIZE NON
COMPETITIVE FUNDING FOR COUNTIES
TO SUPPORT PROGRAMS TO REDUCE
YOUTH.
CRIME THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE
ALSO ASSIGNED A BOARD OF STATE
AND COMMUNITY CORRECTION BSE SEE
AT THE FUND ADMINISTRATOR
ADMINISTRATOR.
A TWO THOUSAND ONE SENATE BILL
EXTENDED THE FUNDING AND CHANGE
ITS NAME TO THE JUVENILE JUSTICE
CRIME PREVENTION ACT J. J. C. P.
A THIS WAS ESTABLISHED TO
PROVIDE A STABLE FUNDING SOURCE
FOR PROGRAMS.
PROVEN TO REDUCE CRIME AND
DELINQUENCY AMONG WHAT I CALL AT
PROMISE YOUTH.
THE MANAGEMENT OF THE FUND
SHOULD BE BASED ON IMPLEMENTING
LANGUAGE COLLABORATIVE AND
INCLUSIVE OF THE COMMUNITY.
FURTHER PROOF OF COMMUNITY
FOCUSED INTENT IS THE
REDEFINITION OF FRONTLINE LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO INCLUDE COMMUNITY
CRIME PREVENTION AND JUSTICE
JUVENILE JUSTICE PROGRAM.
DJJ C. P. A PROGRAM.
HAS PROVIDED GRANTS TOTALING
APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED MILLION.
EACH YEAR FOR COUNTY TO SUPPORT
YOUTH IN THE COMMUNITY THROUGH
AN ARRAY OF INTERVENTION AND
PREVENTION PROGRAMS.
EXCUSE ME MY CONCERN IN A REASON
FOR THIS AUDIT IS TO ENSURE THAT
THESE FUNDS ARE USED
APPROPRIATELY TO PROVIDE THE
RETURN ON INVESTMENT R. O. Y. DE
CALIFORNIA JUST BACK WHEN
FUNDING THESE PROGRAMS.
IN PARTICULAR HAVE CONCERNS THAT
COUNTIES ARE OUT OF COMPLIANCE
WITH DECISION MAKING PROCESS IS
MANDATED BY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
JJ CPA REQUIRES COUNTIES TO
CREATE A JUVENILE JUSTICE
COORDINATING COUNCIL THAT
COLLABORATIVELY DEVELOP JJ CPAP
SPENDING PLANS WITHIN GRAZIER
FROM COUNTY DEPARTMENTS
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
AND THE COMMUNITY.
AT LARGE GET A NUMBER OF
COUNTIES HAVE LEFT MANDATED
MEMBER SEATS VACANT FOR YEARS
AND THERE IS EVIDENCE THAT SOME
COUNTIES ARE NOT ENGAGING IN
COLLABORATIVE REALLY OR UPDATING
THE REQUIRED SPENDING PLANS TO
KEEP UP WITH THE NEEDS OF YOUTH.
CURRENT SPENDING PRACTICES MUST
BE INVESTIGATED TO NOT ONLY
ACCOUNT FOR POOR ALLOCATION
DECISIONS BUT ALSO POTENTIAL
UNDER SPENDING OF JJ CPA FUNDS
FOR EXAMPLE.
THE LOCAL AUDIT OF LOS ANGELES
COUNTY FOUND THAT BY DECEMBER OF
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN TWENTY
SEVEN MILLION IN UNSPENT J. J.
C. P. FUNDS.
HAD BEEN ALLOCATED AND LITTLE
EVIDENCE EXISTED TO SHOW ANY OF
THE SPENDING WAS EFFECTIVE IN
REDUCING RECIDIVISM A RIP.
IMPROVING YOUTH OUTCOMES
MOREOVER EXISTING COUNTY
REPORTING PRACTICES MAKE IT
EXTREMELY DIFFICULT FOR COUNTY
AGENCIES ELECTED OFFICIALS ARE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC. TO
EVALUATE HOW EFFECTIVELY JJ CPA.
DOLLARS ARE BEING INVESTED OVER
A HUNDRED MILLION IN STATE FUNDS
HAVE BEEN ALLOCATED TO COUNTIES
ANNUALLY WITHOUT ADEQUATE
REPORTING TRANSPARENCY OVERSIGHT
FOR NEARLY TWO DECADES.
THIS PROVOKEDAUDIT WOULD NOT
ONLY INSURE POLICYMAKERS AND
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC HAVE AN
ACCURATE UNDERSTANDING OF HOW
THE STATE DOLLARS ARE BEING
ALLOCATED TO MANAGE EACH YEAR
BUT ALSO INSURANCE INVESTMENT
LOCAL SERVICES THAT MEET THE DID.
THE DIVERSE NEEDS OF OUR STATE
YOU.
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR OPENING WE
WILL MOVE TO YOUR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON THE PHONE IF YOU
STATE YOUR NAME. FOR THE RECORD
AT LEAST ONCE MADE THEM WITH THE
YOU'VE JUST COALITION.
OKAY -- HE'S -- IN LA COUNTY WE
ORGANIZE TO IN THAT JJ CPA
FUNDED VOLUNTARY PROP BRIGHT
PROBATION PROGRAM I SAY
VOLUNTARY WITH -- PARENTHESES
AROUND IT BECAUSE THAT MANY
YOUTH AND FAMILIES WERE GIVEN
MUCH CHOICE.
WHETHER OR NOT TO PARTICIPATE IN
THIS PROGRAM. THOUSAND YOUTH
EACH EACH YEAR ARE SUPERVISED.
BY PROBATION OFFICERS EVEN
THOUGH THEY HAD NEVER BEEN
ARRESTED. 81% ARE SUPERVISED BY.
PROBATION OFFICERS FOR ACADEMIC
REASONS SUCH AS LOW GRADES ARE A
ABSENCES -- I'M WHAT I WITNESSES
PROGRAM IN SCHOOL -- WHEN MY
FORMAL PROBATION OFFICER?
TOLD ME THAT I HAD TO REPORTS OF
MY ON CAMPUS PROBATION OFFICER --
BACKGROUND WITH THE COMPTON HIGH.
AND I CALLED AND I WE AT THIS --
BUNGALOW AND THE BUNGALOW -- IS
WHAT IT TO POLICE.
THE SCHOOL PLEASE WHERE -- SO I
ALSO SYSTEMS OF VOLUNTEER
PROBATION BEAR WITH ME
[inaudible]
SO.
SO THE PREVENTION OF HIS WAS PUT
INSIDE BUT SO THE PROBATION
OFFICE WAS PUT IN FACT POLICE
BUNGALOW SINCE I WAS A FORMER
PROBATION EVERY DAY.
FOR DURING MY FORTY FIVE MINUTE
LUNCH BREAK I HAD TO WALK POLICE
TO WALK TO THE POLICE VOTED.
AT A YOUNG AGE I WAS -- SORRY
I'M I'M I'M I'M ALL OVER THE
PLACE WITH MY WITH MY NOTES OKAY
BUT LET ME COME DOWN.
SO I CALIFORNIA 90% OF YOUTH ARE
INCARCERATED.
THAT ARE INCARCERATED IN
JUVENILE LOS PROBATION CAMPS AND
STATE DJJ YOUTH PRISONS WE'RE
SUPPOSED SUSPENDED AND EXPELLED
FROM SCHOOL BEFORE THEY WERE
LOCKED UP LIKE MYSELF -- AND
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL I WAS
SUSPENDED -- FOR I WAS EXPELLED
FOR BEING SUSPENDED TOO MANY
TIMES AND EVENTUALLY I WAS ON
PROBATION AGE.
TWELVE OUT OF VIOLATED A
PROBATION -- AT COMP DIES SO I
HIGH SCHOOL AND I WAS ACTUALLY
SENT. TO JAIL FROM COMPTON HIGH.
SO I KNOW THIS PROGRAM.
THE VOLUNTARY PRO PROGRAM OR
PROBATION PERIOD DOESN'T GIVE
YOU THE TOOLS NECESSARY TO
REALLY BE SUCCESSFUL IN LIFE.
SO I FEEL LIKE THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA NEED TO KNOW WHERE
THEIR MONEY IS GOING AND IF IT'S
GOING TO PROGRAM IS GONNA REALLY
BENEFIT THE COMMUNITY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING ARE OR AFTERNOON
AFTERNOON -- MY NAME IS FOR NAME
AND ART -- BUT THE CENTER ON
JUVENILE AND CRIMINAL JUSTICE.
IN THE MOST RECENT YEAR REPORTED
THE STATE A LOT IT A TOTAL OF
ONE HUNDRED AND FORTY NINE POINT
THREE MILLION DOLLARS FOR JJ CPA
TO REDUCE YOUTH INVOLVEMENT IN
THE JUSTICE SYSTEM.
THROUGH LOCAL PROGRAMMING.
COUNTIES RECEIVE GRANTS NON
COMPETITIVELY EVERY YEAR AND
WITH LITTLE OVERSIGHT OR
ACCOUNTABILITY THERE ARE RISING
CONCERNS ACROSS THE STATE ABOUT
POOR MANAGEMENT OF JJ CPA FINDS.
RECENT EFFORTS BY RESEARCHERS TO
FIND OUT HOW THESE FUNDS ARE
BEING SPENT HALF ON MAJOR ISSUES
WITH DATA REPORTING PRACTICES BY
COUNTIES AS WELL AS THE BSE SEE.
COUNTY REPORTING OF PROGRAMS ARE
MINIMAL RELYING ON BRIEF PROGRAM
DESCRIPTIONS SOME OF WHICH HAVE
NOT BEEN UPDATED YEAR TO YEAR
AND REPORTING LACKS ANY STATE
LEVEL SUMMARY OR ANALYSIS ON
OUTCOMES.
IN FACT WE'VE BEEN UNABLE TO
EVEN FIND OUT THE NUMBER OF
YOUTH BEING SERVED BY JJ CPA
FUNDED PROGRAMS.
THE JG CPA IS A VITAL INVESTMENT
FOR THE STATE BUT COUNTY
ALLOCATIONS DO NOT SEEM TO HAVE
KEPT UP WITH THE NATIONAL BEST
PRACTICES NOR CURRENT JUVENILE
JUSTICE TRENDS.
ACROSS THE STATE AND NATION WE
ARE SEEING HISTORIC DECLINED IN
USE THE REST MEANING THAT FEWER
USE ARE COMING INTO CONTACT WITH
THE JUSTICE SYSTEM ALL TOGETHER.
YET THERE IS EVIDENCE THAT THE
MAJORITY OF JJ CPA DOLLARS ARE
BEING SPENT ON SALARIES AND
BENEFITS NOTABLY FOR COUNTY
PROBATION DEPARTMENTS DESPITE
THE DROPPING NUMBERS OF YOUTH
THEY SERVE.
HARMFUL PROGRAMS FUNDED BY THE
JJ CPA SUCH AS VOLUNTARY
PROBATION WHICH IMPOSES
RESTRICTIVE PROBATION
SUPERVISION OVER YOUNG PEOPLE
WHO HAVE NOT BEEN PROSECUTED FOR
CRIME.
FURTHER CRIMINALIZE YOUTH RATHER
THAN PREVENTING THEIR
INVOLVEMENT IN THE JUSTICE
SYSTEM AS JJ CPA INTENDS.
IN SOME CASES AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JONES SAWYER MENTIONED COUNTIES
ARE FAILING TO DISTRIBUTE FUNDS
EFFECTIVELY LEAVING MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS AND SPENT INSTEAD OF
SUPPORTING YOUTH IN THE
COMMUNITY.
TODAY YOUR CONSTITUENTS AND
FELLOW LEGISLATORS SURE DEEP
CONCERNS ABOUT THE ILL SPENDING
UNDER UTILIZATION AND POOR
EVALUATION OF THE JJ CPA. TO
PROMOTE HEALTHY AND SAFE
COMMUNITIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA A
STATE AUDIT IS LONG OVERDUE AND
MUCH NEEDED.
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR APPROVAL OF THIS AUDIT
REQUEST THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND I BELIEVE MISTER
JONES SAWYER MENTIONED THIS HAS
BEEN LOOKED AT FOR OVER TWO
DECADES.
CORRECT RIGHT WITH THAT WE'RE
GONNA GO AHEAD AND MOVE TO THE
STATE AUDITOR'S PRESENTATION.
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS AS
AS ASSEMBLYMEMBER JONES SAWYER
INDICATED THIS WOULD BE AN AUDIT
OF THE J. C. PA -- THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE CRIME PREVENTION ACT P.
SPECIFICALLY IDENTIFIED COUNTIES
THAT HE WOULD LIKE US TO TO
VISIT AND REVIEW THOSE COUNTIES
ARE KERN LOS ANGELES MENDOCINO
SAN JOAQUIN AND SANTA BARBARA.
AND THERE'S A VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT OBJECTIVES THAT HE'S
ASKED US TO ACCOMPLISH I'M GONNA
TRY.
TO ADDRESS THOSE AT A FAIRLY
HIGH LEVEL -- BUT WE WILL DRILL
DOWN TO ALT SO THE FIRST FIRST.
A GROUP OF OBJECTIVES ARE
QUESTIONS IS RELATED TO THE
PROCESS FOR SOLICITING
APPLICATIONS AWARDING FUNDS
ALLOCATING FUNDS HOW ARE THEY
GOING ON THESE RESPECTIVE
COUNTIES GOING ABOUT DOING THAT
ARE THERE DIFFERENCES IN.
THE CONTRACTS THAT ARE OR THE
AWARDS THAT ARE ARE PROVIDED
WITHIN THOSE RESPECTIVE COUNTIES.
THERE'S A SERIES OF QUESTIONS
RELATED TO UP A PLAN THERE EACH --
COUNTY IS SUPPOSED TO PREPARE A
COMPREHENSIVE MULTI AGENCY OUR
JUVENILE JUSTICE PLANNED SO HE'S
ASKING US TO LOOK AT THOSE PLANS
HAVE THEY BEEN REVISED.
OUR IS IT COMPLYING WITH US
CERTAIN STATUTORY REQUIREMENTS
ARE THEIR MEASURABLE OF
PERFORMANCE METRICS IN THOSE
PLANS HOW ARE THEY MONITORING
THE ACCOMPLISHMENT OF THOSE
METRICS IN THE PLANTS.
CERTAINLY ASKING US TO LOOK FOR
ANY UNSPENT FUNDS A FIVE YEAR --
WINDOW FIVE FISCAL YEARS
THIRTEEN FOURTEEN THROUGH
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN TO DETERMINE
IF THERE'S ANY ON SPENT MONEY AT
EACH OF THOSE PARTICULAR
COUNTIES.
EACH COUNTIES RESPONSIBLE FOR
HAVING A COUNCIL OF THAT WILL IS
INVOLVED IN SOME OF THIS
DECISION MAKING A JUVENILE
JUSTICE COORDINATING COUNCIL
HE'S ASKED US TO LOOK AT THE
MEMBERSHIP OF THAT COUNCIL THE
AUTHORITY AND RESPONSIBILITY.
IS THE EACH INDIVIDUAL MEMBER OF
THAT COUNCIL HAVE EQUAL OUR
RESPONSIBILITY AND AUTHORITY.
HOW OFTEN DO THEY MEET OUR SOME
OF THE DISCUSSIONS RELATED TO
HOW THEY MAKE THEIR DECISIONS --
HAVE THEY DEVELOPED BY LAWS
PROTOCOLS IT CETERA SO LOOKING
AT THAT COUNCIL HE'S ASKING US
TO IDENTIFY DATA.
WITH RESPECT TO ALLOCATION OF
MONEY -- COUNTIES PROCESSES FOR
AGAIN MONITORING THOSE THOSE
PARTICULAR FUNDS AND THEN A
VARIETY OF OF INFORMATION AGAIN
OVER THAT FIVE YEAR WINDOW HOW
MUCH WAS THE BUDGET HOW MUCH WAS
EXPANDED.
HOW MUCH OF THAT WENT TO PAY FOR
PROBATION -- SALARIES OR OTHER
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT OR NON LAW
ENFORCEMENT A SALARY SO A
VARIETY OF DIFFERENT THINGS ARE
IN THAT PARTICULAR OBJECTIVE --
THE PERCENTAGE OF COUNTY
PROBATION DEPARTMENTS THAT ARE
SUPPORTED WITH THESE FUNDS NOT
JUST THE SALARIES BUT THE PER
NATION DEPARTMENT AS A WHOLE --
ALSO TRYING TO LOOK AT ISSUES
RELATED TO AT RISK YOUTH THE
DOLLAR AMOUNT PERCENTAGE OF
COUNTY EXPENDITURES THAT ARE.
REALLY USED FOR ADDRESSING AT
RISK YOUTH AND PROVIDING
SERVICES FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHAT'S THEIR DEFINITION OF AT
RISK YOUTH DOES IT DIFFER FROM
ONE COUNTY TO ANOTHER -- ASKING
US TO TO DEVELOP SOME
DEMOGRAPHIC INFORMATION OVER A
FIVE YEAR WINDOW WITH RESPECT TO
THOSE INDIVIDUALS AT THE YOUTH
THAT ARE BEING SERVED BY THIS
PARTICULAR PROGRAM.
ON THERE WERE SOME SPECIFIC
WELFARE AN INSTITUTION CODE
SECTIONS THAT -- MISTER JONES
SAWYER WANTED TO MAKE SURE WE
LOOKED AT AND DETERMINE WHETHER
OR NOT THESE THESE FUNDS ARE
BEING USED FOR THOSE PARTICULAR
PURPOSES IN THE OUT WELFARE
INSTITUTIONS CODE.
IN REFERRING TO THE BOARD OF
STATE COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS
ASKING US TO LOOK AT THEIR
PROCESSES -- FOR ENSURING THAT
COUNTIES ARE COMPLYING AND AND
FOLLOWING STATUTORY REQUIREMENTS
AND SIMILAR OBJECTIVE TOWARD ARE
REFERRING TO AS FAR AS GETTING.
INFORMATION WANTING US TO TRY TO
CAPTURE SOME STATEWIDE
INFORMATION RELATED TO
EXPENDITURES -- BUDGETS
EXPENDITURES HOW MUCH SPENT ON
PROBATION DEPARTMENTS STATEWIDE
WE CERTAINLY WILL DRILL DOWN AT
THOSE FIVE COUNTY SEE IDENTIFIED
BUT ASKING US TO TRY TO CAPTURE.
THROUGH THE BOARD OF STATE
COMMITTEE CORRECTIONS STATEWIDE
INFORMATION SO I WON'T GO
THROUGH THE LAUNDRY LIST BECAUSE
I JUST LAID THOSE OUT FOR YOU
FOR THEIR SPECIFIC COUNTIES.
AND THEN THE LAST ISSUE IS HOW
MANY OF THE COUNTY STATEWIDE ARE
REPORTING USING JJ CPA FUNDS --
FOR PURPOSES SPECIFIED IN THE
WELL FOR AN INSTITUTION CODES --
THAT HE IDENTIFIED IN HIS
REQUEST AND WE WILL CERTAINLY
LOOK TO TO DETERMINE IF THERE
ARE OTHER.
CODE SECTIONS OR OTHER STATUTORY
REQUIREMENTS THAT DOC COUNTIES
NEED TO BE FOLLOWING -- SO A
VARIETY OF DIFFERENT OBJECTIVES
ARE THIRTY THREE HUNDRED HOURS
TAKE US ABOUT EIGHT MONTHS TO
GET DONE BUT AGAIN BECAUSE WE'RE
NOT ONLY LOOKING AT STATE LEAD
RESPONSIVE AGENCY
RESPONSIBILITIES THOSE FIVE
COUNTIES.
AND THEN THE BOARD OF STATE
COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS.
THANK YOU MADAM AUDITOR FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION AT THIS TIME LET'S
GO TO MOVE TO THE AFFECTED
AGENCIES.
PLEASE THEY COME TO THE TABLE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU IF WE CAN --
HAVE YOU FIRST START BY STATING
YOUR NAME AND AFFILIATION WITH
WHAT'S AGENCY AND BEGIN WITH
YOUR TESTIMONY GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I'M KATIE HOWARD THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE BOARD
OF STATE AND COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONS.
I JUST WANT A BRIGHT PROVIDE
SOME ADDITIONAL BACKGROUND TODAY --
IN ADDITION TO WHAT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JONES SAWYER HAS
REQUESTED AND WHAT THE STATE
AUDITOR HAS REFERENCED ON THE
ISSUE OF STATEWIDE AND LOCALLY
AVAILABLE DATA ON JUVENILE
JUSTICE.
ISSUES ACROSS THE BOARD HAS BEEN
SOMETHING THAT HAD QUITE A BIT
OF ATTENTION IN THE LEGISLATURE --
IN THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS BACK
IN THE BUDGET ACT OF TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN IN A TRAILER
BILL THERE WAS A JUVENILE
JUSTICE DATA WORKING GROUP PUT
TOGETHER WE ACTUALLY HAVE A
REALLY HELPFUL REPORT WHICH WERE.
HAPPY TO PROVIDE THAT REFLECTS --
SOME OF THE LIMITATIONS IN THE
AVAILABLE DATA IN THE AVAILABLE
STATE WIDE DATA SYSTEMS FOR
THESE KINDS OF DATA.
AND I WILL JUST SAY THAT -- AS A
RESULT OF ALL A WHOLE LOT OF
WORK AND REVIEW AND ANALYSIS
THAT WENT ON ABOUT WAS AVAILABLE
WHAT WAS AVAILABLE AT THE TIME
AND IN A SECOND DELIVERABLE.
FROM THIS SAME WORKING GROUP
ABOUT WHAT A POSSIBLE FUTURE
JUVENILE JUSTICE STATEWIDE DATA
SYSTEM MIGHT LOOK LIKE.
THERE WERE COMPROMISES MADE.
AND A LOT OF DISCUSSIONS BETWEEN
ADVOCATES AND COUNTIES AND THE
STATE ABOUT HOW THE JJ DATA
PARTICULARLY TO THE JJ CPA AND
WHILE BG.
COULD BE STATS THAT YOUTH --
YOUTHFUL OFFENDER BLOCK GRANTS
WHICH IS ANOTHER RELATED GRANT
HERE -- AND EVEN THOUGH WE SAY
GRANTS OFTENTIMES PEOPLE THINK
OF THOSE AS COMPETITIVE GRANT
PROGRAMS THESE THESE ARE
ALLOCATED OUT TO THE COUNTIES BY
FORMULA.
SO ANYHOW WHAT THE MAIN POINT
THAT I WANT TO SAY HERE TODAY IS
THAT -- THERE WERE NEW --
PORTING REQUIREMENTS AGREED TO
AND CODIFIED IN AB NINETEEN
NINETY EIGHT OF TWO THOUSAND AND
SIXTEEN THAT RELIED ON THE
AVAILABLE STATEWIDE DATA SOURCES
AND THAT ARE ADMITTEDLY LIMITED
THERE'S QUITE A BIT OF DATA THAT
WE'RE OF COURSE HAPPY TO PROVIDE
TO THE AUDITOR ON STATEWIDE
EXPENDITURES -- BY PROGRAM
WHAT'S FUNDED IN J. J. C. P. A.
AND WHY WILL BE G. BUT THE LEVEL
OF DETAIL ABOUT THE NUMBER OF
YOUTH SERVED IN THOSE PROGRAMS
ISN'T AVAILABLE THE ISSUE OF
OUTCOME MEASURES IS PARTICULARLY --
PROBLEMATIC AND I THINK JUST THE
BOTTOM LINE POINT THAT I WANT TO
MAKE TODAY IS THAT THERE'S A
REAL AWARENESS -- FROM THE
COUNTIES AND THE STATE THAT
BECAUSE OF THESE FUNDS BEING
PROTECTED BY PROPOSITION THIRTY
IF THERE ARE ADDITIONAL DATA
REQUIREMENTS PUT ON TO THE
COUNTIES.
THE STATE HAS TO PAY FOR THOSE
AND THAT IS JUST REALLY QUITE
FRANKLY BEEN A BIG ISSUE HERE SO --
WE'RE MORE THAN HAPPY TO SHARE
ALL THE INFORMATION THAT WE HAVE
WE DO GET THE REPORTS BACK FROM
THE COUNTIES -- QUITE
CONSISTENTLY ON HOW THEY'RE
SPENDING THOSE FUNDS BUT IT
SEEMS LIKE THE SPIRIT OF MISTER
JONES MISTER JONES SERVICE
REQUEST IS TO HAVE MORE
INFORMATION ABOUT OUTCOMES WHICH
I'M JUST GOING TO SAY.
ARE NOT COLLECTED.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL TESTS.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAMES STEPHANIE JAMES I'M THE
CHIEF PROBATION OFFICER SAN
JOAQUIN COUNTY.
AND I ALSO HAVE THE PLEASURE OF
SERVING AS THIS YEAR'S PRESIDENT
FOR THE CHEAP PROVISIONAL SERVES
THE CALIFORNIA.
I WHEN THE CRIME PREVENTION ACT
OF TWO THOUSAND WAS PASSED
RESOURCES BORN FUSED INTO COUNTY
PROBATION DEPARTMENTS FOR
REDUCING DELINQUENCY IN
ADDRESSING JUVENILE CRIME
THROUGH QUOTE PREVENTION
INTERVENTION SUPPRESSION.
AND INCAPACITATION.
USING THESE RESOURCES AND WITH
THE SUPPORT APPROVAL OF THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE COORDINATING
COUNCILS MANY EARLY INTERVENTION
AND PREVENTION PROGRAMS AS WELL
AS ENHANCE PROVISIONS SERVICES.
HAVE BEEN PUT INTO PLACE THAT
HAVE BEEN VERY SUCCESSFUL.
OUR EFFORTS STATEWIDE IN THIS
AREA -- CLEAR AS THE RESULTS TO
THE JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM HAVE
BEEN ASTONISHING IN THE PAST TEN
YEARS THERE HAVE BEEN A 73%
REDUCTION IN JUVENILE ARRESTS.
67% OF A REST STATEWIDE HAVE
BEEN DIVERTED BY PROBATION
DEPARTMENTS.
THERE'S BEEN A 60% DECLINE IN
YOUTH DETENTION RATES A 74%
DECREASE IN DJJ POPULATIONS.
AND 90% OF OUR YOUTH ARE SO IN
THE JUSTICE SYSTEM OR SERVER
SAFELY IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
THIS IS BEEN ACCOMPLISHED BY
USING VALIDATED RISK ASSESSMENTS
DIVERTING LOW LEVEL YOUTH FROM
THE JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM.
TARGETING HIGHER RISK YOUTH WITH
THERAPEUTIC INTERVENTIONS AND
PROVIDING TARGETED INTERVENTIONS
THAT ADDRESS OUR USE NEED TO
HELP THEM ONTO A HEALTHY PATHWAY.
THE PURPOSE OF NOT ACCOMPLISH
THIS WORK ALONE.
AS THE LYNCH PIN IN THE JUSTICE
SYSTEM WE HAVE WORKED IN
COLLABORATION WITH OUR PUBLIC
AGENCY PARTNERS.
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH HUMAN SERVICES
SCHOOLS LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS AS WELL AS
OUR FAITH BASED AND COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS.
JJ CPA FUNDING IS JUST ONE SMALL
PIECE OF FINDING INFORMATION
APARTMENT.
THERE ARE MANY OTHER LOCAL STATE
FEDERAL FUNDING STREAMS AS WELL
AS BOTH PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
GRANTS.
THAT ARE USED TO PROVIDE
SERVICES TO YOUTH AS WELL AS TO
PARTNER WITH OTHER AGENCIES.
DEPARTMENT STAFF ARE HIGHLY
TRAINED IN NUMEROUS EVIDENCE
BASED INTERVENTIONS AND PROVIDE
MANY DIRECT SERVICES TO OUR
CLIENTS.
THESE SERVICES ARE BASED OUR
RESEARCH AND OF IMPROVING TO BE
EFFECTIVE WE DELIVER THEM WITH
THE FACT IF THANK AFFECT HIS MY
CATS AT WORD WITH EFFECTIVENESS
AND ARE ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE
RESULTS.
ASIAN CHIEFS ARE COMMITTED TO
SERVING AT RISK YOUTH IN OUR
COMMUNITY.
BY PROVIDING THEM WITH SERVICES
TO ADDRESS THEIR NEEDS AND TO
PREVENT THEM FROM COMING WITHIN
THE JUSTICE SYSTEM.
I IN AS YOU WILL HEAR IN A FEW
MORE MINUTES THE CHEAPER
BASENESS OFFICERS OF
CALIFORNIANS NOT BELIEVE THAT
THE CURRENT SCOPE OF THIS AUDIT
REQUEST WILL TELL THE FULL
NARRATIVE OF OUR WORK.
THE OUTCOMES THAT HAVE BEEN
ACHIEVED AND THE PARTNERSHIP.
PARTNERSHIPS THAT HAVE BEEN
DEVELOPED AND SUSTAINED.
THAT HAVE MADE THIS WORK
SUCCESSFUL I BELIEVE IN MAKING
DATA DRIVEN DECISIONS AND DO NOT
BELIEVE THE ART IN ITS CURRENT
FORM IS GOING TO PROVIDE THE
OUTCOME DATA NECESSARY. TO
ENHANCE THE SERVICES PROVIDED TO
THE U..
SO I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT
THIS AUDIT REQUEST BE EXPANDED
AND REVISED TO INCLUDE OUTCOMES
RELATED TO THE PROGRAMS THAT ARE
BEING FUNDED.
AS WELL AS LOOK AT THE VAST
ARRAY OF SERVICES THAT ARE BEING
PROVIDED TO YOUTH IN OUR
COMMUNITIES THERE ARE OTHER
FUNDING STREAMS AS WELL.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY
YES HI -- GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS HI MY NAME
IS A SHEILA MITCHELL ON THE
CHIEF DEPUTY PREVENTION OFFICER
FOR A LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF CHIEF
MCDONNELL SINCE OUR ARRIVAL IN
JANUARY OF TWO THOUSAND AND
SEVENTEEN TO DO CPA HAS BEEN A
KEY PRIORITY FOR US.
I CHEER THE JUVENILE JUSTICE
CORN IN COUNCIL ON BEHALF OF THE
CHIEF I JUST WANTED TO GIVE YOU
A GLIMPSE IN TERMS OF SOME OF
THE THINGS THAT WE'VE BEEN DOING
FOR THE PAST COUPLE OF YEARS.
ONE WE HAVE -- THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE CORNING COUNCIL IS NOW A
TWENTY EIGHT MEMBER BODY.
WHICH IS COMPRISED OF TEN
COMMUNITY MEMBERS AS WELL AS
COUNTY DEPARTMENTS AS WELL AS
THE OFFICE OF YOU FOR DEVOTION
AND DEVELOPMENT.
AND OTHER -- STAKEHOLDERS THAT
WAS SOMETHING THAT WAS PUT IN
PLACE IN TWO THOUSAND AND
SEVENTEEN I'M ALSO IN MARCH OF
TWO THOUSAND AND SEVENTEEN OF
THE JUVENILE JUSTICE CLINIC
COUNCIL COMMISSIONED A NEW
ADVISORY COUNCIL.
AND THIS IS THE COMMUNITY
ADVISORY COUNCIL THAT IS CHAIRED
BY A NONPROFIT JOSH GREEN WITH
URBAN PIECE.
AND IT IS A WAY TO SOLICIT INPUT
FROM THE COMMUNITY THAT HELPS
INFORM THE PLAN.
IN NOVEMBER TWO THOUSAND AND
SEVENTEEN WE APPROVED OR GROW
FUNDS IN WHICH 81% OF ALL OF OUR
ROLE FUNDS WENT TO COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS.
THE MANY OF THOSE WENT TO COUNTY
GOVERNMENT.
IN JANUARY TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHTEEN WITH OUR NEW OFFICE OF
YOU TO VERSION IN DEVELOPMENT.
THE J. J. C. C. APPROVED TWELVE
MILLION DOLLARS TO GO AND THAT
IS REALLY ABOUT DEVOTING KIDS
FROM THE JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM.
IN MARCH OF TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHTEEN WE COMMISSIONED A NEW
ON COMMITTEE AND THIS COMMITTEE
WAS CHARGE WOULD REVAMPING OUR
PLAN.
I'M A PLAN HAD NOT BEEN REVISED
IN ITS TOTALITY IT WAS TO
REIMAGINE WITH THAT PLAN COULD
LOOK LIKE AN OMINOUS HAVE BEEN
REVISED -- IN FIFTEEN YEARS IT
WAS DONE SO ON THROUGH
200-018-2000 NINETEEN AND IT WAS
CHAIRED IT WAS A TASK FORCE OF
ABOUT TWELVE PEOPLE IT WAS
CHAIRED BY -- PETITIONS SONG
WITH THE CHILDREN'S DEFENSE FUND
AND ONE OF OUR FELLOWS THAT THAT
WE HAVE AND THE PROBATION
DEPARTMENT.
I THINK EARLY AS SOMEONE
MENTIONED ON ONE OF THE SPEAKERS
ABOUT VOLUNTARY PROBATION --
THAT WAS SOMETHING THAT WE
DISCONTINUED AND TWO THOUSAND
AND EIGHTEEN YOU KNOW IS A VERY
DIFFICULT DECISION BECAUSE WHY
WE WERE DOING VOLUNTARY
PUBLICATION WITHIN THE SCHOOLS.
IT WAS SOMETHING THAT THE
SCHOOLS REALLY ASKED US TO DO
AND THAT WE WERE DOING GOOD WORK
AT HOWEVER PHILOSOPHICALLY IT
WAS NOT SOMETHING THAT I WAS IN
LINE WITH US DOING.
AND SO WHAT WE DID IN ITS STEAD
AS WE STEPPED OUT OF DOING
VOLUNTARY PROBATION WE REALLY
WORK WITH SOME OTHER NON PROFITS
TO HELP MOVE INTO THE SCHOOLS TO
TAKE.
THAT WORK WE ESTABLISHED IN TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN IT WAS
APPROVED BY A BOARD IN TWO
THOUSAND AND NINETEEN SOMETHING
THAT IS VERY INNOVATIVE IT'S
CALLED A PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIPS.
ANYONE KNOWS THAT WHEN YOU
WORKING COUNTY GOVERNMENT BY THE
TIME YOU CONCEIVE OF AN IDEA --
IN TERMS OF A REQUEST FOR
PROPOSAL SOMETIMES IT TAKES A
YEAR TO GET THOSE FUNDS OUT.
THEN SO THIS PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIP THAT WE HAVE IN
CONJUNCTION WITH TO FOUNDATIONS.
IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY IS WITH
LIBERTY HEALTH FOUNDATION AND
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
FOUNDATION ONE IS TO DO WE
GRANTING WE MOVED FROM GETTING
I'VE FUNDS OUT FROM A PERIOD OF
ONE AND A HALF YEARS. TO A
PERIOD OF THREE TO FOUR MONTHS
AND THEN THE OTHER FOUNDATION IS
LIBERTY HILL AND THEY DO
CAPACITY BUILDING FOR US.
ON TO OTHER POINTS WE REALLY
REMAIN ON INFORMED OUR MISSION
STATEMENT GUIDING PRINCIPLES FOR
JGTC OR FUNDS -- MIRA.
OUR MISSION VISION IN FACT A
200-019-2000 AND TWENTY PLAN 87%
OF ALL OF OUR FUNDS FROM THIS --
FUNDING SOURCE GOES TO COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS WITH 13%
GOING TO COUNTY GOVERNMENT.
WE HAVE NO UNALLOCATED FUNDS AT
THIS POINT I KNOW THAT WAS NOT
THE THE THE PLACE WE WERE AT TO
WHEN WE ARRIVED IN TWO THOUSAND
AND SEVENTEEN A PLAN -- IS A
COLLABORATIVE PLAN DEVELOP WITH
A COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS A PLAN IS
AVAILABLE TO THE PUBLIC IT IS ON
A WEBSITE WE MEET REGULARLY.
AND THAT IS MY TESTIMONY IF I
CAN ASK IF THERE'S ANOTHER
AFFECTED AGENCY IF SOMEONE CAN
PROVIDE.
THEM AN OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT
THEIR TESTIMONY AS WELL.
YOU CAN BE CONCISE WE'D
APPRECIATE THAT.
ABSOLUTELY AFTERNOON CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M TANIA
HEITMANN CHIEF PROBATION OFFICER
FOR SANTA BARBARA COUNTY I JUST
WANT TO SHARE THAT WE WELCOME
THE OPPORTUNITY TO REVIEW THE
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES PROVIDED
TO THE YOUTH IN SANTA BARBARA
COUNTY.
IN THE LAST TWO YEARS WE
UNDERTOOK A DEEP DIVE INTO OUR
LOCAL LOCAL JUVENILE DATA.
ALTHOUGH IT WASN'T FOCUS
SPECIFICALLY ON JJ CPA -- WE ARE
CURRENTLY IMPLEMENTING
SUBSTANTIAL CHANGES TO OUR
OVERALL SYSTEM AS A RESULT OF
WHAT WE LEARNED.
AS SUCH WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE THE
AUDIT EXTENDED INTO FISCAL YEARS
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN AND NINETEEN
TWENTY WE WOULD ALSO SUGGESTED
FOR THE REVIEW OF THE SCOPE TO
ENSURE IT PROVIDES A FULL
PICTURE OF HOW THESE FUNDS ARE
UTILIZED.
AS WELL AS THE LOCAL CHALLENGES
AND NEEDS BEING ADDRESSED WE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR INTEREST IN
OUR WORK.
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT I BELIEVE THAT'S ALL
THE AFFECTED AGENCIES AT THIS
TIME WE'RE GOING TO GO AHEAD AND
MOVE -- BACK TO THE DYESS FOR
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS.
HEARING AND SEEING NONE LET ME
JUST ASK THE AUTHOR IF YOU'VE
LOOKED AT SOME OF THE TESTIMONY --
PROVIDED BY THE AFFECTED
AGENCIES WAS LOOKING AT MAYBE.
AN EXPANDED SCOPE OF THE
OUTCOMES IN THE SERVICES BEING
PROVIDED IS THAT SOMETHING YOU
LOOKED AT AND THE ULTIMATE
DECISION AND WHAT THAT ACTUALLY
WOULD BE FOR THE OUTER.
YEAH AND I'M NOT SUREIF THIS IS
MORE FOR THE AUDITOR'S BECAUSE
IT TO IT'S REALLY A QUESTIN OF
COSTS AND I KNOW I'VE DONE OTHER
AUDITS BEFORE.
AND PART OF LIMITING IT WAS.
ACTUALLY THE THE BUDGET AND
STAFFING THAT THEY HAVE -- WE
WENT IN THIS DIRECTION ECAUSE
WE THOUGHT WE WOULD GET THE MOST
BANG FOR A BUCK AND TO BE ABLE
TO GET THE INFORMATION WE WANTED
SO I I'M NOT TRYING.
TO AVOID YOUR QUESTION BUT
CORRECT.
IF IF FOR FOR MY PERSPECTIVE IF
WE HAVE THE RESOURCES WE HAVE TO
STAFF ANY RESOURCES WE SHOULD DO
IT.
AND THE FUNDING TO DO IT -- BUT
I DON'T WANT TO COMPROMISE THE
ENTIRE AUDIT BECAUSE WE WE OVER
DO NO WORRIES SO.
SO MISTER CHAIRMAN ONE OF THE
ONE OF THE COMMENTS WAS AS FAR
AS LOOKING AT THE EFFECTIVENESS
OF THESE PROGRAMS AND HOW AND I
THERE WERE.
WARS INFORMATION PROVIDED AS FAR
AS THE NUMBER OF YOUTH -- WHO
ARE NO LONGER ENGAGED IN AT LAW
ENFORCEMENT PROCESS THERE THERE
ACTUALLY IS AN OBJECTIVE?
IN THE IN THE AUDIT REQUEST AND
IN OUR ANALYSIS THAT ASKS US TO
DETERMINE HOW EFFECTIVE THESE
PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN AND REDUCING
INTERACTIONS.
BETWEEN YOUTH IN THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM SO I THINK WE
WOULD BE ABLE TO GET AT THAT
PARTICULAR COMMENT WITH THE
EXISTING SCOPE -- THAT WE HAVE
DEVELOPED AS FAR AS EXPANDING
THE NUMBER OF YEARS WE'RE
LOOKING AT WE'RE ALREADY LOOKING
AT FIVE FISCAL YEARS -- WITH ALL
DUE RESPECT TO SOME OF THE THE
COMMENTS MADE LOOKING AT
NINETEEN TWENTY I MEAN IT'S NOT
EVEN NINETEEN TWENTY YET IT WILL
BE SOON -- BUT I THINK.
THE THE OBJECTIVES THAT MISTER
JONES SAWYER HAS ASKED US TO
ACCOMPLISH LOOKING AT A FIVE
YEAR WINDOWWILL IDENTIFY SOME
TRENDS -- SO.
IT WOULD BE A SCOPE MODIFICATION
THERE CERTAINLY RULES RELATED TO
THE COMMITTEE IT WOULD BE AN
EXPANSION OF THE AUDIT.
ALSO I WOULD HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT
THAT I DO THINK THERE'S A LOT OF
INFORMATION THAT -- MISTER JONES
SAWYER IS ASKING US TO CAPTURE
AND I DO THINK WE WILL BE ABLE
TO GET AT SOME OF THE
DEMOGRAPHICS HOPEFULLY AT LEAST
IT AT THE SPECIFIC COUNTIES
MAYBE NOT IT IS STATEWIDE BASIS
BASED ON SOME OF THE COMMENTS
MADE -- BUT CERTAINLY WE WILL BE.
HOPING TO LOOK AT I'M SOME OF
THE REDUCTIONS THERE IS THAT
SPECIFIC OBJECTIVE AS FAR AS THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF OF MANY OF
THESE PROGRAMS THAT HAVE BEEN
FUNDED BY THIS ACT.
UNDER THE PARAMETERS OF THE
AUDIT WE WILL BE ABLE TO ANSWER
SOME OF THESE QUESTIONS AS TO
THE EFFECTIVENESS AND THE
OUTCOMES AS WELL WE WERE HOPING.
TO THANK YOU ALL RIGHT WITH THAT
LET'S GO TO MOVE TO PUBLIC
COMMENT TO HAVE PUBLIC COMMENT
ON THIS ITEM.
WE DO IF YOU COULD PLEASE STATE
YOUR NAME AND AFFILIATION IF YOU
WERE ARE WITH THE GROUP OR WHICH
COUNTY YOU LIVE IN.
PLEASE PROCEED.
AND IF YOU CAN MAKE YOUR
COMMENTS CONCISE IN UNDER TWO
MINUTES PLEASE I GET AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS DOMINIQUE YOUNG FOR
THE CHILDREN'S DEFENSE FUND
CALIFORNIA I JUST WANT TO
PROVIDE SOME ADDITIONAL
PERSPECTIVE FROM LA COUNTY ABOUT
THE NEED FOR THE STATE RIGHT
AUDIT.
AS SHEET METAL SAID THERE ARE A
LOT IMPROVEMENTS THAT HAVE
HAPPENED SINCE TWENTY SEVENTEEN
BUT THOSE ARE MAINLY PROPELLED
BY DISTURBING FINDINGS BY
ADVOCATES IN TWENTY SIXTEEN THAT
WERE NOT INCLUDED IN THE AUDIT.
AND THOUGH IT'S MAINLY INCLUDED
ONE I'M AN ADMISSION BY THE RAND
CORPORATION WHO IS THE LEAD
RESEARCHER SINCE TWO THOUSAND
AND ONE FOR LA COUNTY.
HE SAID THAT THERE WAS NO
EVIDENCE IN THE YEARS PRIOR IN
THE FIFTEEN YEARS TO SHOW THAT
ANY OF THE CHICKIES CPA FUNDED
PROGRAMS WERE EFFECTIVE AT
REDUCING RECIDIVISM OR IMPROVING
YOUTH OUTCOMES.
AND SECOND THEY GET REGARDING
VOLUNTARY PROBATION THAT I'VE
GONE TO THE POINT WHERE IN
TWENTY FOURTEEN TO TWENTY
FIFTEEN MORE THAN HALF
APPROPRIATIONS CASELOAD WERE
ACTUALLY YOUTH WHO HAD NEVER
BEEN ARRESTED.
AND BASED ON THIS INFORMATION I
JUST WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THAT
THERE IS A REAL NEED FOR
STATEWIDE AUDIT FOR OVERSIGHT
ACCOUNTABILITY AND IMPROVEMENTS
BECAUSE WHAT TYPE OF ADVOCACY
CANNOT AND SHOULD NOT NEED TO BE
REPLICATED ACROSS THE STATE.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS MICHAEL AND DOES AND
ON THE POLICY DIRECTOR FOR THE
ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION.
A WIN ORGANIZATION THAT IS
COMPRISED OF IN SERVICE FORMALLY
COSTS FOR INDIVIDUALS THROUGHOUT
THE ENTIRE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND THEY'RE AND MANY DIFFERENT
COUNTIES -- I LIVE IN SACRAMENTO
COUNTY AND IN MANY DIFFERENT
COUNTIES THESE INDIVIDUALS NEED
SERVICES.
IT'S BEEN OVER CLOSE TO TWENTY
YEARS -- SINCE WE'VE HAD NOT ON
THIS AND I THINK THIS IS THE
RIGHT TIME SEEN THAT WE'VE SEEN.
DECLINES IN YOU THE REST AND
MORE DIVERSION FOR THIS
POPULATION SO -- WE NEED SERVICE
IN OUR COMMUNITIES AND I THINK
THIS IS A GREAT TIME TO HAVE
THIS AUDIT DONE -- MAN WITH THIS
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU.
DOES ANYONE CAME WITHIN WITH THE
ALLIANCE FOR BOYS AND MEN OF
COLOR AT POLICY LINK FIRST WE
WANT TO THANK THE CHAMPION OF
THIS WE THINK SOMEONE NUMBER
JONES SAWYER -- AND THE
ALLIANCES MADE UP OF A NETWORK
OF OVER TWO HUNDRED PLUS
PARTNERS THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA -- I CURRENTLY RESIDE
IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY HOWEVER OUR
COMMUNITY MEMBERS AND COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS ARE LARGELY
BEING LEFT OUT OF THE DECISION
MAKING PROCESS FOR HOW THE JJ
CPA FUNDS ARE BEING SPENT.
WITH POOR TRANSPARENCY IN
REPORTING THE COMMUNITIES THAT
WE SERVE HAVE BEEN UNABLE TO
FIND OUT ON THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
JJ CPA FUNDED PROGRAMS WITHOUT
THE STATE AUDITOR'S SUPPORT.
SOME COUNTIES ARE FUNDING
HARMFUL PROGRAMS LIKE VOLUNTARY
PROBATION WHICH SUBJECT YOUTH
WITH NOT COMMITTED A CRIME TO
RESTRICTIVE AN INVASIVE
PROBATION REQUIREMENTS.
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE TO LOOK INTO HOW THIS IS
AFFECTING COMMUNITIES LIKE THE
ONES THAT I SERVE AND BUT I LIVE
IN.
AND DECIDE IS GREATLY NEEDED
THANK YOU THANK YOU ADDITIONAL
PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE -- GOOD
AFTERNOON WHEN A STATUS MY NAME
IS ISRAEL VIA ON THE PROGRAM
POLICY COORDINATOR WITH ME BY
OUT IN SALINAS MONTEREY COUNTY --
WE ARE PROUD CALL SPONSORS OF
THIS REQUEST -- THIS AT THIS
STANDS NOW THESE RACES ARE NOT
BEING INVESTED IN EFFECTIVE DO
PROGRAMA SERVICES AS RECIDIVISM
ROOTS REMAIN VERY VERY HIGH.
VERY LITTLE LEASES ARE BEING
SHARED WITH CRUCIAL AND OFTEN
THE MOST EFFECTIVE STAKEHOLDERS
WHEN IT COMES TO NOT WORKING
WITH OUR CHILDREN BUT EMBRACING
HELPING ELEVEN THESE CHILDREN.
AND THAT BEING COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS.
OF FORTY SOME OF THESE FUNDS
HAVE BEEN USED TO FIND SOME TYPE
OF WANT TO PROBATION WHICH IS
ONE OF THE STRINGS CONCEPT I'VE
HEARD OF THE DECISION MAKING
PROCESS IS NOT EQUITABLE AGAIN.
ONE OF THE MOST IMPORTANT
STAKEHOLDERS IS LEFT OUT.
OR OR VERY MINIMAL INCLUSION
THAT'S ON ON MONDAY COUNTERS ONE
COMMUNITY SEAT -- SO AGAIN THIS
IS NOT EMBRACING OR A REFLECTIVE
OUR COMMUNITY COMMUNITY STAKE
HOLDERS COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS FORMING CARCERI IT
AND DIRECTLY IMPACTED FAMILIES
WHICH ARE VERY VERY IMPORTANT
STAKEHOLDERS AT WHAT MUCH TO
CONTRIBUTE TO THIS CONVERSATION --
WHERE DAD IS CONCERNED THERE
AGAIN THERE'S VERY VERY LIMITED
DATA VERY VERY LIMITED --
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS -- WE
HAVE CONCERNS OF HOW MUCH.
OF THESE RESOURCES ARE ARE BEING
USED THE GAME THE AS IT WAS
MENTIONED THERE IS NO NUMBERS TO
SEE HOW MANY YOUTH ARE BEING
HELPED -- BUT ONE THING THAT I
DID CLEARLY READ FROM THE B. S.
E. C.'S YEARLYCHECK THE CPA
REPORT IS THAT THE MAJORITY
THESE FUNDS ARE GOING. TO
SALARIES AND BENEFITS
SPECIFICALLY NOT TO OUR KIDS
WHICH IS VERY VERY ALARMING AND
DISHEARTENING -- I THINK WHAT'S
GOING ON IN LA IS EXACTLY WHEN
THIS HAPPENED ACROSS THE STATE
THEY INCLUDED MUCH MORE
COMMUNITY SEATS TO THEIR
JUVENILE JUSTICE COMMISSION
THEY'VE ALSO INCLUDE A COMMUNITY
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE WHICH IS
EXACTLY WHAT WE NEED IN OUR
COUNTY AND ACROSS THE STATE.
AND WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND
I WILL THANK YOU.
NO PUBLIC COMMENT [inaudible]
PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON BRIAN GOLDSTINE
WITH THE CENTER ON JUVENILE AND
CRIMINAL JUSTICE.
IN MAY TWENTY EIGHTEEN CJ CJ
RELEASED A REPORT LOOKING AT
FIVE BAY AREA COUNTIES AND HOW
THEY USE.
J. C. K. FUNDING AND OUR
FINDINGS WEREALARMING.
WE FOUND THAT 75% OF THE FUNDING
WAS GOING -- TO COUNTY SALARIES
AND A SMALL PORTION OF IT WAS
GOING TO COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS.
WE ALSO FOUND THAT MILLIONS OF
FUNDING WAS UNSPENT WHEN WE WENT
OUT INTO THE COMMUNITY WHEN WE
WENT OUT INTO COUNTIES.
AND PRESENTED ON HER FINDINGS
WHAT WAS ALSO ALONG WITH THE
FACT THAT.
KEY JUVENILE JUSTICE
STAKEHOLDERS DOING THE WORK
EVERY DAY.
WE'RE NOT INVOLVED THEY WEREN'T
PART OF THIS COLLABORATION.
WE THINK THIS AUDIT IS ESSENTIAL
AND WE HOPE THAT YOU SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ADDITIONAL TO PUBLIC COMMENT
PLEASE.
A GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
LAURIE DELFI ON THE ODD POLICY
DIRECTOR AT THE W. HE WOULD
BURNS INSTITUTE WERE A NATIONAL
NONPROFIT BASED IN OAKLAND.
AND YOU WORK TO REDUCE RACIAL
NOTHING DISPARITIES IN THE
JUSTICE SYSTEM.
I'M HERE TODAY TO STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE JG CPA AUDIT -- AND
AND TWENTY FIFTEEN I SAT ON THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE STATUS --
WORKING GROUP THAT WAS MAKING
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR IMPROVEMENTS
ON DATA COLLECTION FOR JJ CPA
AND THE YOUTH CENTER BLOCK GRANT
PROGRAM I'M PLEASED THAT SOME OF
THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS WERE
BROUGHT TO WERE WERE -- MOVE
FORWARD BUT ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE LEARNED IN THAT IS ALSO
INCORPORATED IN THE REPORT IS
pTHAT THE JJ CPA OF BRICK.
REPORTING IS REALLY COMPLIANCE
MONITORING IT DOESN'T TALK A LOT
ABOUT WHAT THE IMPACT IS BOTH ON
THE YOUTH AND THEIR FURTHER
TRAJECTORY INTO THE JUSTICE
SYSTEM AND THAT SOMETHING WE
NEED TO NOW THIS IS A HUGE
INVESTMENT OF FUNDS.
THAT CAN IMPACT A HUGE NUMBER OF
CHILDREN IN THE STATE AND WE
NEED TO KNOW WHAT THE RETURN ON
THAT INVESTMENT IS -- AND WHAT
WE DON'T KNOW A LOT ABOUT WHAT'S
HAPPENING WITH THOSE FUNDS AND
pARE WE DO KNOW THAT THERE'S TENS
OF THOUSANDS OF KIDS WHO ARE
COMING INTO THE JUSTICE SYSTEM.
THAT DON'T NEED TO BE THERE THAT
HAVE LOW LEVEL OFFENSES
MISDEMEANOR IN STATUS OFFENSES
THAT DON'T NEED TO HAVE THEIR
PETITION FILED IN COURT. ONE
THING THAT I WOULD NOTE THOUGH
IS THAT IN THE C. POCK
OPPOSITION LETTER THERE'S
REFERENCE 267% OF YOU TWO ARE
REFERRED TO PROBATION BEING
DIVERTED OUT OF THE SYSTEM.
AND IF WE LOOK AT THE LATEST
DATA THAT'S AVAILABLE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
WHICH IS THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN
DATA OF THE APPROXIMATELY
SEVENTY ONE THOUSAND YOUTH WHO
WERE REFERRED TO PROBATION 53%
OF THEM HAD A FORMAL PETITION
FILED IN COURT. 5655% OF THOSE
YOUTH WERE USED WHO HAD
COMMITTED MISDEMEANOR STATUS
OFFENSES SO THERE'S A LARGE
SWATH OF YOUTH WE ARE NOT
REACHING CURRENTLY WITH JJ CPA
THAT WE NEED TO TOUCH.
AND THOSE NUMBERS ARE
DESPERATELY IMPACTING YOUTH OF
COLOR 44% OF WHITE YOUTH I REFER
WHO ARE REFERRED A PETITION DONE.
COMPARED 262% OF BLACK YOUTH AND
54% OF LATINO YOU THANK YOU
THANK YOU DESPITE ALL PUBLIC
COMMENT.
GOOD EVENING WHEN I STARTED IS
MY NAME IS JAMES MARTINEZ WITH
ME BY.
I AM A YOLO COUNTY CONSTITUENTS
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT THE JJ
CPA AUDIT -- AS I WAS HEARING
YOU KNOW I'M A BIG BELIEVER IN
CHANGE AND I UNDERSTAND THAT
ADVANCEMENT DEMANDS CHANGE AND I
THINK IT'S TIME FOR US NOW TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT.
WHAT WHAT'S HAPPENING THEN IS
NOT WORKING NOW?
AND WE CAN SEE THIS AS THE PROOF
IS IN THE PUDDING.
IN A LOT OF TIMES I THINK WE GET
CAUGHT UP ON WHAT WE WANT WITH
THE SELF BUT OFTEN WE FORGET
ABOUT OTHERS OUTSIDE OF
OURSELVES.
AND ONE THING I FOR THAT WE NEED
TO KEEP IN MIND HERE TODAY.
IS HOW THE PRACTICES ARE NOT
WORKING AND AS YOU CAN SEE HERE
HOW IT IT WAS MENTIONED IN THE
THE FUNDING IS.
IS BASICALLY BUT EVEN BEING PUT
TOWARDS.
SYSTEMS ARE BEING INEFFECTIVE.
AND IF SOMETHING'S BEING
INEFFECTIVE IN THE WATER WE
CONTINUE TO FUNNEL RESOURCES IN
AN AREA WHERE IT'S NOT BEING.
MEANINGFUL -- BEING SOMEONE WHO
WAS FORMALLY SYSTEM IMPACTED.
I'M I'M SPEAKING FROM EXPERIENCE
I'M NOT SPEAKING FROM WHAT I
READ I'M NOT SPEAKING FROM WHAT
I HEARD I'M SPEAKING FROM HANDS
ON EXPERIENCE AND I'M A BIG
BELIEVER.
THAT THOSE THAT ARE CLOSEST TO
THE PROBLEM OF THE ONES CLOSEST
TO THE SOLUTION AND THE SOLUTION
HERE TODAY IS THIS AUDIT TO
ENSURE THAT.
EVERYTHING IS GOING ACCORDINGLY
TO THE WISHES OF THE PEOPLE AND
JUST NOT THE WISHES OF A SELECT
GROUP THE IN GROUP.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ADDITIONAL PUBLIC COMMENT.
HELLO MY NAME IS CHRISTIAN
FRANCO AND I WORK REGIONALLY IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WORKING
WITH USE YOU FOR SYSTEM IMPACTED
JUST AS THE BALL.
ON JUVENILE HALL FROM SACRAMENTO
COUNTY YOLO COUNTY -- SOLANO
COUNTY AND ALSO AT THE STATE
LEVEL AT DJJ AS WELL AND SO MY
**** TODAY IS JUST THAT THIS
THIS AUDIT.
IS SUPPORTED -- TO ENSURE THAT
WE ARE INVESTING.
IN THE RIGHT AREAS RIGHT THAT
THE PROGRAMS THAT ARE MOST
EFFECTIVE -- IN REDUCING
RECIDIVISM AND DIVERT IN OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE -- ARE ALLOCATED
FOR RIGHT -- SO IT'S A IT'S A
GRAND OPPORTUNITY FOR US AS THE
STATE TO DO THIS I WORK WITH
THESE FOLKS EVERYDAY I ACTUALLY --
CANCEL MY BJJ -- PROGRAMMING
TODAY. FIFTY YOUTH THAT I REACH
AT THE STATE LEVEL TO COME HERE
AND ASK THAT YOU ARE SUPPORT
THIS AUDIT.
THANK YOU.
ADDITIONAL PUBLIC COMMENT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'D DANIEL SANCHEZ ON
BEHALF OF THE CHIEF PROBATION
OFFICERS OF CALIFORNIA REALLY
APPRECIATE BEING ABLE TO BE HERE
TODAY THIS IS A EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT -- TOPIC BOTH FOR US
AS WE KNOW IT IS FOR
ASSEMBLYMEMBER JONES SAWYER -- A
FEW COMMENTS THAT I WANT -- TO
KIND OF IN PART TO THIS
COMMITTEE IN AND HOPE THAT
YOU'LL CONSIDER GOING FORWARD --
GIGI CPA HAS BEEN A TRULY
TRANSFORMATIVE -- INVESTMENT IN
LOCAL SYSTEMS -- WHEN IT WAS
ENACTED THE FOCUS REALLY WAS ON --
TO INFUSE THE LOCAL SYSTEM AND
FOR A LOOK AT THE LOCAL
DEVELOPMENT OF A PLAN THAT MEETS
SENSE BASED ON THOSE NEEDS --
AND AND WHAT THE SERVICE --
REQUIREMENTS AND NEEDS WERE OF
THE LOCALITY -- THAT HAS LED TO
AND I THINK THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT POINT THAT WE DON'T
FORGET HAS LED TO HISTORIC
DECLINES IN BOTH ARREST AND
DETENTION -- DIVERSION IS A VERY
MUCH A FOCAL POINT OF PROBATION
AND SOMETHING THAT WE KNOW IS A
IS A GROWING FOCUS AND SO WHEN
WE LOOK AT THE SYSTEM THERE
SIGNIFICANT DATA TO SHOW THAT --
BOTH THE WITH WITH JJ CPA AND
OTHER FUNDING SOURCES THAT THERE
HAVE BEEN.
SIGNIFICANT ADVANCEMENTS THAT
CONTINUE TO BE MADE AND I I JUST
DON'T WANT THAT POINT TO BE LOST
AND THAT THIS IS IT GETTING TO
THE RIGHT EFFECTIVE APPROACHES --
WE CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND THAT IS
THAT IS THAT COMMITTEES DESIRE
TO TO LOOK AT THESE THINGS --
BUT WE'RE CONCERNED THAT THE WAY
THE SCOPE IS CURRENTLY DRAFTED
THAT IT MAY NOT CAPTURE ALL OF
THE PIECES THAT -- WE THINK BOTH
THE AUTHOR WOULD BE INTERESTED
IN THE LEGISLATURE BE INTERESTED
IN OR THAT REALLY PAINTS THE
FULL PICTURE -- OF THE TYPES OF
PROGRAMMING THAT IS HAPPENING SO
IF YOU THINGS I WOULD -- NOTE --
THE ANNUAL REPORT AS WE
MENTIONED THERE IS ANNUAL
REPORTING THAT IS HAPPENING --
AND SO WE THINK THAT THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT -- IS ALREADY IN
MANY WAYS CAPTURED WITHIN THAT
THE SCOPE OF THE AUDIT --
REGARDING THE TIMELINE IT DOES
MENTION -- UP UNTIL.
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN I THINK
INCLUDING EIGHTEEN NINETEEN IS
IMPORTANT SIGNIFICANT CHANGES
HAPPEN YEAR OVER YEAR AND SO NOT
HAVING THAT LAST YEAR IN THIS
COULD MISS SOME SOME VALUABLE
INSIGHTS -- THE REQUESTEDTHIS
IS ON ONE PARTICULAR FUNDING
SOURCES AND AS WE KNOW BECAUSE
THESE AREN'T FUSIONS AND A LOCAL
SYSTEM AND THERE'S BLENDING OF
SOURCES AND AND FIGURING OUT HOW
BEST TO A RE SOURCE THE LOCAL
COMMUNITIES.
THAT AGAIN IT MAY NOT PAY THE
FULL PICTURE FOR LOOKING AT ONE
SPECIFIC SOURCE FOR ONE SPECIFIC
PURPOSE -- THE ONE OTHER THING
WE WOULD ENCOURAGE JUST OUT
COMMITTEE IS TO LOOK AT OTHER
METRICS THAT MAY BE IMPORTANT.
ON THE PHONE THE FOCUS IN MANY
WAYS SEEMS TO BE ON WHERE THE
DOLLARS ARE GOING INTO TO WHICH
ENTITIES -- BUT THAT DOESN'T
NECESSARILY GET OUT QUALITY OF
SERVICES OUTCOMES FOR YOUTH AND
OTHER IMPORTANT FACTORS THAT WE
THINK AGAIN ARE PART OF MAKING
SURE WE'RE DOING.
THE RIGHT THINGS THAT WE ALL
WANT TO SEE HAPPENING INTHIS
REGARD -- AND THEN THOUGH THE
ONE OTHER POINT I WOULD SAY IS
THAT -- I THINK THERE'S BEEN A
DISCUSSION ON THIS BEING A GRANT
PROCESS WITH KIND OF
SOLICITATIONS AND AND GRANTEES
AGAIN THIS WAS NOT DESIGNS
NECESSARILY IN THAT FASHION THIS
WAS DESIGNED AS AS THAT HAS BEEN
DISCUSSED WITH THE LOCAL JJ CC.
ON TO DEVELOP THAT PLAN AND THEN
IMPLEMENT FROM THERE AND SO WE
THINK THAT'S AN IMPORTANT POINT
THAT SOME OF THE QUESTIONS MAY
NOT COMPLETELY COMPORT WITH I
THINK HOW -- THE PROGRAM WAS
DESIGNED IN AND DOLLARS ARE
FLOWING SO -- WITH THAT WE
APPRECIATE THE DISCUSSION
CERTAINLY GLAD TO BE PART OF IT
I THINK WE WENT ON CERTAINLY ASK
AND HOPE THAT THERE'S
CONSIDERATION BY THIS COMMITTEE
TO HAVE MORE DISCUSSION ABOUT
THE SCOPE OF THE AUDIT -- IF IT
IS TO MOVE FORWARD TO MAKE SURE
WE CAN DO ALL THE THINGS THAT
ARE DESIRED BY THIS COMMITTEE
AND THE LEGISLATURE THANK YOU.
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY FROM THE
PUBLIC IF YOU CAN KEEP YOUR
COMMENTS CONCISE.
WE APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU.
HELLO EVERYONE MY NAME IS ARE
YOU THOMAS ARM FROM THE YOU JUST
COALITION ALL IN ENGLISH
CALIFORNIA AND I'M HERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE JAYS A CPA
AUDIT REQUEST.
THIS ISSUE MATTERS TO ME BECAUSE
MY EXPERIENCE BEING ON PROBATION
FOR THREE YEARS FROM THE AGE
SIXTEEN OPUS EIGHT SCENE WAS A
VERY HUMILIATING EXPERIENCE.
DURING THE ENTIRE TIME I WAS ON
PROBATION I NEVER HAD A SUPPORT
AND ROLLING IN SCHOOL ONCE I WAS
KICKED OUT AND OUT OF SCHOOL FOR
MONTHS.
I WAS TOLD TO DO ANGER
MANAGEMENT CLASSES FOR HIGH RISK
HIGH NEEDS YOU BUT MY MOTHER
COULDN'T AFFORD.
THE FEES SO BASICALLY ALL I GOT
DURING THOSE THREE YEARS WAS
DRUG TESTED.
ARE YOU TELLING ME THAT THE
STATE SHOULD GIVE LA COUNTY
FORTY FORTY MILLION DOLLARS A
YEAR AS WELL MORE THAN SIXTY MY
AS OTHER COUNTRIES.
YOU DON'T WANT TO SEE HOW THEY
SPEND IT.
ON IF THE PROBATION DEPARTMENT
WE'RE USING MONEY RESPONSIBLY
THEY SHOULD SPONSOR THIS AUDIT
INSTEAD OF INSTEAD OF PUTTING
MORE MONEY INTO PROBATION WE
SHOULD PUT MORE MONEY INTO OUR
COMMUNITIES.
AND JOB CENTERS AND YOUTH
CENTERS NO THINGS THAT HELP US
IN LONG RUN SO I RESPECT I
RESPECTFULLY ASKS FOR YOUR A
VOTE.
THANK YOU.
ADDITIONAL PUBLIC COMMENT.
IRVING OUR IS WITH YOU JUST
COALITION AND BROTHERS ON
THEMSELVES COALITION -- TO AS A
PRODUCT OF SCHOOL TO PRISON
PIPELINE -- I MEAN SEVENTEEN
YEARS OLD I'M BEING ARRESTED FOR
LOITERING -- AND BEING ON
PROBATION FOR THREE YEARS WAS
SOMETHING THAT I NEVER SAW UP
CORRECT.
LOW DURING YOU KNOW HANGING OUT.
I WISH THE YOU KNOW I'M A
SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD ANY ANY KID
WOULD DO THAT HANG OUT YOU KNOW.
AND JUST BEING DRUG TESTED AND
PROBATION OFFICER PULLING UP TO
MY HOUSE EVERY HOUR WHEN HE
FEELS LIKE IT THAT'S ARREST ME.
YOU KNOW THAT'S NOT INVESTING IN
OUR YOUTH DOES NOT MAKE IN OUR
FUTURE ALL UP GROW AND BE BETTER.
THAT'S ACTUALLY HOLDING US BACK
IN -- NOT MAKING AS LEARN
ANYTHING BEHIND FOUR WALLS THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT LET ME TURN BACK.
TO THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER IF YOU'D
LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU AND I JUST JUST SAY A
FEW KEY THINGS ARM AT AS YOU
KNOW SHOULD CHEER YOU AND I CAME
IN A TWENTY TWELVE AND ONE OF
THE THINGS WE TALKED ABOUT WAS
OVERSIGHT.
AND BECAUSE WE HAD TWELVE YEARS
INSTEAD OF SIX WE'RE IN A
SEVENTY YEAR.
WE WOULD BE GONE.
THERE WOULD BE NOBODY.
THERE WOULD BE NO OVERSIGHT TO
WOULD BE NO DISCUSSION ABOUT
WHAT'S GOING ON THAT'S THE
BEAUTY OF THE INTELLIGENCE OF
THE ELECTORATE TO GIVE US TWELVE
YEARS.
A CITY WE HAVE THIS OPPORTUNITY
LOOK AT THINGS AND IS LISTEN TO
SOME OF THE DISCUSSION AND THE
WISDOM OF THE COUNTY. TO TO STOP
A PROGRAM THAT WAS NOT
FUNCTIONING -- FOR FOR MAYBE
TWENTY OR TEN YEARS IF THEY HAD
ONGOING OVERSIGHT LIKE THIS IT
MAY HAVE BEEN CAUGHT SOONER.
AND THAT'S WHY IT'S SO IMPORTANT
THE TO HAVE THIS OVERSIGHT MY
INTENT.
IS TO SH TO HIGHLIGHT.
THE GOOD THINGS THAT ARE
HAPPENING AND THE THINGS THAT
NEED IMPROVEMENT I DON'T SAY BAD
ADJUSTED THINGS THAT NEED
IMPROVEMENT TRY TO FIGURE THAT
OUT -- ANY REASON IT'S SO
IMPORTANT WE DO IT NOW.
AND WITH THE JUVENILE JUSTICE
SYSTEM IT BECAUSE THE GOVERNOR
OF THIS STATE.
HAS DECIDED THAT.
HE'S GOING TO TOTAL SEA CHANGE
IN THE WAY WE DO DEAL WITH
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM THEY'VE
TAKEN IT OUT THE CDC ARE AND
WE'RE TRYING TO DEVELOP.
WHAT THAT NEW PARADIGM WILL BE?
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT IS.
I THINK THIS AUDIT WILL HELP US
GET TO THAT THIS AUDIT WILL HELP
US LEARN HOW COUNTIES AND CITIES
AND AN SEC ALL WORK TOGETHER NOW.
AND AGAIN LOOK AT THE THINGS
THAT ACTUALLY WORK.
SO THAT WE CAN INCORPORATE THOSE
THINGS.
IN THIS NEW SYSTEM THAT GOVERNOR
NEWSOME -- PLANTS TO CREATE.
AND AND AND JUST JUST FINALLY
ONE OF THE FRUSTRATING THINGS.
THAT HAPPEN BEFORE ANY THE
PEOPLE THAT WERE HERE --
PROBABLY WERE INVOLVED -- I WAS
CHAIR BUDGET SUB.
FIVE I WAS ABLE TO GET A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS. FOR
REHABILITATION PROGRAMS.
AND IN TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN I
ASKED HOW.
THAT MONEY WAS SPENT -- AND
DIDN'T GET ANY RESPONSE THIS
LEGISLATURE DISASSEMBLY THIS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WAS IGNORED.
ON EVEN BY MY OWN COUNTY COUNTY
OF LA COULD NOT GET INFORMATION
ON HOW EFFECTIVE THESE PROGRAMS
WHAT HAPPENED TO THE MONEY WHERE
THE MONEY IS COULD NOT GET A
RESPONSE FROM MY OWN.
COUNTY.
THINK ABOUT I JUST SAID WE GAVE
THEM A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
AND I COULDN'T FIND OUT HOW THE
MONEY WAS SPENT IN MY HOME.
DISTRICT AND I GOT THE MUCH.
THAT'S WHY.
THIS AUDIT IS SO IMPORTANT THAT
WE GET THIS INFORMATION OUT SO
THAT. ONE THAT THIS LEGISLATURE
IS RESPECTED. TO THAT WE DO OUR
FIDUCIARY RESPONSIBILITY WHICH
IS TO HAVE OVERSIGHT.
WE NEED TO START DOING IT NOW.
WHEN A SEVENTY YEAR?
IF NOT NOW WHEN.
SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU THE ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GENSLER IT'S BEEN MOVED BY OUR
VICE CHAIR SENATOR ROBB SECONDED
BY.
ASSEMBLY WOMAN RUBIO --
MISTRANSLATED SHARE YOUR SENSE
BEEN ON THE ACCOUNTABILITY AND
OVERSIGHT THAT'S THE WHOLE POINT
OF THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE AUDIT
COMMITTEE IS FOR US TO PROVIDE
THAT ACCOUNTABILITY IN THAT
OVERSIGHT -- THE VOTERS DID GIVE
US GRANT US TWELVE YEARS UP TO
TWELVE YEARS TO SERVE.
AND WITH THAT I'LL BE SUPPORTING
THE AUDIT TODAY -- MISTER SECTOR
CALDERON.
THE MOTION IS TO APPROVE ATER
QUEST NUMBER TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN DASH ONE SIXTEEN
JUVENILE JUSTICE CRIME
PREVENTION ACT FUNDS BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JONES SAWYER.
SOME REMEMBER SALAS HI SALAS HI
BOERNER HORVATH.
BOERNER HORVATH I DEEP.
DEEP I PATTERSON [inaudible]
RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE VOEPEL.
VOEPEL I WOULD.
CENTER ROTH.
ROTH HI FOR JUST [inaudible]
GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG.
MONNING.
MONNING HI MOORLACH.
WIENER I WIENER AYE.
OKAY THAT'S PASSES WILL HOLD THE
ROLE FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
THANK YOU MISTER JONES SAWYER.
THE SERGEANTS IF YOU COULD CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS AS WE GO
THROUGH.
WE'RE GOING TO GO THROUGH EACH
OF THE ITEMS TO CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS THE FIRST.
ITEM IS THE MOTION TO CSUS TO
WAIVE COMMITTEE RULES THIRTEEN
AND FIFTEEN SO TO TAKE UP THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
I CAN ASK THE AUDIENCE TO PLEASE
QUIET DOWN WHILE WE CONDUCT.
TODAY'S COMMITTEE HEARING
BUSINESS.
SO THE FIRST -- ROLE WE'RE DOING
IS WAVING COMMITTEE RULES
THIRTEEN AND FIFTEEN SO THAT WE
CAN TAKE UP THE CONSENT CALENDAR
THE SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
PATTERSON [inaudible]
WOULD [inaudible]
SENATOR BARGES [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
MOORLACH.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO
THE CONSENT CALENDAR -- BUT
SECTOR CALL THE UP THE MEMBERS.
YOU CONSENT TOP CALENDAR CONCERT
CONSISTED OF AUDIT REQUEST
NUMBER TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN ONE
ELEVEN DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT.
MOBILE HOME PARK INSPECTIONS BY
SENATOR LEYVA TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN ONE TWELVE CALIFORNIA
STATE LOTTERY BY SENATOR CHIANG.
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN DASH ONE
NINETEEN LANGEVIN PETRI SHORT
ACT IMPLEMENTATION SENATOR STERN.
ABSENT MEMBERS PATTERSON
[inaudible]
WOULD [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
MOORLACH.
OKAY WITH THAT WE'RE GONNA MOVE
TO AGENDA ITEM NUMBER FOUR TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN DASH ONE ONE
THREE THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA ADMISSIONS POLICIES
AND PRACTICES.
STRUCTURE CALL THE ROLL.
DEEP I DEEP HIGH [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
RUBIO II [inaudible]
CENTER BARGES [inaudible]
HERTZBERG. FOR MORE LACK
[inaudible]
WIENER I WIENER AYE.
RIGHT NEXT WE'RE GONNA MOVE.
TO AGENDA ITEM NUMBER FIVE TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN DASH ONE
FOURTEEN CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY CAMPUS BASED STUDENT
FEES -- CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
DEEP [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
DEEP HI [inaudible]
BARGES [inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
CENTER WIENER.
WIENER AYE.
OKAY NEXT WE'RE GONNA MOVE.
TO GEN ITEM NUMBER [inaudible]
YES.
NOT CHEN ITEM NUMBER SIX TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN STATION CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
BOERNER HORVATH [inaudible]
DE HI [inaudible]
I SENATOR ROTH.
SKEWS ME CENTER BORDERS
[inaudible]
SENATOR HERTZBERG.
WE ARE ON ITEM OTTER QUESTS TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN DASH ONE
FIFTEEN DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR
VEHICLES FOR LIKE THE
IMPLEMENTATION BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SALAS [inaudible]
MORNING [inaudible]
MONNING NOW.
SENATOR WINNER NUMBER -- WINNER
NOW.
OKAY NEXT WE WILL MOVE TO AGENDA
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN DASH ONE SIXTEEN
JUVENILE JUSTICE CRIME
PREVENTION ACT FUNDS.
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
ASSEMBLYMEMBER PATTERSON.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD
[inaudible]
SENATOR BORDERS [inaudible]
SENATOR HERTZBERG.
CENTER HERTZBERG HIGH.
MORLOCK.
ALL RIGHT NEXT WE WILL MOVE TO
AGENDA ITEM NUMBER EIGHT TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN DASH ONE
EIGHTEEN CALIFORNIA LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES.
AUTOMATED LICENSE PLATE READERS
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
DEEP HI.
HI DE HI [inaudible]
CENTER HERTZBERG -- CENTER
HERTZBERG HIGH MORE LOCKED.
OKAY MEMBERS WITH CALL WENT
THROUGH EACH OF THE AGENDA ITEMS
WE WILL GO THROUGH ONCE MORE. TO
ALLOW THE ABSENT MEMBERS TO MAKE
THEIR WAY DOWN THE J. LACK AFTER
WHICH WE WILL CLOSE THE
COMMITTEE HEARING -- LET'S GO
THROUGH IT ONE MORE TIME.
MISTER SECRETARY LET'S START
WITH THE SUSPENSION OF THE RULES.
ARE WAVING COMMITTEE RULE
THIRTEEN FIFTEEN CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PATTERSON.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD
[inaudible]
SENATOR BARGES.
BORDERS I CENTER HERTZBERG.
CENTER HERTZBERG HIGH
[inaudible]
CENTER MOORLACH [inaudible]
THE NEXT.
AB THAT MOTION CARRIES -- WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO THE PROPOSED
CONSENT CALENDAR WITCHES AGENDA
ITEMS ONE TWO AND THREE TWENTY
NINETEEN DASH ONE ELEVEN
DEPARTMENT HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT MOBILE HOME PARK
INSPECTIONS BY SENATOR LEYVA.
TWENTY NINETEEN DASH ONE TWELVE
CALIFORNIA STATE LOTTERY BY
SENATOR CHIANG TWENTY NINETEEN
DASH ONE NINETEEN THE LAND
SHERMAN PETRIE-NORRIS ACT
IMPLEMENTATION BY SENATOR
STIRRED.
UP PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS MISTER SECRETARY
PATTERSON [inaudible]
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WOULD
[inaudible]
CENTER HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG HI SENATOR MOORLACH.
STATE TAX WILL MOVE TO AGENDA
THAT MOTION CARRIES -- WE WILL
MOVE TO AGENDA ITEM NUMBER FOUR
TWENTY NINETEEN DASH ONE
THIRTEEN UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA.
MISSION POLICIES AND PRACTICES
BY ASSEMBLY WOMAN BERNHARDT.
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS --
MISTER SECTOR CENTER BARGES.
BORDERS HI CENTER HERTZBERG.
CENTER MORE LOCKED.
MORE LIKE A HIGH.
THAT MOTION CARRIES I WILL MOVE
TO AGENDA ITEM NUMBER FIVE
TWENTY NINETEEN DASH ONE
FOURTEEN CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY CAMPUS BASED STUDENT
FEES BY ASSEMBLY WOMAN BURNER
**** BATH PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS SENATOR GORGEOUS.
CENTER BORDERS EYES CENTER
HERTZBERG.
CENTER HERTZBERG HI.
THAT MOTION CARRIES -- NEXT WE
WILL MOVE TO AGENDA ITEM NUMBER
SIX TWENTY NINETEEN DASH ONE
FIFTEEN DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR
VEHICLES REAL IDEA
IMPLEMENTATION.
AND THE SECTOR CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
SENATOR BORDERS.
CENTER BOARD JUST HI
[inaudible]
SENDER MINING.
OKAY.
THAT MOTION IS HELD IN COMMITTEE.
AGENDA ITEM NUMBER SEVEN TWENTY
NINETEEN DASH ONE SIXTEEN
JUVENILE JUSTICE CRIME
PREVENTION ACT FUNDS.
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES SAWYER.
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PATTERSON [inaudible]
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WOULD
[inaudible]
WOULD I CENTER BORDERS.
HE WOULD BE ABLE TO ITEM
[inaudible]
SEVEN JONES SAWYER [inaudible]
BY.
OR JUST HI [inaudible]
SENATOR MOORLACH.
SENATOR MOORLACH HI.
GEN ITEM NUMBER EIGHT TWENTY
NINETEEN DASH ONE EIGHTEEN
CALIFORNIA LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES AUTOMATED LICENSE PLATE
READERS BY SENATOR RAINER --
MISTER SECRETARY CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS CENTER MORLOCK.
SENATOR MOORLACH HI.
THE MOTION CARRIES.
LET'S GO.
TO ALLOW MISTER I BELIEVE MISTER
WOOD MISTER MOORE LOCKED NOW AT
ON'T.
WHICH MEASURES ARE WE GOING